Icey's in jail because she keeps trying to turn against me, it's fine.
She just a little brat that needs to be corrected, don't worry about it.
Okay, okay, mods, mods, mods, mod, I love you.
You don't have to ban every time, you can ban when somebody says Shibidi toilet, that's
fine.
You can't do it when it's like, they're just saying Shibidi, like that's whatever.
Cause like even like, hi Pookie!
Pookie's a little cute goat girl, she's very sweet and Toto is a tomboy tiger girl, also
very sweet.
I love all of my friends from my past life and my current life and I will do, so you
will see some names you probably don't recognize that are not Corpo being modded because they're
my friends.
No!
I fucking died!
Oh!
I literally gave her like the easiest fucking thing, oh no I didn't need to kill her!
My friends are my friends, I didn't fucking, I just harvester her name, no, I can't resurrect
her!
I accidentally my finger slipped and I hit square instead of x, oh my fucking god, don't
tell her, don't fucking tell her I did that, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I won't forgive you if you do.
Let's add some grass.
Okay, everybody's going to sleep, they're going to eat, we're going to do a little funeral
tomorrow for, not Azura, cause I cut her up, but it's fine, we have the cannibal tree,
I mostly wanted to eat you guys, I didn't want to eat the other girls.
Hi, Tony, so who?
I like how you only particularly said hello to some people, how do you think you, you
made those people feel really bad?
Why don't you say everybody's name?
Huh?
I'm about to start, I'm about to start cracking down on everybody.
I'm like, you know, I'll be nice first week. I'll be nice. I'll be nice. No more Mrs. Nice Sheepie
Cool, then our foodie would eat one day wake up. Very good. Okay, we got that we got that
We got that we're good. Okay. I got some wood. You got some wood
Although it's really awkward because like my friends I'm gonna be saying like some really like out-of-pocket shit and flirting with my chat because I'm a whore
So I apologize in advance
Boop boop boop boop boop boop
But uh, pookie kind of already knows that
She's been she's been watching I
Don't know why I'm planting hops when I don't have the beer thing yet
I have to wait I have to wait for everybody to wake up
Because they want to build up my faith before I go and I also want to do a devotion thingy
I'm just really quiet most dreams. That's fine. Um
Um
Mod
Mod, what did I say? I said if somebody says she be it's okay
It's when they say she be toilet and our fucking zoomers in my chat
Then you can fucking eat them
I'm gonna bow bow you
It's funny I used to never have mods
Like I never had mods before um, but you guys are just get out-of-pocket and you gotta be wrangled
It's like you're scared to speak like
Yes, the cult is out of starvation we are thriving we are you know having a great time like wrangling cats
Mmm, that's for sure something like that
Is this like
Hold on Misma, I'm so sorry. I have to do something
Money money money money must be funny. Let me do this first
Okay, I go. Oh, I have one of these. Oh, no, I don't I thought it was like saying red that I had one
Um
It's the ones I've already unlocked. Okay
Yeah, and I also
Right, what rights I also um, what should I call it?
I was gonna say belief in materialism or beliefs and we're gonna do materialism
Wait decorations
No, cuz a lot of the people in the cult or actually have the materialistic trait anyways
So cuz it said they would do better like a lot of the people have like them in the trait where like they do 50% more devotion
Oh
Cool
Bada bing bada boom
It's a cult grind set good, you know, you don't like jorgen out in the open
You're not a true follower if you don't like jorgen in public. Just just fucking whip it out and jorgen
Back from work and she'd be still streaming. Yes, I get
Ten hours, can we do ten hours? No, I'm not doing ten hours again. Maybe maybe who is whining
Okay, we can reeducate I see and let her out
Are they waiting in line for the bathroom cuz that's kind of cute looks as to this is serenity
Okay, let's release I see
Yeah, group draw this is this is the jorginate area. Okay, this is where everybody just jorges it
Okay, but I'm gonna upgrade people's stuff though. That is a good idea. Why is it so fucking overgrown over here?
I'm gonna my name on a
Okay
Yeah, see do I have materials to upgrade?
Okay, so I have that I didn't mean to roll away hello, so there's that collapse less often
Yeah, you guys are gonna have a communal jorging area
I'll play some in between
Okay, I need more blocks
So I'm gonna upgrade all those cuz I only need like a couple because there's only 14 of you
Any upgrade these two can I upgrade those
Did I unlock that yet? No, I didn't okay. I need to unlock that next. What the fuck am I thinking?
Okay, I mean make why is there like a bomb everywhere. Oh
I don't want to do that. I don't want to hit that
Why is it sparkling? I don't know. I'm just gonna
Go old shit
Yeah, that's full of poop
This is also full of poop though. I just cleaned it
Can I build another outhouse real quick? I
can
Put it right I put the prison right next to the
Um
House so everybody just shits right near him, you know
Wait, is this gonna make it that cuz I don't like it if it's uneven
I'm gonna freak out if it's uneven. We have a goon cave
Okay, this is the goon cave. So if you want to group goon or jorgin at session
Then you know, you can have a good time
We love goon in in this house
Perfect
Fabulous, I'll probably get another janitor. Do I have money for janitor station cuz I'll just make another one
No, I don't anymore that okay. I can just get that right now
Do another janitor what oh I only have one I thought I had four
You want a solo gooning session no, it's what my patreon audios are for
All right, I think we're good. Oh
And take a sip
Oh
Can you guys think of something other to say than ayo
I'll after while you release patreon audio honestly, I need to ask strawny cuz I think mine's
tomorrow
It's once a week. So it's four times a week
bio
She
Pardon
Pardon oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. See these are more creative everyone's so creative. Wow
See aren't you happy you get to make madame laugh
I
Sorry, give me a second. There was a stuffy
Money money money, that's me money
Oh, why did I fall asleep? Hello? That was tracking
Uh
You always make me laugh. Yeah when you're acting pathetic. I always love pathetic things
Uh, okay, my faith is going down. So I'm gonna so I beat that beat that beat that
Um
Eat that pussy up
Come here you bitches. So this is the last one I have to beat
But I'm always pathetic. Yes, I know you're that you're just funny because you
Literally don't
Do anything for anyone's life. Oh wait, hold on
Okay, cool, I just want to make sure that
The session was started properly for the crowd control, but yeah crowd control is on
Have fun
Is he trail? Oh sweet rolling into an enemy
Oh fun
Now if I press r2 I can just teleport back home
She's got a gun
Oh
Oh, that's kind of cool because I was rolling into him
I
Sick I like that. I like that skill. I need to buy more tarot cards
Which I may go up
I'm broke too bad
Did I freeze him?
She's got a gun
I hate sometimes if I like move barely it like will
um
I forgot the rocks don't break wool or break wool by touch for me
It like will aim it and not in the direction I wanted
Why I feel like this one should lead to somewhere, but it doesn't do the bombs hurt me my own bombs
I have a sawn off or a shot a shot a sawed off
Sawed off won't you? Okay, just roll into them
Yeah
What the what the heck is going on? What the fuck is going on? What the fuck is up kyle?
I'll step the fuck up kyle
Fucking die stop healing bitches
You
Why are these guys so strong for no reason
Like these should be dying a lot sooner. Yeah, I was rolled into that
Give me the fucking
Come here you fucking spiders
Meat must have meat
This is nice because
Because then I can collect silk and stuff because I think I can get like clothes for you guys
Okay, that bomb hit him good
One in doubt roll into him
She got that boom boom pow these bitch been dragging my style
I don't know how to unlock clothes yet. I probably have to purchase them before it starts dropping silk and shit
Oh wait, I didn't go this way
Kyle didn't step
That's one of my favorite vines
Stop the fuck up. Why am I missing so bad?
Sound like one of them said shit like oh shit
At least I can just roll into him
Keep rolling rolling rolling rolling what come on my tits
Like you're still fucking alive come on. I'm fucking missing because my thing isn't in the right way. Oh my god
Please I'm aiming. I'm a aiming straight ahead. Why is it at an angle? Do I have like stick drift or something?
I'm just walking through stuff
How's this work?
Hey, I'm just gonna stand right on you dammit
Hey white by the rocks of the dark sea at the foot of the strong sudden drop
Within the more pointed teeth beasts the stutter of the heart that stopped
In the psease
He was the fifth the fifth piss up piss piss up
I have a lisp of the old fifth our brother the one who waits back when he was known by the name Norenda
I don't know why that's actually difficult for me to do
You get the idea you got what you you can read it
You understand
You already said oh, I don't do I need
No kamikaze
Kamikaze zombie
Oh, no
I gotta kill you. Oh, no
Oh, you'll be missed. You'll be not missed at all actually
Hmm delicious
Sometimes you just gotta put, you know trash in their place
Whoo, I just got a fucking shiver
Monday Monday Monday
Wait, why are there two?
Okay, there's that can I I want to I want to I like to clear on the first run every room
Can I other bodies in there can I eat them?
Let the bodies hit the floor let the bodies hit the floor. Oh, I can't growl
Beaten why for why for
Can't
Take much
More
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Now one nothing wrong with me two nothing wrong with me three
Nothing fuck
Nothing wrong with me
Something's got to give please something's got to give
Let the boys. Let's hit the floor. Let the boys. Let's hit the floor. Let the boys
Let's do it
I don't know what comes after four
Wait, I was like moving in slow motion for a second. Can I do that again?
All right
Fits considering this game involves death all the time. It's precisely
I don't have to break up these skeleton homes. Oh, perfect. The bomb helps
Okay, I actually fucking hate this blunder bus. I would rather or something else
What is that?
Um
Oh, I can get clothes. That's right. Let me go here. I was gonna go get a relic, but I need clothes more
Hi, you're the cute little silkworm
Darling you look so
Drab if that's how you dress how ugly are your followers
Luckily I sell patterns for the finest fashions. It's a family business except for stupid bob
Don't mind me. Just think about how my no good brother left us all behind
Anywho, you'll need somewhere to craft these dawdling designs
Maybe you should look into this
Oh my god, thank y'all
I don't care
Oh
Zellie no Zellie's dissenting
Zellie stopped dissenting. It's literally her and icy
Oh
Um
There's a lot of hearts over here the hell
Oh
Well, I'd say follower waiting for indoctrination when I already I I didn't save anybody
Okay
Fashion is pain, you know like passion for fashion. What is this? I don't know what this is
Does that do something for them?
Does it do something for me when I kill them? I'm just gonna keep rolling into you motherfuckers. She better doesn't do a lot of damage
Nope, I don't have any
I don't have any I don't have any fava
I don't have any fava
Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Please aim down
Jesus krim
Give me a different weapon
Thank you
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Give me that months. Give me that money
Sh money and I'm just gonna run into rocks because hopefully then they will make rocks
Make stone for me. I wish I would do that for everything like a bunch of
Wow, it's literally doesn't drop any rocks. What's up with that?
I
How is she bad at call of the lamb what?
Would you love your followers if they were worm it'd be easier for to step on you if you were worm
IDK what the random relic gave you but you got one. Um, I don't have a relic. I think it didn't queue properly
Because I never I never had a relic in the bottom corner
I
Short range weapon for a roguelike. No, I like this
Yeah, using a sword is so much better. I can't aim with the thing properly
Okay
Oh, she beats bad at call of the lamb. Oh, bitch and moan bitch and moan. Oh, oh my god. I'm such a little whiny fuck
Jesus you ever get tired of hearing your own voice. So I get tired of hearing your voice
I missed
Oh
Now my nose
How do you guys skitter around so fast come here. Thank you
Hmm, okay, I think the sleep where's the sleep
I don't even know what hit me. Oh problem one of them landing hit me
Oh, if you don't destroy it, it'd be they spawn more
That makes sense
It's supposed to show up in the corner. Oh, I can see what's cued up in the top, but it's very small
All right, I don't need to go that way yet
I
Like madams voice
They're spootish they're supposed to skitter
Wow, I missed like two rooms. Oh, no, it was just one
Stop starving
After this run, I'm gonna go back
Do I talk to the tree first? Okay, no, I just chopped down
And usually the tree also gives me something chop chop chop chop
What do they mean by chopping wood? That's crazy
Sometimes I shit out a bomb and it just actually legit
Scares me a little bit because I forgot I keep forgetting I have that ability. Where am I going?
Oh
I made you decide to play call the lamb because I like the game
You freeze oh what the hell I really can't tell what's happening right now. Oh babies
Oh
Oh, he hits me pretty well
Oh and you shoot out little
So
Okay, that does freeze him for a second
I can't really tell what's happening
Damn it was hoping on land before the bomb
I see mo we did it meow meow meow meow meow meow meow
Easy clap easy clap
Yeah
Take a sip of tea
So fuck
There we go, I don't know why I covered to my keyboard suddenly
Hmm
I could use some more wood I could always use a little bit more wood sugar. I don't really care about these. I have a lot of bones
Let's go
Cool beans
Oh
Gee that's what I sound like when I whimper this game looks like enter the gungeon
It's made by the same people who would have fucking thunk
Oh my followers are starving. Oh no poor babies
I
Who is this fucking dude
Who said you could eat oh it's fucking zelly
Oh
Oh, I forget when they eat
Follower meat, they'll actually stop dissenting which is kind of weird. Okay, this will be
Mamosa
And I kind of want her to stay a worm, but isn't she like a white fox
We'll see I can choose different roads. See you guys can have different outfits. Oh my god
Isn't that cute? Oh my god, please back. Um
Um, let's see. Let's see. I kind of really want to keep her as a worm
Yes, she's gonna be my little worm
What a variant of worm
I can give her a fat neck. No, I'm gonna give her a little swirly on her head
She's a she's celibate. Okay. She's gullible. She's terrified of death
Are we all deep down?
Um, I'm a mosa you can
You can
worship
This will be marrow
And marrow is a little is she a jellyfish
Sometimes this doesn't want to work. Um, I don't have a jellyfish
Show you're gonna be a normal fish
I can make a little crab
Can make a little axolotl
I actually totally forget what
Because this is I would probably pick this one. Um, because that one's the one
I make a little axolotl
And she's like pinky blue
That's got pinky blue
Yeah, why not she's also celibate and she's a natural skeptic
Just a crispy fish
Crabs and jellyfish should break through the same thing. Yeah, you're right. All right
Everybody's mad. I have to fucking tell her to do something. Why don't you go work on a farm? Um, everybody get in here
Stop dying
Get the fucking here bitches stop looking so angie
Wait, I have a cow in my
See a little ritual
Um
We do we have we have do we have a funeral for mercy?
I don't know flowers. That's weird. I'm surprised. I don't know flowers. Um
Bonfire they look so his all
Oh
Are you guys happy now?
Get rid of this little pop up here
Lovely give me your fucking money
Hey guys are hungry. Let me cook you up something nice can oh jesus christ can wonder oh you guys
Didn't eat already. Okay
Oh, I see is elderly she's gonna die soon, but it's okay because we'll just resurrect her
Your followers are no longer starving. Yes, I know look at all this beautiful produce we have
You know what this calls for I think
Let's do
Let's do a no, let's do a stone. No that one doesn't make any sense. We'll do
Kind of want to make this look cool
Oh, uh, that's fine
Oh
Fuck
Yeah, let me just fill her in
Just fill her in just fill you know this looked a lot better in my head
I don't like it
Never mind
No
I press cancel
Get rid of it get rid of it
Fuck I fucked it up
It's actually very hard to remove stuff when there's stuff with the stuff
Uh
Mistakes were made who we learn
Okay, it's good
I just I wish I could cut all this grass
Hey, it's for horses not for cows pigs don't eat it because they don't know how though pigs are very smart
Wow, maybe I should go fishing I'll make like one more meal
Make one meal for myself and then
Cool
Oh
Emmys elderly too all the girls are getting old what the sigma
All right, what if we
Who is all my people who are super fucking ah
Why can't why can't I decrease your age?
Oh
Why do you have to be elderly?
All right
Get out there champ. Go get us some meat
I'm leaving you
Have a good time. All right, and I'll summon a demon because I haven't been doing that
Automatically collect drop fervor
To projectile
I
Don't think so
Takes our home
There yeah, there is a charm that prevents them from aging, but I didn't give it to them
I gave them a different job
Okay, you know, I'm I think we're in a good place I am going to okay. What do you want dude?
Oh, you're the son of bitch. I timed out for 24 hours. Um, no, we're not gonna make them eat poop you fucking idiot
I
Got a maid dress
Oh, baby
All you guys are gonna be dressed up as maids. I can't wait
Holy shit male little personal little maids. Oh boy my little boy maids
Wow
Yeah, I didn't mock those yet because I'm stupid
I'm so close. I'm so close yet so far away
I
Need some camilla might get another seed thing
Please so close
Who can I take in confession confess everybody type your confessions in the chat
Type your confessions
Why is there a sheep?
I'm your fool why you guys biting your nails something the matter you're scared
Oh
Amy's gonna die soon
RIP to Amy going to die soon
It's okay, we'll just bring her back
Anyone know I bother repairing that
Um, because I'll take these
I
Make some
Oh, yeah, I just don't desperately might make two more refineries
All right, let's do
So I can make a mating tent drum circle drink house where's the cook fire
There's a cook fire not around here
Did I not unlock it
Am I tripping or was there another cooking thing it must be up here? Oh, yeah, it's right here. It's under kitchen
It's this bone decorations fun
Kind of unlock the tailor, but it's not really a priority right now
Um, I kind of have enough research to cheaper rituals
Um
What the fuck my chat just disappeared. Uh, you guys alive
Okay, weird
Hmm ritual cooldowns
Oh, I should have done this one not the other one god damn it
Oh
No, I need to I need to do the
Oh the lumber yard and this are under that are you serious? I could have sworn they were lower
What the fuck fine
This skill tree in this game is like absurdly huge
Oh
Oh, no here let's pay respects to mercy while we're here
She this is it's what she would have wanted it's what she would have wanted
Okay
Make another one of these put it like right here
Um
Do I love people too
Hell yeah
See you put some more here for some more of that
For some more of that
I don't like that
What's up marrow
Later it's getting too relaxed around here. We need a curse. Do you want to do a fast sure
All right, no food for any of you bitches
It's fast in time
It's funny because it just like cancels it out
No, I don't have a lot of faith. Well, this is awkward. Um
Either way it would have fucked me because I would have had no faith and faith
Okay, can I have my faith back? Oh, thank you
Okay, let me
Hmm. All right. I already kind of busy and doing the thing. I think we're good
Uh faith's kind of down, but it's fine. Don't worry about that
You guys
There's no faith in me don't know what's up with that actually I want to play some am I supposed to do
Whoa, it's got really dark
I'll walk taylor and build a taylor. Yeah, I don't care about that right now. Not the priority
And then she fasted over everything
Oh
Okay
Yoy
Okay, cool
See I'm so proud of myself. I'm being chill
I'm being normal because you know
YouTube people are gonna see this you'd be like, wow, we should monetize our channel
Got the minus touch
The minus touch
Everything's golden everything is golden. How's that? Who sings that song? It's Akari. Awesome. Can I like break this?
This isn't why you made out like fucking butter
I am the most wholesome vtuber. What do you want? Oh, thank you for all this stuff
I'm not gonna read that in that voice again. I'm just too lazy
Oh
It's like very um
On intelligible whispers and it's giving me ASMR right now
Why would the fuck fuck you?
At least I can hit you in like one thing
If I could aim no, oh, I'll get you eventually. I'll get you eventually. Don't you worry about it
Oh
Oh, you're fucking huge and I don't have the rolling thing anymore. Ah get away from me get away
Hammer is too slow you guys healing me
What this fucking bitch
Just quish
Pagan god ASMR win good question. Why is he so big? Why are you so huge? I didn't expect it
Still not the biggest I've taken but you know
Why didn't I walk into that?
Ah
I miss it's so close quarters. It's actually really hard and with the hammer. It's just not good
There we go
All right
Top things I've never heard why there's so many guys with fucking guns in here
No guns swords whatever. Thank you for the halt
Oh
Okay, I feel like I want to go this way
What
Oh, it's tarot card guy usually here
He's like, uh, you're you got fucking tarot cards. You don't need me. All right later, dude
What the hell is this
Be not afraid
Oh, I just hoping to get out of the way in time
Be not afraid what are you going dude?
What this oh mosaic. Oh
Tarot card guy don't go don't go tarot guy
You're just gonna keep healing him. I don't the fuck here come up up here
You're gonna fucking I didn't point that way. I'm not pointing that way off
Just actually perish like actually fucking kill yourself
In cult of the lamb
Wait, that was like a huge spider corpse. I like how the spider has bones
Oh a skull pile what I've always wanted
I've always wanted a skull pile
What the hell am I doing? Uh, I think a gold
Uh
Okay
Well this way because I'll get gold in a relic because I don't really see if the other relic is nice
Oh, well looking only us
Get grass
Just because I use that to fill the uh
Try and go this way
We'll need to look in here. I wish I had an uncrustable this
Lightning uh, actually I prefer the poison
Oh have it yes
Yes, no, I only have 11 dollars to my name
Uh anyways, I'm gonna
Oh
He doesn't do anything when I do this so just gonna
Your followers are dead and tied up so I'm gonna eat them
Can I hit you? I'll fight you right now
Like he doesn't do anything about it like fucking do something about it, bro
I
Wanted to ask your headcanon about the wonderland hotel, but if you claim the idea that just makes it canon
What what do you mean like be more specific
What particular headcanon did you have a question about?
Wonderland is a hotel. We offer lots of different amenities. You we have spas. We have a bar
um
We have um a restaurant in-house
Um, there are places below level that offer different experiences
We offer like kind of like
You know a unique
There's also like companionship like there's uh, there's like a hostess
There's a hostess place downstairs called the garden. Yeah
Um, the girls are dressed like uh bunnies. It's pretty cool
You
Pretty nice. Oh, you're still alive it sometimes you blend in the fucking stuff. Okay
Hostel garden, yeah, you can spend time we have a lot of different amenities. We have a concierge
We have a valet
Um, we have really nice places nearby if you like wanted to know more about that
Um, we're also a sex club
But you know
It's fine
Get off my jock back to fuck up
I'm gonna go down first
Yeah, sauna is really nice. We have a whole spa. It's gorgeous. You would love it. What the hell is that? Oh, sweet
Am I playing fucking one?
Fucking snake over here
I had to shot that guy with a tentacle
Um
We don't have a casino in house, but there is one next door
Um, it is under my jurisdiction. Um, it has a different name
The casino is called, um
Uh
I don't know. I think my name the restaurant's called Jabba walkie. No, I'm kidding
Oh my god
Guys are synced up
I need some more Alice in Wonderland reference ideas
Oh
Yeah, we have the jabba walk because I said Jabba walkie and I'm like, no that just sounds like the dance crew
They do come sometimes and do a show
Oh, what's this decrease in size? I don't really care about
I will take this beat though
Thank you for the meat
Man, did you just like stop showing up to give me a relics or something?
How does he get so many people to die for him so often? What's what's his deal? I want to know what his story is
Queen of hearts for the oh, yes. Yes. Yes. I like that. We'll call it the queen of hearts
When the man on the chess board get up and tell you where to go
And your mind is just some kind of mushroom
Yeah, I can remember the last probably
I'll fucking keep walking into that shit
Remember
You want the door my son
Need your hand
Can I have something divine blast? Oh
Zoke mine you fuck can do love
treasure cat club
That's the name of the dance club. That's because we have a dance club in house
um
The dance club is in house and it is called it's called uh the treasure cat club or the ccc not the kkk the ccc
Some people off-hand they call it hey do you want to go in triple C?
So it's pretty cool
Mad hatter slots
Like no not like that. Um, yeah, I like queen of hearts
For the for the casino
Um, what should be the name of the restaurant? I was thinking like the tea party, but like was it like the fucking boston tea party?
Please get away from me get away from me
I was not paying attention. I was more focused. I was actually i'm like actively thinking about what to name stuff
Did you hear that? Oh, the sun's gonna be stuck in my head
Silly's no longer a demon
Why oh serenity
Serenity baby girl. I gotta lock you up
I'm waking up
Oh
What's up zelly yeah, I know this I know this already
me
All time
Wow
Mad hattery creamy but the mad hattery that's actually pretty cool, but like
Yeah, there's a fashion boutique on one of the floors if you like forgot something at home
We special in swimwear you specialize in swimwear rather
Oh, I didn't mean to press that come back here you sons of bitches
I'm killing one of you
And it's gonna be this guy just because he disrespected me earlier
Oh
Sacrifice toto, what do you mean? I bless the ring. Oh, I'm like, why did this just pop up? Um
It's probably me. Yeah, it's the phantom one. Um, this is an
All right. All right. All right. All right
Do I want more weapons or do I want more curses?
You know, I did have more focus of like a weapon run last time I played this game
Oh, I press R1. Um, and I would prefer actually
Let's let's have some curses more
Ahuka lounge
Ahuka smoking caterpillar
How do I not have enough
Okay, let me guys are still fucking angry
Flowers are still blooming so I can't I don't have any camilla flowers
I see no
Oh, I see. Oh god. Oh, I'm so sorry
Oh
Oh, that's fucking cool actually. Hello
Nice
Mamosa, why do you have to fuck it up for us? I don't have to make food
People are gonna leave my call if I don't do something guys
I don't need a sermon
Oh, that's not what I wanted to press either
Why do I feel like I had so many more things unlocked before it's because I don't
It's because I'm not I'm not interacting with you guys a lot in terms of like the actual
Little like I should be talking to you more
Like I can just murder you
Oh
Everybody's so mad it's like happily put something in there. Oh, I need I need the camilla flowers
I don't have enough money money money money
I don't really need that. Yeah, it's whatever
I
Can these grow faster like I just need these to grow faster
Can you make them more happy I have to do like a ritual or do a sermon but like
I can't really do that because I don't have the means to do so so kind of sucks. So some of you will probably leave
I
Need to
If people leave I'm just gonna open up the thing where you guys can use your coins to oh my fucking god, um
To join the cult
That's very odd
Why are they crying blood
Why do you look so fucking weird
Don't want me to give you yeah, why not
Oh
Well fuck
Oh if I give money they'll give me back more. Okay interesting. I feel like I was just scammed. Can you stop popping up?
Oh
So if I
Okay
Oh
I don't know why I'm looking at this when I don't really have any oh, oh, I
Huh, I like this one
Coolio, can I like kill some of you guys and
Look at this. I don't care about any of that
I
Can sacrifice one of you
What happens if I sacrifice you
All right, one of you guys is dying
I
Don't know who this is, but it's you. Oh wait. No, this is just like one of the random
Things random characters
Oh, it looks so sad. Oh shit
Oh
Okay
So I just can well
Who's next
Oh you
You
Dang we mean nothing to she be yeah, cuz you're trash. What do you expect?
Fabulous wow
Thank you so much. Oh my god
Anyway, so who wants to join my call on opening applications now, um, hold on
Let me change that
Let's see, let's see
Add yourself to the cult wow
Go on and add yourself if you'd like
To delay
Okay, cool
You know you want to join come on
Come on
Just click the link above and join come on
I'm not gonna eat you talking about
Oh
I take such good care of you such good care of you
Um, let's see
Double damage
I
What I want like some of these I'm like no
I don't know which one to pick
I don't take double damage
It was to wait did the price change on it because I didn't touch the prices on anything. I'll be honest with you
Um, what was the price last time if people can remember?
I literally just turned it on I didn't change anything
Um, let me go to effect manager and what were that for you all?
It was not two coins
It was 250
That's so why the fuck is it two thousand the hell I don't even think people
get
2000 coins
Oh
Very cool
What the fuck how much is the thousand how much is two thousand coins and
I'm sorry guys. I didn't know what happened
First I'm like, why aren't people saying two thousand because I'm looking that I'm looking at it. I'm like, oh, yeah, there's an extra zero there
Okay
And
We're getting rid of it now there's too many of you
Oh my god
I'm gonna have to make more beds
Wait, hold on. Oh, fuck. I shouldn't have done a sermon until I whatever it's fine
I
Everybody would just be fucking mad anyways
20 bucks Jesus, I'm so sorry
Oh my god, please tell me you lived
Oh, thank god, thank you for the meat
Okay, are these done yet? Give me give me these I only got three
I need to buy more seeds
Now we can do a ritual
Actually before that I'm gonna I'm gonna let you all here. Oh wait, are you guys already here?
Wait
None of you guys showed up
Sure
It's cute, okay, why the fuck is it cute?
Let me see if I can adjust because I swear was
Really weird like before I would show like more information besides like a tiny ass little thing
Okay, let me see
I'm like really pissed at myself that somehow it became 2000 the fuck. I don't know how that happened
Option nope, that's not it
Compact mode
Off make it bigger
Make it bigger
Cute effects we're gonna disable cute you guys should all just show up now
Oh mine has worn out of stone
Um wait, I think that just fucking disables the queue in general. Why is this so confusing?
I made this bigger
We don't have to show the coins
Oh, it's fine. I'll back mode minimal preset. I almost know how to cut it. Okay
How do I see?
It doesn't still show a lot. It still shows it like small
Oh, do I need to refresh it maybe
Okay, we'll see how that works
I
Let's see
It got refunded fuck. I am a Sathari
I'm just gonna keep the person out of
Enable again, no wait, can you guys do it?
Can you guys do it?
Can you open oh, that's right
That's right. I need to reopen followers. Hold on. Hold on
Hold on
Fuck me
Oh my god crowd control literally just fucking blanked out
Oh, sometimes it bugs out have to restart it. Yep, that works now
Oh my god, it actually logged me out of crowd control I might have
Sorry I feel logged back in
Having fun. Yes, of course. I always love being a cult leader
What the heck why isn't it working now?
Well, it's fun until crowd control stopped working properly and I forgot to turn back on at followers
It's probably pause the game, but you know, I look like the edge
Stop whining
Stop whining that you're faithless
I
Did it log me out let me in let me in
Oh my god, it's literally not working game
Session
Okay, okay, okay, we're back add yourself to the cult save boom
Oh my god, okay, stop. Holy fuck. Holy fuck. Holy fuck. Stop. Stop. Stop
So fucking many of you stop
Oh my god
Now I don't have enough beds
I'll do that in a moment. Let's um
Who is oh
Serenity stop crying
Oh
Jesus Christ, it's Jason boom. Okay now I gotta make y'all food
Eat up your little booty holes
Hope you like my cooking
There is poop on the ground very much
Out of cauliflower seeds
I'm gonna buy some cauliflower seeds
Oh, look at all you praying
Yeah, yeah now we're cooking with yeah, oh fuck
Okay, um, um, I'm gonna start upgrading everybody's
Shalters
Oh
Nobody talked to me go away what do I need?
Why do I oh cuz they need to be this first
Can I not make more oh I need more money
How what can I sell?
I need money give me money
I need to make more beds
I'll be sure that okay, what if I make more gold bars
I don't have enough money
I can't sell the gold bars
Yeah, so everybody going uh, uh, what's happening?
I'm waking up fuck
I need money. Oh, I need to release you
I didn't mean to talk to Zelle. Oh, thank you
Oh, I need to go buy some seed wake me up wake me up inside
Fuck since sister just died
Save me save me from the
I don't remember the lyrics in the
Mid my blood to rise
Or I come undone
Time to eat her body and may come
Jizz all over the place till it's all on your face. Have a great day. We're
Fucking
dumb
The secret seven member of you there come forth my flock in prospa
Glorious day
If I like is there like a max amount of people I can have
In this game for like followers
As I'm kind of tempted to just like
Will be the big like 50 of you
Oh
At least all of you are just praying oh holy shit, um
Okay
Oh my god, I can't wait to make a cooking fire so you guys can leave me alone
In fact, I'm gonna go oh, I must miss that I'm going to go heat up some soup I got from olive garden
We can just hang out and chat for a bit
Like how the eyes are just full of flames
Rise up for sheepy
No bread. Yeah, I got some bread. They gave me 12 breadsticks. You think I ate them all yesterday. Jesus fuck
No
I had to
You I'm gonna throw them in the air fryer because it toasts to them. He he
He beat boo boo. Oh, they're sleeping on the ground. Okay, hold on
Oh, I don't have money for bread beds. I am oh, but I can make
You make one of these
I can make you. Why isn't me out of shit?
Here I'll do
Right here
Look at that wake up
Don't be mad
Oh wait, you guys I can't wake you up because I have to build it first
Help me build this
And then you can sleep in it
You're so tired looking
I got the Zupa Tascana soup
The Zupa Tascana why do your breadsticks in your air fryer is chilling?
What do you mean there's no I know there's not enough beds
Oh, I now have enough beds. Okay, then tell everybody to wake up
Wake up
Okay, now they're finally all waking up
I make
I can only upgrade
We go to go to bed, dude
I was just I was just telling you
I was waking you up to go to bed. Um
This guy is stealing a fucking rock
Like a weirdo
There is shit on the ground
Did you these things fucking eat everything? Oh, then they all just
Okay
They all just uh spazed out there. What is happening? Is everything just like staying in the same spot for some reason?
Wake up everybody. It's time for your daily
Flogging
Let's do a sermon. Oh money. Oh, thank god
I need to make more doctrines
Yay, um person with the guide
Why not
Oh
Unlocked all the curses sick
Everybody having a great day. Oh my gosh, perfect. Oh
Lovely and come back here
Come back here
We're gonna have
A funeral
I
We gather here today
To remember
strongy
She's been dead for quite some time now, so it's fair that we give her a proper burial her body is sticking out of the coffin
Bagpipe noises
Bad bagpipe noises
You'll miss you dearly momay
You did so much for this world
We'll never forget it
Thank you for raising me up to the be the best doctor that I could be
That's all I've ever asked for
To make you proud mother. Thank you
Hey
Everybody's so happy everybody's so happy
Anyway, it's time to eat. I see actually I don't want to do that
Um, I'd rather
I
Like I said, I'm gonna get up and eat my soup, but I always just get distracted by
Trying to make sure I can
Leave in a good spot, but then I'm never satisfied
Come here
I
Need to do more things to level them up. Let me uh, let me level up serenity
Wait serenity he's fucking old now. Wait a second
Because then every time I do a confession I can usually get somebody to be
Oh, fuck it didn't work. Um, if I give her something for she
I don't want to intimidate her. I just want to ask her I can't give her a gift
I can just kill her
I should have okay, I shouldn't have picked her I think somebody else
Is there a like a place I can have a deposit that all right now I have money
You build another bed I can't anymore gold
Okay, um
That's not what I wanted to do
I'll make one bed roll
Oh, fuck it like doesn't fit
No
This is what a wattage. I don't like this that works. All right, one of you guys get to that
Scotland forever
Oh
My god, I hate it here
Thank god for that. Thank god for so I could collect tides from everybody like I go around and shake people down for their money, but
I don't know
Doesn't sit right with me. Love. I don't get fucking care. It's a video game
Oh my game just
Cool like a serenity live in life
live in like Larry
And all this wood
I always end up running out of something
I
Like I'm glowing a little bit
Because everybody looks so suspect
All right, can you guys fucking work
Can you would go refine some materials and can you also
Do some fucking work Jonathan Hanley. Why do you use your full fucking name like a weirdo?
Oh
What just happened I don't know what that does
Okay, all right, we're fine look at this fucking do with the helmet with this fucking ah
Look at this fucking turtle ass head. That's hilarious
It's Ellie
Oh, I have like a perfect amount of followers to I didn't mean to go in here
Uh
Wow, you guys are all like really fucking low levels. Okay, whoever don't die. I'm gonna send you out for meat
You should be fine
Are you an owl what the fuck is that
Do you guys get to pick what your character looks like or do you just spawn in like that?
We have a little we got a little thing going on you get to pick. Okay, cool. All these species
That's nifty
That's so that's paused
Oh, I just like popped my collarbone. Hello color
Okay, I'm gonna go
And make some soup
You
Okay, get up what the hell I was like couldn't toward it in the weirdest position
I also got some dip in sauce for the breadsticks if you want I don't mind sharing
Do you not want this exploding a little bit my microwave now do we
until we
My boobies are very soul
But two breadsticks
When I was taking out the trash this morning when I was
And my trash is still like the bag with the breadsticks coming I was like
Oh
That's a good tea that's a good tea sis
Don't you hate it like you put something on my way
Everybody
Okay
See what's going on
How do you pop her collarbone? Uh, I like twist a certain way and it just like makes a popping noise. I don't know
Tell you
You're going great after watching the collab. Are you asking us or the cats? I'm asking you guys
Raina's by my feet in her bed when we swapping around
Where's the little girl she she hanging out
Weirdest places like I have all these cat beds as she sleeps on the back of the rug behind the door in my bathroom
I don't
Why
Oh
I don't mind the way the dip in sauce
I
Little bit of dinner
Ow, boomi
Sometimes he puts his paws up on my legs but has his claws out stretches in their parts
I
Love love love love does your bra foot well it might be it not on my bra spit well
It's hard for me to find bras
They usually don't carry my size in those places because when I take service on the home gun
Usually after that that's why I like the
um
Rihanna place because they have like like that long drink
It looks like that is
Not all places carry e-cups
And it honestly it varies from like
Um
brand to brand because like I'll wear like an airy bra
And
Their biggest will like sort of fit me and I'll wear a victoria's eager bra other bras
Don't fit me and then I'll wear savages 20 bra and those bras are fine
Yeah, that's such a pain
I got my soup it tastes delicious. I got my breadsticks
Looks like I'm ready to get boys
I
I thought you can see me fucking chewing
Do the background music for that this one tastes delicious
I didn't go all your booty. It's so funny how like
What people like how people's opinions change on body types
Because I remember like early 2000s
It was like awesome if you were like anorexically thin
And now it's like and then after that a little bit later 2000s like you need huge titties and now it's like you need a huge ass
It's like so funny to me
Or fish it in Japanese
Damn have to leave for work right as yeah
Sorry you might miss out on the appage
99 are you happy?
I want to accidentally put something on my keyboard so I can move this on the way
I don't even know what to yap about I don't have any idea what to yap about right now
I think all my energy
Was stolen from the collab and just laughing so hard
I
She be out of yab
It happens
Madam do you happen to work in tech my phone's flashing a green tint? I don't know what that means
Oh like your phone screen. Do you have a android or an apple device?
The club was oh the club was hilarious. Please watch the vod
Is an apple did you drop it?
If it's flashing a green tint you probably have to take it to the junior bar
Because it sounds like you might have loosened a cable
I hope you have apple care bro
It's apple care, you know screen replacement is
29 bucks, but um, I think depending on the model it's way more than that
I apple care on my phone because I drop that shit all the time
I
For the low price of your soul
I know Mike's you tweaking well, yeah, because we were tweaking so we were gonna peak like hell
Club was fire if you haven't seen it watch it now if you have watch it again
Yeah, we couldn't and we didn't end up doing a power wash simulator because nothing was working
So I was like, all right, we're gonna play this. Oh, we don't have that game. Okay, we're gonna play this
Okay, we don't have that game
All right, play this. Okay. We don't know if that would work properly because we don't have time to set it all up and make
Sure, it's fine. Although then we did guard dick phone. It was worked out worked out
The boys is back. Are you serious? What?
I fucking love that show the boys came back. Okay. I have to watch that then probably watch that tonight
It's the last season
I thought they were doing five seasons. I know they already got renewed for a fifth season even after this fourth one was released
I'm so excited. I I'm so fucking it's that's funny. So I have a guilty pleasure of watching like really cheesy romance shows like
Um, so I've been watching like exo kitty on netflix was about like this
half korean half white girl who goes to
Korea to be closer with her mom
And also see like her long-distance boyfriend or whatever
But then he figures she figures out that he's like cheating or whatever the fuck it's a long story
Um, but they use the same exact school as in gen v
And so they break into like the principal's office in one scene and i'm like wait a fucking second
This is the same principal office from gen v. I was like, huh?
Um, I was just really i'm really amused by that because the juxtaposition of those two shows is quite amusing. Um
And but i'm really bummed that actor died because I i really like that actor. He was really good at sabrina
Um, he was really good in gen v. I really want to see his character develop more and it really just sucks
He died in a um the actor that played the guy with magnetic powers
Uh, I can't remember off the top of my head. Uh, he died in a motorcycle accident
It's really sad
Reminds me of the guy from star trek who
Um, he was like had that thick accent, but he was also in a couple other things
Um, and he got
Crushed by his own vehicle. It like squeezed him between a gate
And he was squeezed between a gate in his car and died like that's
It's so sad like oh, what a way to go. So there's great talent gone
Especially they were both young
Yeah, like um like my uncle has a motorcycle
And I have like my cousin uh, he's he's really into dirt bikes and I always like worry for them, but it's like
It is what like it is a dangerous hobby as long as you can take all the right precautions
And it can still be not your fault or something can still happen and you know, that's the same with a car, you know
Yeah
Oh my god, the soup is so good. It's a little bit too salty though
But I'm so I have to watch that then I like
I like what was it did somebody make like a reference to like
Oh, that's right in that video that someone made a memes of our um
Of our debuts and 2.0's they like used a couple the boys memes with like, uh the deep
And like strutty and like um octopuses octopi whatever and stuff and I was like I was like wait
Why was I thinking of the deep the other day?
Every time I think about
That actor I just laugh because he plays the deep and then he also plays the main love interest in gossip girl and I just
Sends me every time I'm tense. I'm gone
Anton Yelkin. Yes. Yes, uh russian peas. He was young too
He was really good in star trek and he was also in like, um odd thomas. That was the movie
You want me to have you want me to have a alt alt account? Uh reaction to the boys
The deep and strong use a scary ass combination you're right
Sup sup sup
But I just look it was like making jokes about like the octopus and the deep
Strani is the octopus and the reeflings are the deep
And his original girlfriend the deeps girlfriend is um reeflings
Current girlfriends and they're leaving her for the octopus
Take a sip be
Homelanders and mk. What does that mean?
A mortal combat
No fucking way. That's actually a perfect character for more mortal combat. That's hilarious
Sorry took me a moment
Mario Kart
Oh
Omni-man peace maker. Oh my god, I would love to see a homelander versus um omni-man
That's so awesome
I personally suck at fighting games
I just to be honest I could totally see a crossover of the boys and invincible
Not like a cartoon one but like a um like a live action one
I was called him glenn. Um, I don't think they would be able to have the same guy as the actor for
The main character. I can't remember anybody's names from invincible. What?
Iron man invincible. Yeah, I know that. Yeah. Mm-hmm. I didn't know about that
The boys getting washed facts
Yeah, uh, I don't um omni-man would destroy homelander. I will say it
I
Also
The last season of invincible. I'm sorry, but like
It was such a fucking letdown for me
I'm like it was just all over the place like the main villain disappears after an episode and then comes back at the very last
Episode and like does fuck all and I'm like, okay
Excuse me
Yeah, I was I was really disappointed
It's funny how you can technically put all I guess anyone he gets wiped true
He's just he's just psychologically like
one of
Homelander's traits is he just really knows how to manipulate people really well
um
Because he's a fucking psychopath
And so he knows like
It's it's funny because he's not a sociopath because he has empathy
um
And he but he uses his knowledge of empathy and how people react to things against them. It's very smart
Totally unhinged. I actually really like he's one of my
favorite
Villain characters because he's just so well developed
um
I think that's why I really liked like I just like you know, you think there's a character you just love to hate
And like that is homelander like he's such a like like ah, fuck. I hate him, but he's awesome
But fuck him like that's yeah, that's homelander
Yeah, the minute you crack his ego he's done for yeah, like he has like he's a super powerful
Whatever the fuck likes what do they call them?
What do they call people with powers I forget
V hero
Vagina hero virginity hero a soup. Yeah, he's really soupy
um
But I would even it's funny because not even a superhero. He's just he just has superhuman abilities
Hope they handle them well on the news. I bet they will super powerful man, baby. Yeah, because he's like under like mentally
He's just like has not had proper human interaction
Gaslight maxi. Yeah, I also really like um
Butcher because
He's such a like a good anti-hero like I would love to see like uh team up of butcher and the punisher
Like that would be a cool crossover
Homelander is an incel with a cape
But it's funny because he's like
At first I'm like, oh, he's like a what like, you know when he's with that
One chick who's a nazi which that made me
crack the fuck up
Like his relationship with her and how he just like would complain about stuff all the time
Like she's in that bed and she's just getting me in my handy and she's like half dead
Um, basically the dude from mega mine. Yeah, you know
But like
he's not
Like he was it's weird because he like respects people at the same time. He's like, no, no, no
We don't we don't we don't treat people like that, but then he'll just like kill people again
Like that. It's just so such a funny thing to me. He's like, no, that's where I draw the line
racism
No
I won't allow it
Uh, see when he works. Yeah, yeah, that was that was an intense scene
Like when he kind of just like switches it on
and just like fucking
He does have a way with words
A milk scene is a very iconic
all the best like terrible characters
Drink milk in such a weird way
It like I remember reading an article of like, you know, you got like jack knuckleson's character
I think from one flew over the cuckoo's nest then you have like, uh, the main character from like a clockwork orange
And then you have homelander in like what milk
Represents because it's usually something that children consume
And it's like these adult men consuming it and like twisting innocence. It was such a great article
I wish I could recall more of it. It was such an interesting
uh
deep dive into
What fucking milk symbolism was just like corruption like, uh, how they can do this corrupt others
But they're also extremely childlike at the same time
Homelander is definitely deserve a fan. He's a bleeding heart
That would be so funny if they had like a scene of him just like
Fapping to a vtuber or like he falls in love with like some online girl
Then he hunts her down and like freaks like like I feel like he would be a good yonder, eh?
His interaction to the storefront was like, yeah 100%
Um
Little man, no
But uh, yeah, I always love
character development
And uh tv shows that there's no character development or like the characters are just so infuriate
Furiatingly superficial or one-sided. I'm just like I can't consume this
Poor boy. Yeah
Yeah, that was I actually really liked uh black noir's character. Um
It's weird though because
It's very different from the comics
And I
I kind of wish they stuck to the comics because I think that would have been
very
Interesting to go
Down like that route. Yeah the original uh boys comics
It isn't as good like the people have said like this tv show
I've only read like a couple like a little like bits of uh the comics here and there. Um, but
Apparently like the show is actually better than the source material
Um
There's your comments about yeah
The
Creator from letter didn't say he's meant to be satirical. Oh, yeah, that's that's totally
So prevalent just satire of the american dream. There's a twisted version of the american dream. He is manifest destiny, you know
um, but
Yeah, it was I would have I would have liked to see how that would have gone down
I feel like it would have
Been interesting
But um, I feel like they'll approach that in another way like because I feel like they're
Already kind of approaching that with the sun and everything like what
would have happened
The comics just an edge of abortion on the justice league. Hey, man. That's what my fan fiction was when I wrote
When I wrote a fan fiction I was younger
I think this hates superheroes as parodies of them are very surface level. Yeah
Hero guys episode was tame compared to the comic. Oh, I did not it was funny. So like
My dad's recommended the boys to me. Um
and
I remember I was watching that season that here guys. I was in he's like, did you get to the episode?
I'm like, what he's like, did you get to the hero guys an episode?
And I'm like, no and he's like
Just walked away
Like
Okay, and then I like and then I like watching I'm like dad
Why did you recommend me the show because I think I started watching it when like the second season came out
Or whatever. It wasn't the third season that one was in. I don't remember. Um
And yeah, sometimes
Sometimes my dad recommends me shows and I'm like, why the fuck did you recommend this to me?
He's like, yeah, you'd like this
But he's right. I like it
It was it's a great show
I recommended the boys to my boss. I'm not sure who watched it was wife. Yeah, my mom could not watch that. My mom has very uh
My mom is weird because she hates
Violence, but she really likes military related tv shows because I think she was watching like seal team or whatever the fuck it's called
And I'm like, okay mom, you can't watch the boys, but you'll watch like war
Like this is just like out like silly goofy like, you know, it's fake
But like that's like based in reality
and like
war
And like like for example
My mom really likes outlander
Outlander is a great book really great premise if you don't know what it's about
It's about this woman who has this ability to go through these special stones back into
Ireland I think in like the 1400s and she falls in love with a guy there. Um
Again the 1400s was a wild place in scotland. There was a lot of
raping and pillaging and murdering and terrible stuff
And I'm watching the most fucked up scene from this tv show
So my mom's like, oh you'd like it. It has like fantasy and like historical stuff that you like. I'm like, okay
And I'm like, oh this dude is totally just
On going ham on this poor woman and okay
I'm like mom
Yeah, my mom likes like medieval shows
Um, but she couldn't watch game of thrones
Actually, no, did she finish I asked my mom. Did she finish game of thrones? I don't know
maybe
And it's weird for her she like has to watch something that's like realistic
Like it has to have some realism to it or she just can't get into it and like a lot of people are like that
So she likes historical fiction because it's like rooted like you can twist the truth just a little bit like it leaves enough for like, um
what's the expression
Suspensive
disbelief whereas fantasy you kind of throw that out the window
But like for me, I can understand like and most people can watch it and be like this is fantasy supposed to be like this
I don't have to believe in it. Um, she like Rambo probably. I don't know
I
Wasn't she married though? I think so
Thanks mom
um
Yeah, what I've just been watching a lot of dumb stuff lately
I've been in my my lonely woman era. Um
Sometimes I just like get into this funk when it becomes like spring summer where I'm like, oh, I'm a lonely person
And so I just watched like I or I binge watched this whole like chinese drama one time
And it was really good and I was like sad
And then I just watched binge watched euphoria and that was fucking depressing as hell
I literally cried at the and I don't cry at shows a show depressed me to fuck
And I'm like, I need to I need a palette cleanser. So then I watched bridgerton
It's fucking great. I love bridgerton
I love bridgerton so much. I can't wait for it to come back
in a couple days
I hate that shows split it up split stuff up into two fucking parts now. That is the stupidest shit ever
um
Yeah, I was watching that I literally binge watched that stupid tv show
It's watching watch the kissing booth on netflix the third one
Wasn't as good as the first though
Euphoria no euphoria with the people but the kid the angsty kids in high school
You guys have said the said this to me before
Not that euphoria
Not the visual novel
Yeah, exactly exactly exactly she'll watch that but she won't watch superheroes
Like she'll like watch like a marvel movie, but she like can't get it
So like me and my dad were like, oh, we're gonna go see furiosa
Um, I just in some of you know why I was watching mad max again. Um, my mom's like, yeah, that's for you guys
Okay
The one with spider man's girlfriend
Huh, I don't love I don't even I don't even read the visual novel. I don't know like I just know it's bad
I haven't read that
I've only ever read metamorphosis and that was
You're one of the 50 people who saw furiosa. I haven't seen it yet. I might just I don't think I'm gonna end up seeing it
Um in theaters because I wanted to see you in theaters
But it feels like it sucks because it's got really good ratings. It just got like shat on in the box office
But I heard it was good
I like the actress. Hello
Where does he happen?
We're just hanging out
I like, you know metamorphosizing
When I went to see furiosa, I was the only one there. I think it's because nobody fucking knew what it was about like mad max was
very hyped
Because people remember the old mad max
And then people now are just like, okay, but what's that about?
Yeah, it's got ania taylor joy or whatever her name is
but like
Charlie's there in as hot as fuck
But um
Oh, excuse me
Just fear your own flop. I don't I don't recall. It was okay. Like when I watched it again, I'm like, yeah, this is kind of what I remember
It was so weird because like listening to um
The actor for
max
talk, I realized that the the movie was like weirdly dubbed every time he spoke
Like I know he didn't speak often, but I was like, uh
It feels like somebody else's voice. Like I know he has an um, he usually has an english accent
Australian or something. I was like, huh?
I'm thinking about watching the uh original mad max stuff
Metamorphosis showed editing is only relenting watch barbie purely for Ryan gossip. Listen, I liked barbie
Maybe it's because I'm a woman. Maybe not. I enjoyed it a lot. I saw with my parents
My mom didn't like it
I think she was like it so it was okay. I really liked it. I like cried. I cried at that movie. I felt like it hit me
My dad was like it was cute. I think my dad liked him more than my mom then again, my dad's a Taylor Swift fan, so
Which way was turned black man Taylor Swift from the boys
Ryan Gosling is the goat if you watch drive. Yeah, I haven't actually seen drive. I just watched fall guy
with my parents
Your dad's a swift. Yes
I like he he was like, hey, you listen to Taylor's new album. I'm like dad. What the fuck he's like, you know
Comrade is a cat and he was like, so I'm sick of that. I'm like, what are you? I'm like dad, since when did you become a
Swiftie? He's like her new music bangs. I don't know what to tell you. I'm like, Jesus. Fuck dad
I'm not seeing drive. No
White women music is timeless. You're not wrong. You're not wrong
Again, my both of my parents have very
Range tastes and that's why I have very range tastes
But it's another reason why I don't like country because I never listened to country growing up
I listened to everything else besides country
I would go to bed listening to classical music because my mom would make sure I listened to classical music
And then I would go to school. My mom would play some 80s music
She would pick me up from home and she would play fucking breaking Benjamin in three days grace
Depending on the day that she had then my dad would play some like 80s or 90s rap and then
All like, yeah, I just I was very well
well around it and then I would listen to pop punk and just like alternative and metal
Um
My mom dated a guy who watched pitch perfect every week and played this soundtrack to him from work
Oh god, I would hate that although pitch perfect. Like it was a good movie. I did like pitch perfect the first one
Um, some country music is good. I know I have like one of my friends and it's funny because she's like very russian
Like very like think of icy
But like dialed up to a 10
And I see he's not even russian, but like they have the same accent though dialed up to a 10
and then
she
Really likes fucking country, but she's also she has like the bluntness that some like culturally russian people just have
They're just like very blunt and it can come across as like being a little abrasive
But she's a total sweetheart
And so she like listens to country and I'm just like this is so weird to me
I feel like you should be hating this
Basically ice with a vodka bottle in a cake
Yeah
George story they didn't last long. Thank thank god for her
Um, you have a live stream of just them
Yeah, I don't think I would do a live stream because they would probably just say
My name I did a collab once with some iRL friends
Um in my my uh past life and one of them called me by my first name, but nobody noticed
None of my audience notice
It was very funny
I was everybody went silent too because I had like asked them like okay. Don't use my name
Please look like the company
And uh
One of the one of the girls was just like hey, and I'm like doesn't respond
Um
Yeah, because sometimes this happens and I know like
I think my dad would be able to
It's call me by she be but I think my mom would
Find it hard
Because my dad gets it because he watched uh, he watches a lot of twitch streamers and stuff
I want to be surprised when my dad got into vTubers now. I have to ask him
I maybe I'll recommend him some vTubers. He's a very much
He only likes to watch like cod and stuff though and like sometimes fortnite
I don't know if there's any maybe I don't think yeah, no my dad doesn't like valent
Your dad watching ninja. No, he watched like nick mercs or something
I feel yeah, no, I know my dad would like probably really like vTubers if you watch them
Your dad the actually the best vTuber. I would see my dad getting a model like that one guy. That's like an orc
I have your dad sign up for the next holostars
That would actually be so sick though if my dad was at holostars
He would get in he was so get in
Is that a 14 year old boy?
Yes, no
That would be so funny. What's the male equivalent of a hag?
Because my mom is like definitely like peko mama
Um just like chill and shit
A gilf
She have a papa for holostars. I was like, oh, no, don't call my dad. Oh, do you say no? No, no, no, no
Stop it. Cut the cut the cut the cameras. No, thank you
I don't like that
Is the guysy
Adil
That's not the equivalent of a hag
Silver fox. I like that a zaddy
Can't wait to say daddy cotton mom 360 no scope a 12 year old
It's really funny because
Again, my dad has like a naturally very very very deep voice
But he when he's very excited just like me his voice pitches up
And I'd be like
Chackle hysterically and I'm just uh because like so he would game in the living room
And I would game in my bedroom and my mom would just be like chilling watching my dad play or like playing like some like
I don't know candy crush while she on her iPad all my dad plays games
um
And I would just hear him screaming in the next room
And my mom's like redacted
Be quiet. I'm trying to read
I'm trying to study the bible right now
My mom oh no, my mom my mom um, I don't know she she kind of like
I'm surprised she can sit there and kind of like do her own thing while my dad plays
um
Because once my dad knows he has an audience like if I'm sitting beside him like when I was like doing homework for school or something
That's he starts to narrate and commentate
As if he's a streamer
And it's it's very very amusing
So when he's serious, he's six five, but he's excited. He's five two. That's actually accurate. My dad is is that tall
Yeah, he's naturally a streamer. I guess that's where I inherited it from
So he would be natural in hollow stars. He'd be like, uh
Wait, no, is that Niji Sanji or is that hollow stars again? I don't watch
LVTubers. Um, what is his name like gold bullet?
Is he the brown who's the brown one?
Who are the tan
My dad's built different
I can see why you're crazy. Yeah, that's accurate
Gold bullet is hollow stars. Okay
There you go. Like he could be BFFs with gold bullet. That's the type of name my dad would pick for himself
Can we just talk about how stupid
Male names are like women's names are normal like she be cotton bum. Come on. That's an amazing name
Gold bullet
Vazelius bandage
Who is picking these fucking names?
Jesus
Gold bullet is an awesome name you take that back
Bandit, no it's not
Vantacro bringer
honestly, if they named him like something Vantacro that would have been cool like
Umohoshi Vantacro like that's fine
Hanabama is so normal. I don't know what you're talking about. Listen, I didn't get to pick my name either
Because they I'm pretty sure they get to pick their names and design their characters. Don't they or is hollow
Is hollow also cast for character? Do Niji and hollow allow the talent to make to make your own character?
Shibuya just me as uh, what's his name cyborg?
Vantacro bringer. Yeah, that's what I thought. Yeah, Vantacro bringer perfect calm van
Vantacro bringer
You really got bum in your name. Yeah, because I got a fat ass. I'm gonna stick in your face and sit on it
Smother you shut the fuck up
No, only the second third offense. Oh, okay
Streamers pick the names
Um, you know, yeah mercy picked her name
She was able to pick her name because
Karam beat
Was just not
Not having a good time
Shibuya's gyat. No, my gyat is non-existent
Um, I remember like yeah, uh, Strani asked me if I wanted to like change anything like I
I could have changed like my logo
I could have changed I couldn't change like my character obviously, but she's like is
Is your name cool? And I'm like, yes, I thought it was hilarious
I was like, I kind of liked that. It was very close to being
Nijisanji holo stars level of out of pocket
Strani, so yeah, oh most of like like you guys know I'm getting a tan toggle
You guys know I'm getting a tan toggle
Um spoiler. I'm also changing my eye color
I
Know you might not like it, but I might only use I don't know if it's gonna be only with the tan toggle that my eye color changes
Um
I wanted to do I know nobody has blue eyes in our gen
Nobody has blue eyes, so I'm like give me blue eyes
because
Yeah, mercies are reddish
Strani's are like greenish yellow purple
Uh me and Azura have this and I see have the same colored eyes and um
Emmys are also purple
Yeah, so I'm gonna do instead of blue eyes white dragon. I'm tan she be blue eyes
blue eyes tan she be
Um
Getting glasses. I just like get an asset of glasses. I don't know
But I don't know I have to I don't know if it's gonna be a permanent thing that I have blue eyes
um
Yeah
No my gold eyes
You know, I love the gold eyes
It just it just looked really weird with the tan skin tone to be honest with you because like uh, I was telling her
I'm like, oh because our my the artists in the regular are working on it right now and um
I don't know when they're gonna be done. I might be like a month or so. So you will not have
tan she be quite yet
um, because they're also working on cover-ups for me and Azura I think but um
I was messing around like okay. Maybe if I had this sort of skin tone
I was trying to be close to my normal skin tone
But then I was like I was holding up my hands to the thing and I'm like, holy fuck. I'm so pale
So I kind of made myself just a little bit darker like when I'm in the like when I've gone to the beach
Rather than when I haven't left my home for like a year
Tan she be I don't I don't know if I will be tan by monetization. Who knows?
Um, but yeah, the the gold, you know what? Fuck it. I'll just show you. I'll just show you the screenshot
I sent to strongy and I don't really care
Do-do-do
Because I was I kind of made the undertone of my skin a little bit too red
Um, because I like I kind of so my tan skin kind of does clash with my color palette a bit
Um, like if my red was a little bit brighter it might stand out more
Because my mixture because like uh, I'm like a mixture of monochrome and
um
And my my main color is red and that I feel like that works extremely well with my hair
and my um
My like the yeah in my eyes, but when I'm tan it just doesn't
It just looks too red. I don't
I don't know how to explain it to you because like it's just like it's all color theory really
That's why you see a lot of more like tan
Um
She was with like if they have warmer colors in their palette
It's like an accent color
Rather than like a main color, but you know, I'm completely completely wrong or it's normally like cool colored tones
It's really depending on like what what type of black you are, you know
I mean, where's the screenshot?
I
Was like this makes like I look just like fucking burnt
I look sunburned a little bit
Um, and that's with the blue eyes. So it looks it looks pretty nice
I realize however the eye the layers on my uh, my right eye
We're not cut properly
They were not separated at the same as my left eye. So I couldn't get quite the
color that I wanted for the
for the eye tone
Yeah, they look grayish it's it's never meant to be a blue
Die my hair. I don't know but I like I like the blonde like blonde with tan skin looks so good
Like so I wish I could because I used to uh, I'll be honest with you
Um rtx she be I used to have icy blonde hair and it looked fucking gorgeous against my skin
Like a fine grilled wagyu
Yeah blonde and tan and like I feel like it fits better with the gyaru, you know
If it's way better with the gyaru
But you'll notice
Like you'll see like how my
Like my my on my color palette needs to kind of be brightened up
In terms of like my reds seem to be a bit more intense because they're like a lighter red
So they need to be a little bit brighter. I think
You know
Um
And let me show you the other screenshot I took
Yeah, I couldn't fucking get the eyes right
Because of the layering issue
Because it like just darkened the top my eyes look fucking pitch black
Yeah
Which way western man
Um, I actually like me with darker eyes to be honest with you
I look very nefarious. I feel like I look more bunny like especially when I have my little
I probably will have like my uwu mouth as a permanent thing because I feel like it shows off that I'm like
More bunny like because like it makes my teeth look a certain way
It's both an option. Well, it's gonna be a toggle again. I am going to be she be copper bum
This is she be copper bum right here
Does she be copper bum just like copper cat mouse
But yeah, I think like look at don't I look like such a fucking succubus in this picture like god damn
I was debating whether or not to like add another mole somewhere too. I think that could be really cute
Well, like I'll probably do that in the 2.0
It's copper bum single. Yeah, but she does not want to get with you
Um
Madam only
Uh, my tan lines would go. Yes, like I feel like tan lines would be really good with it too
Let me critical it
Out of tail I have a tail
You just can't see it. I have a bunny tail guys
But crazy thing
I can't turn around and show it to you
So
I don't know how you expect me to show a bunny tail when they're a little bit
They're like tucked in
Yes, I'm a fucking rabbit. Of course I have a tail
Yes, I was telling um
Strawny to tell the artist that I need to like I need I'll need to change my ear
Um color because I couldn't do it because the the ear the inner ear isn't separated from the the
Like the fur part of the ear. So I couldn't change the color of that
You can't believe you're coming. I was trans Rachel. Call me Rachel Dozel
Call me Rachel Dozel. I am trans Rachel
I'm sorry you got yeeted for that
Uh any alt costable I want to do ghiattu naturally. I would love to do ghiattu school girl. Um
I really don't probably like
Moff not like mafia boss look because I kind of already got that going on with the office wear my pops kala
um probably
some sort of like
More madame like like victorian madame brothel owner
Who is in Paris? We finally know the answer to this
Who is in Paris?
Yes, I really want to do a like
Tan bully like older nagatoro
sort of thing
Ojusama, yeah
And to be honest, I would honestly like a cute and funny toggle as well at some point
An old victorian child outfit. Yeah, I just want to wear victor like a dead victorian child
That's just eaten pop rocks for the first time and couldn't handle it
It's funny. I almost look blurry because the way this screenshot is in the back that I'm darker
Like uh makes it look like I'm like blurry and then the in the background like she's in the foreground
I'm in the hair watching you kiss her
Oh
Yeah, I can't keep secrets because I just get so excited
Because I was like I was like, oh, I should keep it a surprise. No, I can't I can't keep stuff surprises
Yeah, I was talking about it. A lot of my friends were also like, why are you white?
I'm like, well, I am half white, but I get what you're trying to say
But uh, yeah, yadu rabbit yadu dom schoolgirl 100%
Yeah, that would be so it need a comically large hat. Maybe like a lady Demetresque s style
Oh, that's more like a Zura because she's like fucking nine feet tall
Any other secrets you want to share? No, don't look at me like that. Um, don't worry. I'll be enthusiastic even we're already knowing
I asked Rani about an April Fool's thing where all the girls swap body types and she said it was about a stupid as an idea changing
Karam's name
Isn't that something you can't just ask someone other white Jenny
Isn't that something
My back I need a stretch
Lol indeed lol, you know, why are you looking at me like that?
You good
Are you coming to snuggle? Oh, hello
No, you're coming. Oh, come here. Hello
Can't wait for she be emotes. Did you get dressed today or are you PJ'd um
I let well I had to go to the the the um post office
drop off a return
for my uh
My my my friends having a wedding and I'm a bridesmaid and the dresses didn't fit me because my titties are too fucking huge
Uh
Love that because everything else fit fine. Um, I might have to get it like actually professionally fitted to me
and um
Uh, I was just I just was wearing a t-shirt and I'm wearing the same. I'll actually no I'm wearing different pants now
I was wearing a well. I'm still wearing. I was just wearing a sailor moon t-shirt
Jeans and flip flops. That's all I was wearing and then now I'm just I've just switched to sweatpants
Somebody asked me what color today and I just uh, I didn't I forgot to answer. It's uh black
I need you laundry I only have his thongs left
I also need to buy more underwear now that I have that fucking
lingerie credit that I got yoinked my money for
And they stole 60 bucks right out of my under my nose
I'm gray sweat so you could see a swaying under there
That sounds like a uh
I uh
Like a a kevin. What's that rigger's name? Um, kevin
Well, you probably know who the fuck i'm talking about. You know how he does all those like sus
toggles
he should make like a sweatpants toggle and then
If you're a male vtuber and you use a toggle you can like toggle on like having a massive dick
It's like the outline
Or like I could use it and like I can have because it's like my strap
Also, by the way, are you guys asking me to like put a strap on my throne? Do you want me to do that?
Apparently some of you have asked me to do that
Because i'm like I don't have one because like who the fuck am I gonna use it on my cat. No
A cat will do
A bold toggle hell yeah untuck my queen
So what's the fabric? It's just pee. It's not prey. It's pee
I mean if you want
I'm surprised no one did a toggle asset based on that one sus are what guy was dressing pulling his pants
But showing his cake in his front. I don't know. I don't know that about that one
Oh, yeah, see you guys are understanding me now
I
Might as well as see how I feel like that I will put it on now and then it would just get bought
I already asked this is kisses to yeah
Like the tip of my finger because I got a boo boo. Oh, you know
You know
Maybe like that. I'm a clumsy gal
I got popular in toilet. I probably won't do it senator later. Oh, okay
I am stroking my kitty right now. I am petting that pussy. Do you like that? Do you like that's right now?
Oh, yeah
You are what?
Guys get your head out of the gutter. I literally just told you Rena's on my lap
I
Her in and rumbling away
Vibrating even
With their purse. What color is the cat? She's a samee's cat. She's a blue point
Hey, she be have you seen those glow in the dark stockings? I always I read that as schlong for like
A quick second. I don't know why
Hi to the cat. She's chilling
She's shedding all over me. Can you I need to brush you again Jesus Christ lady
Um, no
Uh
I don't know what what is g i w t w m mean
Have you seen the clown that what?
Huh
Oh, I get it
Oh god, I wish that was me. Oh, okay
I have not seen glow in the dark stockings. I really like the cat stockings. I used to have a pair
But I spilled lipstick on them. I dropped my one of my um lip glosses on them
On my my pink one and I don't know where my black ones went of those little like kitty paw print pads
um stockings
Say jelly of the cat that makes more sense
Casually watching these bottoms what bottoms?
Because it's not me
Whoa, huh lipstick on my valentina white stockings
Lipstick on my valentina my lipstick on my valentino bag
Good reference approved. I need to learn how to do like motion effects capture. Like, you know how you can like anchor
like a png or something to like
Like a scene and like adobe premiere and like have it kind of travel with it
Um, I want to do that with the veal or girls and vines, but I can't remember how to do to do that because I've done that before
um
I remember I did like a whole
I don't know what happened to it. I did a whole edit of like hunger games in fortnight with that and it was fucking hilarious
Just do the ai thing like yeah, but she didn't make that we had someone made that for us
So
Oh, you know what's a good idea. Oh, let's answer some maros answer some maros
Wouldn't that be great if we answered some maros?
Did I ever answer this question? What are fun things do with crowd control? I don't know. You could fucking kill me. I think I answered that
I think I said that
Sorry, I was looking at to see if somebody accidentally gave me something that I missed
Okay, they'll keep let me move this food off to the side
Maros maros tell all your friends tell all your friends. She's reading maros
I'm not showing them
I have 41, uh, by the way, I only uh answer maros like every couple days, by the way, so like if you don't get responded to
Um right away, please don't get your fucking panties in a bunch and that goes for all of us
Don't forget we like we have lives the girls go to school
I have to like maintain my home talk to family and friends
Go to doctor's appointments like please don't if you don't respond to immediately
Literally shut the fuck up. I don't care
That you were jorgen your dick and I didn't cream myself over it
Within 30 minutes of you sending it just relax, buddy
fucking relax
In conceivable
Because like I'll have people like spam me with the same one and I'm like dude
I'm doing something. I'm trying to do something because like
I usually sit on the computer for eight hours a day
And I mean doing the same fucking thing when I go back to work
It's like sometimes I need to take a break from the screen
Sometimes I need to put my phone away
And just be a veg on the couch and you know watch the boys or read a book
Go outside touch grass work out
So I try to do that sometimes I'm can't I can't just keep refreshing my maros being able to jump on them and respond to everyone
Thank you
What's a marrow a marrow is a marshmallow a marshmallow?
um
So marshmallow dash qa dot com is a japanese hosted site where you can send anonymous messages to usually your favorite creators
That's what most uh btbs it most of the time in the past people use curious cat
But because that site is so broken and sometimes has a lot of downtime and does not work
We do not use it because it's not reliable
So stop complaining as well that we don't use fucking curious cat. I don't care
When are you gonna understand? I don't care
Anytime you complain and we've already explained to you the reasons why and they're you know
Appropriate reasons and you're like yeah, but still I don't care
What's grass
Does the crap you have to do because you know
You need to be yes, so you need to logged in
Yeah, that's an all anonymous
et cetera
um, okay, so this is
I also can't read japanese
I'll do the most uh recent one. Well, not the most recent the latest the ones that are the furthest in the past
Can I touch your ears, please madam
Uh, no
They're very sensitive. I don't like them touched just like my tail. Please do not tug on my tail or tug on my ears
Thank you
Um
Okay, I'm literally gonna go through all of them today
Um and respond to them
I'm gonna mute my desktop audio though. Let's take a case one of some of you people moan
He he he whoo-hoo
Uh
I shouldn't really sometimes I accidentally confirm stuff when I don't mean to
I can't read this out loud, but
Um, I'm happy I was you honestly you'll probably with how I respond
uh
Know who you are
If if you're here if you're not here then
Okay
Yes, that did happen congratulations, um
I'm you know, I I've had a lot of people I'm the first person
I'm gonna probably cut this this portion of the stream out
But I kind of want to go over uh maros and stuff because it's just fun talking about maros
um
I'm happy that a lot of you feel comfortable enough with me to share certain sides of yourself that you've not done before with other either
um people in your life
Or a certain someone in your life and or another uh streamer or vtuber in your life
So I very much appreciate you for doing that that makes me feel
Very good
Wink, um, I might be talking in code a lot. So I apologize in advance if you can't understand what I'm saying
Always been super shy
I've been super. Oh
Yeah, don't be shy. Don't be shy with me
I'm happy. I can help help you open up and kind of just like be more confident
I'm so glad
Thank you. You're not you never yapp too much. I yapp chat reflect streamer
I'm code switching
Mamosa no get out of here
Mamosa leave you're too young to see this
You're too young
Um, how about sometimes it's very annoying trying to respond
Boop boop boop boop
Isn't that guy who plays aquaman, huh?
I'm in my you're in your 30
Mamosa you're fucking with me
You're so fucking with me right now you are not in your 30s. I do not believe you
If you're in your 30s, I'm 56
Hag love
Still 20 years younger than madam. That's what I mean. That's foul
I identify as 25. Yeah, I'm 56 guys
She meant she's in her threes. She's divisible by three
Okay, um
Okay, this one I can say outside
Hi, she be I've been head over heels for you since you spat in our collective mouths in your debut
Talk about a power move. I've only become more impressed in enamored as time gone on because of your chill dorky vibes
Your maculite memory and your rutless
I can't see that
What does that mean?
Say sexiness. I don't know probably
Um, it feels like such a rarity to see someone who doesn't just play a dom in role plays
But actually and is and loves being dominant
No shade to the people who are putting on an act is still wonderful content
But I think it hits different when you know that the words are heartfelt
Have you had much real life experience doming people? And if so, are there any particular events or scenes to stand out to?
You've been da-da-da-da
Uh stream audio is really good at both. It's funny because you're wrong
Um
Uh, I've been very transparent
That I'm normally a switch, but again, I am very knowledgeable
with um
That side of things
Uh, I have not had real life experience doing that
Um
Sorry
Sorry to break the kayfabe for you
Um, but I am realizing
As I am learning more and you guys are teaching me
that
I am really fucking enjoying it. I uh
Like what I did earlier in stream today where I kind of just bitched at you guys and bossed you around
Oh, that was nice. That made me feel very good. You have no idea. I'm telling strongy right now
But yeah, um
I don't yeah, no, I don't
I do
I do put on the act sometimes
But the majority of the time late like when I first like the first like two days
I was putting on an act then after that I was like, holy shit. I actually like this
Like I actually don't mind this
Um, and if that bothers you
I'm sorry
But I don't care
If it bothers you then I'm normally a switch
I don't care. I really don't
Cry I want you to cry. Can you record yourself crying to me?
So I can fucking laugh at your stupid little boy tears. Thank you
Yes
Um
Madam if I wait
I can't read that out loud um
Is there anything particular I want in videos and go follow your heart, dude
I get a lot of questions asking me to
Um, you're more of a bully
Yeah, because that's how how am I supposed to do?
More dom related things
When one this is not an actual
Dom sub relationship
We have not gone through like actual consent forms. I don't know what you like. I don't know what you're into
I can't inflict pain upon you. I can't do the acts you're asking me to it's all audio
I am so limited
In my character with what I can do
Whereas I see
She can do age play just fine. It's not hard for her to do that. It's easier to like
Regress to a child than it is to an act like one which was appealing to her fan base
than to
Have me pretend like do you want me to pretend to punch you like?
If you
can tell me
How to be better
Within audio related stuff perfect
Or on stream someone made a very good. I I um
I read it this morning and I took the advice someone said to me
You should use your crop intermittently and wave it in front of the mic
And make the user anticipate and not know when you're gonna hit it and I'm like that is perfect. Thank you
Thank you
That is constructive
advice
Like I'm like that's perfect for a 3do for like whoa, where am I gonna go? Oh, whoops like
And so I try to do a little bit of that with this microphone
But I didn't really work that well because you can't really hear the movement in front of the mic
um
So yeah, see thank you. I can instruct you to do stuff
I don't really
Oh, why did I read punch ourselves? He said punish ourselves. Um, and I have done that
People like ask me
Um, hey, like what can I do and I'm like, okay, you can do this for a week and you can do that
But if you're not sending Maro's asking for that stuff, I'm not gonna purposefully
I'm not gonna tell you. I don't I haven't fucking talked to you yet
She be uni experiment with audio. Thanks
um
You should the you should
Pointing the circle to your belly. What?
I know you folks are going to go above and beyond when it comes to instruction
Yeah, like now like if you want me to get instructions
Give me some ideas. What sort of instructions would you like me to give because so far I can only think of preventing you to do
Um, like straw in your cuddles if you want me to pretend like to tell you don't straw in your cuddles for a week
And I have done that
Do you listen? No, you know often I'll be like, don't do this and people in my maros are like, oh, I did it and I'm like
Okay
Oh, please punish me. No, you can't even take a fucking simple
Direction. I told you don't straw in your cuddles for a week
And you straw in your cuddles and you want me to punish you because you
No, your punishment is I don't tell you to do anything because you're already a disappointment
She'd be so my mom is poor. Can you tell me to do my dishes?
Go do your dishes
Turn off my stream. Do your dishes, please. Do you want me to be your mom?
Clean your fucking room, jimmy
Yeah, yeah, I'm talking to you. Go clean your fucking room. I need a 3d model. You guys can't see my hand gestures
I'm very I'm very when I'm when I'm in a in a mood. I move my arms around a lot
She be my mom's kind of homeless
I didn't
If you're memeing, I don't care if you're not memeing that sucks
Thought I was terminally online dude. I'm a vtuber. I literally I live on the internet. What do you expect?
okay
Anyways, if I was to do if I was to do a video of me straw in my cuddles
Yeah, I kind of already answered that
Um here me
This is a perfect
If you want to send me a video of you wearing color and leash go ahead
Say how awesome I am go ahead do it
Do it you won't
Go buy the collar right now go on amazon
Buy yourself a I even when I first started streaming. I told people to get a collar
Because you are my dogs. You are my pets and none of you fucking did that
By the way, I think people thought I was just joking. I wasn't joking
because
I'm like, oh because like collaring is a very
intense like
But respectful deep connection with your dom when they you get collared
And none of you fucking got collared and when I so look up look up what collaring is in the btsm community
Because you're thinking of like wearing a dog collar. No you get yourself a necklace
It can be you know discreet
It can be something
Simple or you can wear like a bracelet or something just to show people that you are owned
by me
I am your owner
If I was a color what color would I be I don't know like red and it's only everywhere
First Gunpla build and you have to respond to me about how much time I'm wasting with childish activities. Oh, yeah, sure. Don't worry about that
I know I love but she's
If one is broke could a dark metallic. Yeah, that's fine. Like it doesn't have to be like it could be like if you
Have a necklace that you already own and it means a lot to you
You can use that as a representation you can put it on
And that can be your collar
It doesn't have to be like a fancy collar
It doesn't have to be like one of those like stainless steel crazy things with a lock
You can it could usually it's sometimes they've been a lot more discreet
When I was doing research on it
um
And I saw like one girl because I was just like on tick-tock because I was like btsm tips. Hello
and one girl literally her uh
Her I don't know if it was a freaking husband or boyfriend. Um her Dom just got her a normal necklace
And I had like a little heart with a lock on it. I'm like wow
It's that simple. Okay guys get yourself a fucking collar
That's literally what happens and then nobody did it
I never wanted to ruin accessories exactly. It's usually a significant thing. It's very important. It's our connection
You are owned. I own you. It can be a ring. It can be a necklace
It can be a fucking earring. It could be a fucking toe ring a bracelet
A cock ring whatever you fucking you just have to wear it all the time
You can't take it off because I own you I can only take it off. I can only tell you when to take it off
It would clash with my outfit too fucking bad
Hang the chibi key. Yeah the key chain the fucking key chain you bought
The key chain the link is in the description to my merch can be the collar to show that you are owned when you buy it
Sorry she bet that you're trolling
And it's hard because I I do joke a lot so people sometimes like I'll say something. They're like, oh, she's kidding. I'm no I'm fucking not
Maybe my the safe word should be when I'm not joking anymore
Like uh, I'll just say like stilettos and then you'll know that I'm not joking
I'm buying a ring and then gray with the sheebie if you want to be out if you want to do that go ahead
I own you now. Please wear something to reflect that
You know, you have like you have ic and emmy and mercy and they're all very possessive of their own ways
They're possessive
I am possessive as well. We are all possessive
Me uh, you can watch the other girls
You can support, you know, the girls and my gen
Um, you could have you know, they're oh she marks on your name
For the moment you get a fucking collar
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can you know be cute with them. You're fucking mine when you put on the collar though, sweetheart. Okay
I am possessive I do get jealous
I don't like sharing my toys
Um, I'll share them with the girls
I know sometimes they do don't you know mercy has a list, right? She has a list. I remember she was showing me
She's a list of your names
um of those of people who
seemed to be double dipping
It sounds like too much. Okay, I think I got the fuck out
Yeah, she has a list who's been naughty
and who's been uh
Like trying to be like an ojisan and a in a snippet and a this and a that
She was cast so well, wasn't she?
Yeah
So glad mercy yeah mercy streams during my bedtime too. Um, she watches you while you sleep though
She was telling me she shared you she just sent a picture of myself sleeping. It was pretty crazy
Um, is mercy willing to share between viola girls, you know
um
I hope you guys like understand like when we say like, oh, I want you all to myself
That really means like within viola
But it's like there's I know there's like super dedicated regulars in everybody's chat
um
And like
It's when like it it it bothers the girls
When you say that there you're oh she
But then you call another girl your kami oh she
Because that's just being a whore derogatory
Because we're whores affectionate, you know
But like I kind of know I was just responding to the marrow that I was saying out loud that was reading. Um
But like I will always support the girls
And I don't mind
If you watch the other girls, that's fine. I'm I'm someone who I share the love
I I want to make sure everybody succeeds everybody that comes into the vicinity of me. Cool. Um
The other girls may not be like that. Uh, I'm pretty they're like that within our gen
but
If they I know I have I've honestly in the past like when I was
A priestess I would see like my regulars and someone else's like my french chat. I would honestly
Get super upset
Because like
I don't know. I was it was like I was like, oh, I just caught you with another woman. Um
But I think I've grown since that
Since, you know, a couple months ago
Um to be fair, I probably use this term for idol culture called kami oh shi
But no, sorry. Sorry. It was like they go I misspoke. They would call someone kami oh shi and then the girl kami oh shi
That's what I meant
Not oh shi oh shi because I almost said oh shi
Oh shi, but then I was like no oh shi kami oh shi that I meant to say kami oh shi oh shi kami oh shi kami oh shi
Say that five times fucking fast
Yeah, exactly. So mercy knows who's done that because you some of you have done it
I know too now
Uh
This is a good question. This is a very good question. Okay, this is probably a weird question
This is what they started off with but I just don't want to cause trouble
I am not 100 into dom sub but I watch you for your taste in games base takes memes and jokes
Still, there is quite some role playing in chat
Should people like me rather be lurkers and not interact? I have the feeling I would destroy the hegemony in chat
um
You can respond to what you respond to so like if you were
Not into like what I did earlier like you don't have to respond to that
you're not obligated to participate if you're not consenting because um
That sort of plate is all about consent
Um, I do make the jokes about like I don't believe in a safe word, but you know in real life
Consent is important and I'm not going to force you
To talk in a chat that you're not comfortable in
You know like, um
So difficult as I like with hanging on my singular talent so it makes me feel horrible and torn. That's yeah, that's why I'm like I don't
I want you to enjoy who you enjoy
I don't want you to feel bad
But then I also have people on the other hand who wish I was more possessive
So I'm like
I am possessive of you guys
I do get a little hurt when I see you in somebody else's chat not the other but it's funny. It's not the other girls like I'm like
I don't know. It's like
It's like we're all sister wives
I think
Yeah, I don't know. I don't really know
You'd have to ask them you have you'd have to really ask them because I'm like, uh, you know, what is what it is
Where should we send the color proof right you send to my mirrors?
Take a picture put it in cat box
um
But yeah, you don't have to you can lurk
Um, you can only you can talk when you want to participate
Um, I don't if you like say like hi and I'm just like you're a fucking bitch
Like I don't think anybody's gonna freak out
And if they do who the fuck cares
If it bothers them so much they'll just ignore you
If it throws off the flow of chat, then I probably just might not respond but don't take it personally
um, you gotta learn
That like it's the internet
Why do you give a fuck about what people think about you?
In a vtuber bunny dominatrix group chat especially, you know
Everybody's saying hi. Hi. Hi. Hello
I'm still so dark. Should I I should um, I think we're good for call of the lamp for now. So I'll quit that
No, I should probably save
I'm red. Ah red whooping jump scare
Oh my god, I'm still red. Why hasn't it gone away?
I got a sunburn
There you go
And then I forget how pale I am
Oh me for real for real
It's just like she's Deadpool
So mad. Oh, no, that's my crying. Uh, uh, so mad
Ah
I have to make the most exaggerated faces to frown. Um, but yeah
so
Hope that answers your question. I'm gonna just reply like so I'll like I answer the question out loud
Thank you, Jay reads Jay reads tipped $13 and 37 cents. My safe word is give me my money back
I did not consent to this. Oh, no, my money's escaping from wallet right now
Oh, no, no
Oh
Sorry and my uh, there's a disclaimer for when you donate no free funds, baby cakes
Oh, but thank you. Thank you so much. I appreciate it. He's getting taste
That works
I'm sorry. Your safe word must contain between eight to 25 letters
Unique letters and numbers and must have one capital and one unique character
In special character
I think there is a level of some people wanting an owner and others want silly blue goat. Yeah
It's like there's a balance that I have to maintain. Um
You're not the only person watching me. I know. Uh, I like to make you feel that way
Um, I like to make you feel special because you are
Okay, if you are a very special person, especially to me, I really appreciate you watching me now. Okay, if you back on, um
But
I can't tailor every fucking thing to you. I'm so sorry
like
There is half of you that want me to be this half of you want me to this and then some of you that want me to
Know that to be anything at all the shy guy tipped eight dollars
Thank you shy guy answering on stream btw less than three. Oh, of course no problem
BTW less than three
And it's like the angled thing. That's funny. I can't please everyone and neither can the other girls
Like people wish that azura was more like
Sexual or whatever mind you she her fucking voice is sex. So I don't know what the fuck you're on. Um
And that like
I see isn't as mesugaki as we you know
made her out to be and
emmy is you know
More crazy sister than little girl. We made out like I don't know like
In mercy is also a little dork and on top of being a yandere. She's not just crazy all the time. It's like guys are normal
Personalities are gonna shine through because that's what actually draws you in you
Spoiler alert you watch the streamers for their real personality that leaks through
not because
like imagine you watch the streamer that 24 7 was role playing that they were some
fucking fox spirit
Or whatever the hell it gets boring
Because it's not
It's a one-sided character
Like you can only like unless you like flesh out your entire lore in kayfabe like and and
You can't really get that deep into it. I'm sorry
And most people don't even bother with the lore like this dude like you just said
It's funny because I hear people
so often
Say like I wish they would just forget it with the lore because the lord makes no sense
There's no point in putting a lore in a debut
But then I guess for real lure everybody's just like
You have to stick to your lore in your kayfabe. I'm gonna fucking kill myself. That's what you sound like
Arrivals for your affection let me at them fight me chat
I'm really much a youtuber like I was the train all day. Yeah, see that's more interesting
But it's like you have the complexity of our personalities on top
of
You know
War characters are like I'm
naturally
normally
a very teasy
flirty bully person like I
crack a lot of jokes
I also rage at games
And I was picked
Because I was a good
creator
not because I
perfectly fit the character
The straw knee and squishy ghoul made up
it probably like
bumfuck 1am
And straw knees probably like drinking
Be like front of the bosom. No
And I love cats. Yes
I'm not a rabbit IRL. Yeah
No, I am a rabbit
um
Somebody made a joke. I was watching
This like podcast and review of our debuts and somebody made a joke
They're like, I love how she's allergic to rabbits. Does she just wake up and she's in constant pain?
She just wakes up. He goes, uh
Just sneezes all the time. I'm like, oh, fuck. I should make that a joke. Like I'm just like, oh guys. I
I chew
Um
Yes
Do do do do do other maybe liquors, um
Only respond to what you feel comfortable
Participating and of course
If that doesn't float to your boat
No problem and no pressure
To respond
Wake up paints a dumb pain every time I wake up
My body was that character from SpongeBob. He's like my body's made of paper and glass
I spelled doesn't wrong, but it's fine
Oh my god, can I please spell doesn't correctly?
Guy's a con man. He was
Excuse me
Shibi, I'm going to buy some red rope to match yours and do some knot tying. Do you have any yourself?
I actually I don't own any shibari rope. I'm such a fucking fraud
I'm such a fraud guys
I don't have a strap. I don't have shibari rope. I'm terrible
Uh, I want to get some though. Like I've said a bunch of times I want to do membership streams where we learn how to tie shibari together
Um, I think they said called me a poser mistress. I don't
Poser mistress. I mean, please pose on me. I don't know what that means like pee on you
I don't also are you going to get that Glock you're gonna get after you put it on throne? Um
Wait, should I
What should I call this
So
Again, I I I don't I'm not packing anything
But if you you guys seem like you want me to put it on my throne
So I I will I don't
You just want me to like stand in it and be like, ooh, do you like a little like whoo wiggle my hips? I don't know like
If you want, uh, sure
Um
As I listen to your patron audio so happy you're here. No, thank you
Thank you, but no one
Dear and on I should just respond. I should just write every marrow going forward was like dear and on
Thank you for your, uh, correspondence this
evening
I appreciate you going through the trouble of putting a video in a cat box and spacing out the word so it passes the filter and
in marshmallow
dearest and on
It has been many moons since I last heard your voice. I've actually never heard it and I never will
Unless you're trying to groom me
Some of you probably are
Shooting range is more
But your cb kind of shoot. I like how it's not british. You say victorian
Um, I need to stretch my legs. I feel like I gotta pee
Hold it though
um
Thank you for the kind words
I have been asked to put it on my throne
But
Um
I don't know how many of you would like that
So maybe
I also
Do not have rope
And will be purchasing some
Um
Eventually
For membership streams, I can't spell member
How I want a member so bad, I just really want members
Really want a lot of members
You know like a big
Member like a big, you know mountain members, you know
I
Can't type she can answer if you send without an account just always about yeah, uh
I usually respond private if you sent me a cat box unless you want me to show everybody that
Beep beep boop boop joke
Where are you gonna get the rope from the rope store? I don't know probably
There's plenty the days blend together on the vtuber black Blattlefield battle field every stream finds us
No closer to the victory we seek only a correspondence can punctuate the fog of battle that hangs over us
Yeah, you only yeah, you know, I recommend making an account if you want to if you want to
No, if you want to um
Cat box something you need to like clean the can I please respond? Oh
Did it work it worked?
Hey good-looking I just bought a new drum how about we go back to my place and bang it out
Sorry if I sent this twice. I just don't get technology sometimes
I'm not even responding to that
I like cheesy jokes, but that was just bad
Thank you for scolding madam. I'll do better in the future. Truly. I love it when you correct our behavior true mistress to all
I try my best
Hey
Can't read this one out loud because it's naughty naughty naughty you teasing me
Nobro cooked
Oh, man tried the Riz. Oh my god
if you guys think that's Riz then
Lord have mercy. Where did my
What did they have?
Why am I so fucking?
What the hell
I don't know my wrist
Rest went for my for my keyboard. What the hell? Where did it fuck that I put it?
It was just in front of me
I hate that I have like short-term memory loss. I'm not even joking
Uh
All right. Well, that's fucking gun
Sorry, I'm looking around furiously. I don't know where I put it. Am I sitting on it?
Okay, well, I'll never know um
I literally I've not I haven't moved from my desk. I don't know sometimes I'll just do stuff mindlessly and I'll just like move
Stuff around and I don't remember because I'm not like
Mentally present while I do it
Where did I?
Oh, it's on the ground. What the hell?
I don't even remember putting it there. Okay. Uh, anyways
Your model randomly falls asleep. Thank you for telling me the obvious
That's what happens when I lose tracking. Um, maybe you should look around happily rather than furious. Good one. Um
I
Actually, you know what I'm gonna respond to the really intense ones list like later
Uh
I'll be straight with straight and real with you. There was a moment on stream where you
Shit shit posted in your patreon voice
Your shit posted your patreon voice about taking madams juicy farts
You couldn't get it through
It because it's obscene, but ironically that stuff slaps for degenerates
It's just really depraved memory of doming, but we gaso goblins would give a limb
That if you wanted to add something to old toot pack that wasn't just blasting the mic with your cute toots
Do you
English motherfucker, do you speak it? Huh?
I don't
I don't even know how to respond to this because I don't know what the fuck he's asking
Is this is a statement? Is this a question? Are you asking me to do something?
All I understand is that you like i'm assuming you just want me to fart like
Uh
Yeah, the fart pack is coming soon. I'm just gonna
Move on
I think about you too much. I end up daydreaming throughout the day a lot and have to avoid getting hard in public while thinking about you
That's really cute moving on
um
Okay, I just read this one and I can't tell if they're like, I'm very confused. I'm just gonna read it out loud for you
I was oh, let me put on my background music
I was looking at your tweets
And I wondered how did you get that picture of that tanned gyaru bunny bully
That brings all kinds of nasty toys to torment with me at school
One day was a pair of handcuffs and she made me taste your socks
Another was a leash and she took me for a walk on the hallway last day. She gagged me flogged me and told me she
wanted to
Try something on the rooftop someday. I can't say that word
I'm saying this mirror from the locker. I'm currently stuck inside
I don't know how to respond to that. So that's what I'm literally gonna say
I don't know how to respond to this
Huh, is this freddy? No, I don't think so. I don't think that's freddy
He doesn't he didn't it wasn't written like that like how he types
um
Madam I want to rest my face between your legs and give you uh while you work on things
All day long that would be my job
And if you had to get up and move you can attach a leash to my collar and take me with you
You can pick out cute outfits for me to wear and just use me as an object for your
Good times
I won't take a much space and I can feed me via dog bowl. See that's what I'm looking for. Perfect hired
Thank you
Perfect
You're hired
Please tell me your
measurements
For fitting for your outfits
And collar
Thanks
Is that the applications first does anyone send you normal questions? No
Nobody sends me like I I'm like I like responding to normal questions
But like, you know, that's too expected with maros
Um, is there any plans for doing rigging shabari caught in the future feature?
I always love seeing self ties and self suspension. So I'm ordering being the rope bun that you are if it'll be possible
Uh, I've never
Done shabari before
But I am aiming to do
self tying shabari streams
When
Memberships
occur
So we can all learn together
All right, why can't I type I haven't
done
Cool, I'm not using any proper grammar because just don't care right now
There's a plenty of civil war
There is a corner of the internet that acts as if a woman should somehow permanently stop being a top if she ever says
Please or if she displays any kind of a human emotion beyond contempt
Especially when she expresses regret let alone sadness or fear
To say I find it stupid and immature would be an understatement
Evidently these self-professed submissives don't want to be dominated by a woman. They want a robot or a corpse
They must must have much experience with the sm scene for madam to be the best domino she can be she has to undergo her own journey
That is fucking true
Hey, she be I must go to finish up dinner for these shrimp tacos, but wanted to rat out chat on a secret
Apparently they found photos of you being a bottom and are hiding it from you
Last I heard they hid it in the office somewhere
What
Pre-chan on
Um, or what is hold on I where'd it go?
I
Have to read it again
Whoo
Thank you for the tip crimson. Hey, if you miss philip Dennis me shrimp tacos
I don't want to run out challenge. You're gonna barely follow me being a bottom
What those pictures don't exist. So whatever. Um, but thank you
Yeah
He wants to get blustered and defensive I'm not going to because I'm not a fucking idiot
But thanks for the tip. You can't see but I just a little cute salute, you know
I'm gonna
I'll respond to that but like
yeah
I still feel like typing right now actually. Um
Unless it's like something really simple
Uh, yes, I have to go through my own journey. I'm growing as a streamer
I've only been you guys you forget
I've only been a I've been a streamer for a very long time. Yes, but I've only been a vtuber for about six months
Okay, so come me some sock. I'm still learning. I'm still learning
I'm still learning. Thank you
I was taking a short nap and I had a dream
I went up to this house knocked on the door and the madam herself had answered
We exchanged only a few words and then I woke up. What a cruel and unjust world to be living
Oh
Oh, that's too bad
This is an absolutely cold take but I don't think many people here have no they don't they're just like
Oh
Mean lady. Oh, I'm mommy. Sorry mommy. Sorry. That's literally all I know
And like I want you to step on me. Oh, why isn't she doing this this and that you don't even fucking know, dude
Like I can
I can from my maros. I can actually genuinely tell who
Is a true sub and who's just complaining to complain and also I can tell who's a troll naturally
um
Yeah, I just I usually just filter out the trolls. That's easy. That's fine
And there's like one or two like genuine people. They're like, why don't you do this?
And I'm just like, you don't know what the fuck you're talking about clearly. So
Yenne gets an answer love
Oh mean lady, please do my taxes. Well, uh
I'm telling me you debuted 12 days ago and are a pro semer of multiple inside jokes within your community
True
I'm only one of those things I have multiple inside jokes in my community. Most of the jokes are inside me
Oh, um, starting mentioned one of the girls can recognize people in maros by text. That was you, wasn't it? Um, you know, that's probably mercy
but
I don't really
Talk about my maros too much
I've uh
I'd like ask like, oh, how should I respond to like some of them just to like
um
To to like straw knee and stuff, but
I haven't really like gone
and like
prepare like compared stuff like I can usually tell when somebody's sent
the same thing twice
um
Or like sent multiple things in a row
and even when you like because you
They have like a way that they word stuff and people try to like be cool and like change up like how they
Um type and I'm like, no, I know what the way you're talking in the words that you're using. It's probably you
Hmm
Oh, yeah
Um, yeah mercy mercy knows all
Uh, I know quite a bit
And I'll tell that to the other girls
But only when people are being nice
I don't tell them any rude
totally un
Unconstructive stuff
Um, like if somebody comments my maros or someplace else
I'm just going to be like, oh, they said you were cute and then we had a good collab together, etc
Detective hat and pipe on
Say the texas speech is a dare done by a friend of mine who tipped it and tried to pin it on me
Oh, was it now? Nice excuse crimson. Nice excuse
I have nothing to fear. I've been good
Mercy has a special eye, you know, she should just like take off that uh
The eye patch and she fucking knows all
I'm pretty sure she actually has superpowers, but she just isn't telling us yet. Um
That's a bummer we should have smashed
Perfect
Oh, yeah, I saw that clip over there that the chain saw and I was cracking up. I'm like, where did she get that fucking asset?
I
Any constructive contradictions, why do you guys ask me to give you constructive feedback on your
Fun time surprises that you send me
Please skip to blah
Please do this
Please skip to this time stamp if you want to avoid white man jumpscare yapping session
Oh my god, it's yeah, please don't be insecure with me. I am very sweet
Peer of you
I'm normally very kind
If you want me to be mean just tell me to do so and I will be mean
Constructive criticism bust harder
I love you for not taking crap from room temp IQ twats
I don't mean trolls just the snow lures that are trying to tell you what or how to be
Exactly. Thank you. I hate seeing talents. You guys are just feeding my ego today. Yes. Yes. Tell me more
This is from a day ago. So, um
Surely you don't need any consultant or advice on it, but I'm gonna praise madam for having a spine. You have so much promise
Yeah, like I've been around the block
Uh
Again, I used to be
In the youtube commentary community
So
Like I fucking know stuff like I have a spine people are fucking ruthless over there
um
Like I told you guys I used to work for fucking drama alert
I was an intern for a little bit
um
so like
You gotta have a fucking spine when you work in content creation
You can't
Be a little bitch because people are gonna bitch about you on the internet
They're gonna not be happy with what you do
They're gonna do this. You're gonna do that
The majority like honestly
It doesn't eat me up at all that people are like, oh, you don't do this for me
Or like, oh, you don't do this or you don't do that. It's it's just you say it over and over and over again
I'm like, please shut the fuck up. I don't care. I've said I don't care. Stop telling me it
Did you ever meet? No, I've never met Keemstar
I've had them with like once in passing
I usually just like passed off stories
um
I haven't seen a sent a mirror tweeted, but this reminds me of it. So I'll say it
I think you're already doing fine and kind of found it annoying when I was like, I need a Donmore
We're on to yeah, like what fans Lee might be another story late. Leah fans might be different
I thought drama alert was
Oh, I haven't watched that a very very long time. I've been out of that community for quite a bit quite a bit
um
after my
Former friends made the most stupidest fucking
Claim of all fucking time
um
Trying to bring someone down in the community. I hate I hate when people fucking lie
about stuff
Don't ever lie to me. Don't I'll figure it out
Uh
Keemstar just plays with people
I have a favorite song. My favorite song is um, Murakami by Maiden Heights
Oh
We'll need to get their panties on to this. You'll start it a week. Yeah, that's what people also need to like remember
that like yes, like we're
We're more seasoned than straw neons streaming as uh in everything, but
like it's only
It's almost been
It hasn't been two weeks yet. It'll be two weeks tomorrow
So
Like we just debuted on the first like you need to chill out
We're gonna even be even more comfortable with you guys in a couple months. We're gonna be doing this. We're gonna be doing that
You got like there's even the joke that vtubers change their voices
Like a month after debut because it's hard to keep the character on all the time unless you're like a professional professional voice actor
um or actress
uh
So like we're gonna grow a little bit more. We're gonna change. We're gonna be more comfortable with you
We're gonna learn more different parts of us. We're gonna be doing this and uh, whatever
Just yeah, sweetheart
sweetheart, just enjoy the ride
Enjoy watching a streamer that you really enjoy grow into a wonderful content content creator
Watch them flourish support them be happy for them
Okay, because that's what they would want from you
All we want to support us. I don't mean like monetarily
I mean just watch just fucking watch and talk to us. It's all we want
It's all we want
okay
Feels a lot longer for some reason
I know it does. I've I've said that before I just feel like it's we've been here for like a couple months already
Yeah, I love bubbly by kobi. Oh good song
Enjoy the ride. Yeah, enjoy the ride
Like when I I used to watch this small agency start out
And it was like I hadn't been into vtubers in a while
I'd like would occasionally watch like a hollow girl
Or like a needy saunty girl or whatever
Um, I need a burp. I can't
Um, excuse me, uh, nothing came out. I don't know why I said excuse me
But then I was like they're like, oh take the corporal pill take the small corporal pill. So I'm like, okay, I did and I watched this
company
And I was like
holy crap
These girls are so talented and interesting and funny and cool
And they have really cool designs
And then this and they're that
so like
And I just I just enjoy I just sat and I enjoyed and I watched them
And then when I was like busy at a work or whatever and I couldn't catch them
I tuned in a month later. I'm like, oh my god. They're doing this now
Do you know another month later? Wow, they're doing this now
Holy crap
They're they're growing. They're being more successful. They're getting more opportunities
That's like the funnest part is watching people grow
And watching them become so passionate about something
I'm gonna get to zero out of 10
And that agency was Albert Einstein. No, I'll be fucking honest. It was it was a and project
It was a project
I really fucking liked a and project
um
You know, I was a refling
Uh
Was a huge Killia fan
So I am she's great. She's a great fucking
Great fucking talent
I'm watching sky
Kiki was funny
Couldn't watch her because I didn't like Dota
Thank you Trigo
I've only been watching you for a little bit, but you are becoming one of my favorite vtubers
Your dom is probably one of the best I've seen to the point where I'm
Thank you. That's usually hard to do to me. Oh you blushing for me, baby boy. That's so sweet
all that when you blush
based um
Yeah, difficult history, whatever to be honest
Uh
None of us really care about it
Like we don't have any bad blood
um, because contents content
Companies different than their talents just how people see Nijisanji, you know
Not the best comparison, but you get what the fuck I'm saying
Because all you want like so for example, I just saw that
Uh kill you just fucking lost her
Whole setup in a fire
You think I'm gonna be a bitch and be like, oh, yeah, no, I'm like, holy shit. That's like she loves making content
She loves doing this. She loves doing that. I hope that her community helps her out
And like I'm like I want to help out. Is there like where can I donate like?
Yeah, it's it was fucking insane. I feel so she walked away from her computer
It sucks. It sucks
um
I would I would I like I've made I've told you guys some of you guys this before you might have heard me
Uh, right up my sweet little big chunky woman threw up in my case band once and shorted out my entire fucking computer when I turned it on
I was in shambles for like a week
And that's just like all I need to do is replace parts, but she lost
everything
Like it just shorted out my mobo and my I had to get a new like graphics card
So like
That fucking sucks. My heart goes out to her. Um, but yes, I loved watching these girls grow
And that was so fun like that's why I like watching like that's why I watch a humane plus
I love fucking watching them. They're so fucking funny. Mamosa watch Mamosa right now. I don't know. She's still in the chat but watch her
That's not very cool from your cat. I know stop it
She's hilarious. Oh my god. Oh you turn on light. Um
But
Yeah, it was just like it was
It was one of the funnest things to watch and yeah watching humane plus watching pixel link
When they came out watching, uh, the new idol girls
Like just like it just support them. It was so like it's so fun watching people evolve, you know
I love I love watching, uh, I watched cony when she first debuted and her now and I'm just like
I can't get enough like you're so fucking funny
Yeah, they're I'm like you guys are too small we're changing that you may plus too small. Fuck that
Um
I know that we don't
probably have
the best
rep or relationship
with other corpos because of past history
Um, but we are not letting that stop us mind you. Uh, we still want to make friends. We don't hold any bad blood
Um, we still in any corpo like we still want to be able to create opportunities to collapse
Uh, we just want to grow we just want to network
We just want to have fun
That's it
We're just here to have fun
We're here to make you happy
It's fucking it, dude
Um
Okay
I consent for this message to be public so I recorded the short audio of me moaning your name
I've never done anything like this
um
We have quickly become a hyper fixation of mine and I've always had interest in making sfw audio
So this is a very brief amateur point into that
I was in a couple script ideas set in wonderland with you as a listener
Which I might get around to writing recording probably that'd be something you're comfortable with
I hope things this thing's pretty to my madam. Um
Well, no, I'm not gonna play it now
They meant that like I can respond to it publicly is what they said
Uh, especially especially because they're not logged in so I'd have to respond to it publicly. Um
Hello fellow and project enjoyer. Um
Yeah, the new girls are cool too. I like uh, I like zoomie
If I can I'm frogging here like that's fucking funny to me. Um
Boston
This uh, yeah, no, I'll probably listen to it off stream
Um, I know this person is one of the regulars that I see talk in my chat often
um
I might give some feedback. I might
I really yeah, I don't know if I'm gonna read it or not or listen to it or not
I have to be I have to be the fucking mood for that, you know
Uh, the mayor may not be mine. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. See you. I see you
kind of feedback. Are you good like probably
Morgan, I don't even know why you want feedback for me because again, um
I don't
I've only just delved into nsfw audios myself. Uh, so I don't know if you really want critique for me
So I don't know if I could give you anything productive
I'm mostly I usually I just send stuff to strongy and I'm just like, hey, is this good? Is this good? Do I need to do this?
Should I and uh, should I have changed my cadence here? Should I change my, you know, how do I should I talk here?
Blah blah blah like that's what I do
Is she be oh
Um, but I will listen to that later. Um, just wanted to say you're doing great. She be me and the rest of the harem are
Super proud of you. Also, I haven't sent a room. I promise I will once I build up enough confidence
You don't have to if you don't want to
Just please like don't feel prepped just because everybody else is doing it
It's because all your friends are jumping off a bridge. Doesn't mean you have to do it till
Okay, don't feel pressured
You should like jump off a bridge or
She's like the authentic. Um
How do you critique on moans, you know, you can though
Because like you guys know mercy is also new to it
um
And so I remember she's just telling us so like
Strani gave her some like feedback like oh, can you sound like can you do it?
Let more like uh, she's like like uh, and we're like, yeah
Like you guys like we got
We are so comfortable with each other
Like you guys know we'll send our alt audios to each other sometimes before we post some be like, does this sound good?
Like do I sound weird and not in a
Like does this sound real trust me? It's all fucking real
It's all fucking real bud. Oh boy. Uh
If only I got video to go with it, um
But
Uh, we're very comfortable with each other and we will be like
Oh like cut this part out because you do sound kind of weird
Or maybe people will like it because you sound like you were dying. I don't know
Although none of us have actually said that we're all just like yeah the fucking rules post it. Yeah piss on piss piss piss
Yeah piss post the piss audio
Everyone just straight up peer-pressuring what time to join in house stream burning harem and hair uh, I'm not a harem a rabbit
Bye bye peeler. Oh my god peeler
What should I need to make more tea?
Mmm tea is good
Vealers uni will be iron but like we are very relaxed and kind of it's kind of
it's very refreshing being in vealer because
We don't have to hold back like strong always makes a dead joke like oh, we don't have a fucking hr department because like
And without that sort of like not like hr is actually good to have in normal cases, but like
We feel like we can truly be ourselves in vealer
um
I I'll even like I've said like my past life
Uh, I'll say her name because I'm just it's just easier to say like p. Oh, so when I was rena
Some of you might have known that I was rena
Oh rena. No
She was a cute little brown lolly cat and now I'm sheebie a big booby milfy bunny mubby. Um
I liked being rena, but I wasn't truly myself being rena
I actually feel more of myself as she be
Because I feel like I was
Sensoring myself so I could appeal to agencies. I want to join but then I ended up an agency where
I was just wanted to be me
Uh
And so I'm like, yeah fucking let loose like I feel like I
I've I've told my friends are like, oh, how do you like being a vealer?
I'm like, I feel like I'm an indie but I get all the fucking support of an agency
Like I can do what I want
And I'm I kid I am perfect like I can be professional. I'm not gonna fucking flash my titties but
um
It's nice having the support and like the feedback and the advice
and the analytics and just like brains behind like just so many people behind me and the girls
Supporting us trying to push us towards our dreams. That's all strong. He wants you just wants to push us towards our dreams
He just wants she wants she took just a couple of little girls
Especially me. I see in azura
With no fucking names
Because we were small as fuck
And like mercy was medium-sized and um emmy was a little bit bigger
But she was just like I want to help you
I'm giving you a chance
She's like starting who's saying there's a lot of big names that apply to the company
She didn't pick them because she's like, what are you gonna learn from me?
I want to help people grow and learn and I thank her every fucking day for that
Thank you for giving me a give me a chance
Hello, hello, welcome in you're all kind of crazy. Yeah and but you love it though
Let's be in here
No, uh again, I see them
As my girlfriends. No, uh, they're definitely close friends sisters
You thank your chief for blessing us with madam, but like even strong he was saying
To us before we did started stream. She said I receive a lot of marrows
Saying how wonderful you guys are and that I picked so well
And that I chose you and I made you and this and that and she's like she's like, I didn't do fucking anything
All I did was watch the video
And they put in so much fucking work and they charmed the pants off of of me and I had to bring them in
She's like you guys did that. She's like I just
I just said yes, you guys were meant for the role. I just said yes, and I'm like fuck
Hell yeah
I'm so thankful for that
Pants off. I see I see
Yeah, we're we're very happy. We're very happy
This is what I knew you may know me
Trying to stretch away with words and follow the woman to hell back. That's why that's why I liked her so much
That's why like I was so fucking determined to be part of the alert because I'm like I see I literally said in my
audition video
tomome
This is verbatim tomome
I see your vision
And I will do everything in my power to help you realize
A velar can be
And change the v2 being community
I'm tearing up a bit because I'm getting passionate
Oh my fucking back hurts today for some reason. I think it's because it's gonna rain tomorrow. My arthritis is acting up
I'm amazing amazing. I'm almost it. Yeah
um
And like that's like
like
Ah, I don't even yeah
We're family
Vin Diesel
At those 56, you know, I'm not joking guys
I do have arthritis because I ever since I had coven back when coven
You know happened, uh, it fucked up my body and so I have arthritis and my back really hurts right now
And my mom was just like, oh you have flare-ups like me because my mom's fibro
I have fibro 2 I discovered also
They think coven set off fibro in my body because usually fibro happens when you um have a big
event
In your body, it's like a like a bomb goes off in your body for my mom. It was having me surprise. I broke her. Um
And I think yeah coven coven just did a fucking number on me. I thought I was dying
um
And now I have so many fucking
Terrible things. Um, so but every time it's like gonna rain. I'm like, oh my god, they weren't joking
I'm like, I'm not that old
I'm in I'm in my 50s, you know, like
Pants off stream off
When I took the shot I was for yeah
Uh, I was actually I just had a really bad muscle pain when I took the shot
But when I actually got coven because I worked in
I was public facing
I was an essential worker. Don't know fucking why I'm a retail worker being an essential worker, but whatever. Um
I hope it's so fucking fast
Oh, yeah, it's funny. I get like none of no mask. No, I wore I wore a mask
I also wear it because my again, I've told you guys before my parents are immunocompromised
I'm not never going to put them at risk
I thought when my dad got COVID he was going to fucking die. So
Oh, thanks
Not putting my family at risk
Just so you could be missing my pretty face
I loved I loved the customer to a bitch
About wearing a mask. It was the funniest fuck ever. I'm like, you know, like there's a there was literally a customer
that
Actually shout out to this guy. Shout out to this one customer I had
um
Because this happened like back to back
So this one guy comes in complains that he has to wear a mask
Uh, because we were requesting masks
And I say, sorry, you can't come in if you don't wear masks, blah, blah, blah
Uh, he bitches and moans walks off like goes on his phone or whatever like a little bit away
This other man comes in has an oxygen shake with him
Uh oxygen mask on his face
In a normal mask on his face
Uh
Or not it was one of those like little insert things like those little tubes
I can't remember it for the oxygen
And he's like we're just chatting
And I'm like, you know helping him with his sale
And he's just like, yeah, this COVID shit's crazy
I ended up getting lung cancer because of it
Mind you the man's head that was I told him off like you can't come in
He like his head snapped up and looked around like, huh? He's like, yeah, I got
I have lung disease and lung cancer now
Because I caught COVID and that's why I have to use his oxygen
And I'm like, holy shit
And he's like, yeah, so I can I get myself for free and I was like, haha very funny
He's like, you know, I always have to try it. He's like the cancer things works. He's like, I was kidding though looks at me
I was like, honestly, if I could I would but I didn't get fired and I need this job
Oh, I would give stuff off to free so often if I could
Yeah, yeah, I'm like I I I'd say that because people would always ask me like, oh, can I get it for free?
You know, I'm like, I respect you for asking but no
Because like I do the same thing. I'll be like, hey, you know
You got any discounts?
I thought my least favorite thing is when people
Talk to me. I like to get to know me. Um, and I feel like
I think it's like part of our sales interaction and then at the end they're like, oh, so we're friends now
Can I get a fan friends and family discount? I'm like actually go
No
Um, okay
Is it true that before being a wage slave and a man of wonderland you may or may not be the legendary author
I guess this is bloody risk six six six one of the authors of classic piece young adult literature my immortal. Uh, yes
I'm totally her. I totally wrote my immortal
That was my personal diary
Um, somebody sent me a link to
Twitter. I'm not opening that
I used to hook up my friends when my work didn't care
Yeah, like I had like I like I'll give because we have a specific friends and family discount
So I'll I'll give it to them
It I would usually give my discount to people
that like
Like I would usually give my discount for people shopping for their kids for school
And they're like, I'm like, oh, yeah, I just have my discount or whatever because they're like
Oh, yeah, I'm getting this for my kid blah blah blah. I'm like, oh good for you
Like I'm like, I'm gonna help you out education is important. Um
Or just like
like I would just usually do it to like
Help out families that really wanted to provide something for their kid or like they needed it in their family for like a very important thing
Because like the work that I do
People usually tell me a lot of why they're buying something and so I'm like, oh, yes
Like interesting blah blah blah and then I always always make the joke that I was like also a retail therapist because people just tell me the most
out-of-pocket things
like this one lady who like was telling me that her
ex-husband tried to kill
Her and her sister and almost ended up killing her sister and actually no
I think he did kill her sister because he was trying to kill her. I was like ma'am
Uh
Your total is $9.95. Can you
I don't know what you want me to do about this
Man, I'm also a very empathetic person. So I'm like, oh, oh, oh my
Okay, I'm gonna read this exactly how it's written
Madame
You're so sexy
Uh
I can't type in chat. I would get banned immediately
Say
Thanks
Nice
cool
Very cool
Okay, uh, I can't talk about that
Uh, thank you so much for the bunny garden stream. Your dub was absolutely hilarious
I really gotta pee
You've definitely become the top viewer girl. I want to heavily support monetarily
Seriously, she's done a great job
Uh, strontis seriously done a great job picking you all
Now I'm curious if you have any plans to dub future visual novels or h games like honey pop
Again, thanks for the wonderful stream
And I'll be hoping and praying that you land a va role in an anime or video game. Thank you
Very kind. I appreciate that
um
Def I will probably
Maybe do a dub of like doki doki literature club probably. I think that'd be fun
um, I don't know if I'll be able to get to the full game, but
Maybe I'm like again, I lose interest and stuff very easily and I've already played and beat the game before so
um
But like it is one of my favorite games. So I probably would enjoy replaying it
I haven't played it in a very long time. Um, I'm kind of pissed that the developer didn't make a second one
Like he's fucking said he was going to
Because he was like almost doing like an ARG for something that was related to like what Yuri was
Reading in her fantasy books and then he just never fucking did it
Or am I tripping and that did happen. I just didn't hear about it
Oh, who'd you voice act for doki doki doki? No, I like I I dub all the characters
my uh, uh, you need to go and watch my um, bunny garden, uh
Playthrough you can uh, just go into that skip ahead because I yap a little bit
Trauma dumping is extra
um
I appreciate that you want to support me monetarily above everybody else, but please spread that wealth to the other girls
Yeah, I don't know. That's all I can really say about that. Uh, I'm really glad a lot of you seem to really enjoy the
The bunny garden dub and it was actually so fun to do. I haven't had that fun much fun in the stream
Uh, in a very long time
It was very enjoyable
Uh, can't open that
Hello, she be you mentioned having your nippies pierced on stream
I was wondering do you have any piercings if so where also will be receiving to open
Open to receiving some jewelry for them on throne
Um, again, feel free not to answer. Let me met him. Uh
My ears. I don't know. Yeah, my ears
No, I would probably not put jewelry on my throne for that because I'm very particular
Well, what I put on and in my body technically
Um, because some of that stuff can be
Can cause like an allergic reaction or my body can reject the jewelry
Um, it is not fun when that happens. I have had
Uh, one of my, uh, nippy piercings reject jewelry
And I want it to fucking die. So no, thanks. Uh, I appreciate the thought though
Uh, yeah, I hurt like a motherfucker. Um
If you ever get a piercing let's go for any piercing by the way
Um, and you're starting to reject it swap the jewelry out immediately clean it
Uh, do surgical grade
Uh, I also because my, um
Maybe started to keloid
But like you have to be more susceptible to keloids and genetically
Being brown. I am more susceptible to keloids. I just put a little green tea not green tea
Tea tree oil on it went away real quick. So if you guys have are considering that
Please, uh, go to a piercer
Do not do what I fucking did and just go to a mall
I got my tits pierced at Claire's
Uh, your body like reject. Yes. Yeah, uh, just like a normal ear piercing some people
Uh, their body rejects the metal or they have a allergic reaction to it. Um, another thing with, uh, nippy piercings is that they never truly heal
The holes cannot close
close
They never actually truly heal. Um
I have had mine for
Four years now
um
They like there is a certain point where they feel they are like considered like healed and that's usually after a year
So it's like gauges. No my fucking nipped. It's a normal barbell. What the fuck?
I would not gauge that. Holy shit. Did you actually do it at Claire's? No
It was it was like some like body jewelry place. It was like a fucking it was like the equivalent of like spencer's
What they had like a piercer there
No, I don't have any gauges. I don't know. My mom would bully the fuck out of me if I had gauges
My little ear. I have cute little ear lobes. I have cute little lobes. My ears were pierced when I was a baby my ear my um
me
My and my holes have never closed because of that for some reason. So like I haven't worn earrings in a really long time
um
But they never close
Walmart piercings
Hole not healing but now how huge the hole well the hole is small
Like hold on. Let me just look at my nipple
like
I don't know. It's like
I can't
I don't know what to tell you as like a comparison
I don't know what to be like. Oh, it's like this big. I don't
It's like a little thicker than a paper clip. No, it's it's a little bit thicker like a paper clip yet
I don't I don't just go why don't you just look up some titties, dude
She be you giving this for free. I don't care. I'm very open and honest with you guys and if you don't like it
Sorry, I'm not for you then or or like I mean and then in the case of like if you don't like that I have that
Rtx version it's not on my model and you're never gonna see him so
Yeah, so you don't have to worry about ruining your immersion. I'm catholic. That's too bad
Does have a design. Uh, no, just they're just gold barbells
They're just gold barbells
Because gold looks better on my skin tone. I usually only wear gold silver just looks weird non cosplay. Let's go
The girls have seen my non cosplay
my none cosplay
Very nice, um
Uh, I probably wouldn't get any more piercings because they're hard to maintain. Um
Um
Yeah, I also didn't
Get piercings because I did jujitsu and it you can't really have piercings in your face
Or even in your ears sometimes
Like because you'll just get you'll just get ripped out
Yeah, I only could manage with the ones on my chest because I'm wearing a bra
Like I have this it's coverage
Uh
New series ASMR dramatic readings of cringe fanfics
Yes, I'm definitely I want I'm gonna I'm finishing my immortal guys. Sorry
You were on to some wait
Oh, you were on to something but we can take it further beyond
and
RJ is tongue-punch your fart box a b-shay could be throat choke your gluteum
My classic shag might be
Dirt kick your kid cannon
That's pretty good actually
I think the worst face piercings might be the tongue lips and the nose like from worse to least because of whatever rips
Eek. Um, I have a lot of alternative friends. Um
That have a lot of piercings
uh
Trying to think yeah, my friend has like a septum and both her nostrils pierced
um
She wanted to get a smiley and then went against it a smiley is when they pierce your
What's it called?
Like the little like it's like a piece of skin above your gum
Like where you're little like a little like dingley. Yeah, you're friend. You'll um
I don't think people know what a friend you'll am is though
Ow, I'm gonna take this bra off. It's fucking bothering me
My nippies are dry
Also, if you get piercings on your nippies make sure you lotion your nippies just saying
Dang, I oh my friend you'll um
Um
Yeah, it's like they have never oh
Actually, you know like my so my friend has a daughter
And her face is is pierced and her daughter almost ripped out her nose piercing and so she was she was just like I might have to take them out
She almost needed that
Nope, no smiley. Nope. Nope. Actually, I like I like the way it looks. I would not do it on myself
Like I would not put anything around my mouth
Like, you know, I get a little cute like nose pierced thing
You know a little like a little like a little gem or some shit like when like a little white girl gem, you know
You know
Hold on. Nope
But like I remember I like I got one of those like fake
septum piercings to see what I would look like with it
Uh, I'm like, no, this is not fit my face like because there's stuff that's like
Fits your face type. I won't lie to you. Some people get the most dumb ass piercings on their face
um
And they look
Ridiculous because it doesn't fit their face like some people
But some people do it as like self-expression and like, you know go for that
But some people get it
Because they want it to like accentuate a feature or like make them look a little bit better
And I like I'll see some people with a certain type of nose get a septum and I'm like
I
know
Myself included
Full half circle and my mom's like you better not better not ever get one of those
Because there was a girl in my church that was like everybody was like freaking out because she ended up getting a
A septum piercing. She's like, please. I don't want to I don't have to rip it out your nose. You're not a ball. You're not a ball
You're not a ball
See how the high septum
Oh, yeah, so I'll like I'll get like those clip piercings. Yeah, I'll be like, oh like a little fake shit
And it's good to actually get those if you're like wanting to um
My cat's food is going off. Um
Test something because that's what I'm so happy. I didn't just go in and get a nose piercing. I know I'm gonna look like shit
Yes, some can rock it some cannot I am one of those people
You're you're fine. I like you probably look great
I don't know what you look like dude. You can probably
You might look amazing with it
Um
I like dirt kick your kid cannon
Can we get an automated feeder? No, you're not good enough for that. My cats are my children. You are not
Oh
I should make y'all get like an earring y'all get to wear like an earring
um
as if you're like
cows that I've
tagged
That's so fucked. Oh, never mind
No, she be merch
I'm gonna tag your ears
Because you're my uh, you're my product that I sell on the street
It sounds like it would hurt probably does
We're getting brand- oh branding is also an option. Thank you for reminding me
Man, I really gotta
Piss piss piss
Gotta piss piss piss
Milk tagged and branded precisely you get it
We're here to help man. We're bulls
Um
Hope the num nuts don't put you off marrows at all not to imply you haven't been doing enough
I think we're all very grateful for the extra engagement since we already love you to bits madame is clearly too strong minded
To let whatever brain lits you had shut down the or shut down the other day effector
I'm just a worry worried clingy boy slut. I'm fine, but thank you
um
Sometimes, you know what like I like I'm doing right now. I'll have to like go out and address stuff
Um, I probably won't talk about that again. I'm just gonna ignore it because I don't I hate repeating myself
It says one of my pet peeves. Uh, if you don't get it the first time, I'm just gonna remove you from my site
I do not want to look at you. I do not want to perceive you because you cannot follow simple directions. Whoo
A child could follow simple directions a dog can follow simple directions
You are an adult you can't so
Get blocked
Um, why must you hurt me by shaving?
What my little my uh, my little retweet game
It was a little before exactly
There's gf had went to a parlor for tats. I got on the offer for branding tats
Bro, sorry. He saw skin still on the thing and gf was cool. Oh
Oh
Oh, that's so fucked up
Oh, they do that
On their skins. Oh
Sick. All right, we're gonna do that. Sweet. Uh, everybody line up. I'm gonna put this into the fire
Okay, you ready bend over show me your ass spread your cheeks. I'm doing this in your asshole
I'm showing a hot poker up your asshole
Me first
That's really smart of him to put the pin in wrong. So yeah, I would
That's also like
Do you really should you have to do that
Okay, see he's not scared. Why are you scared? It'll hardly only hurt for like a minute in the rest of your life. So
Like I don't I don't think I could be with the person who wanted to fucking brand themselves
At a shady ass tattoo parlor. No, thank you
Uh, I still have a bush anyways moving on
Uh, just wondering how do you feel about AI gend images of sheebie?
I know it is an art, etc
And it wouldn't drop it in your tags probably just I don't know what that word is if anywhere
Uh, if you put some time into learning how to use it these days, you can output some nice looking stuff
This is the usual slop it require creating a trained model of your image though
Which I want to do without your thumbs up or just I don't care how well
Thanks for streams regardless. Uh, please do not make AI art of me
Using my model, please do not feed my model
uh
Into any sort of AI thing if you're like
Just like generating stuff and one just happens to look like me. That's fine. But please do not
Take my model
Do that like I
Am an artist. I also just I don't like it just doesn't look good
Like what is what is that? Uh, there was like a meme. I think it was like a flork meme like
uh these like
This the sex uh post don't mean anything nor anymore. There's no like life behind them. There's not enough horny or whatever the fuck
Um, yeah, they look weird the art style isn't consistent
Um, I'm not a huge fan as someone who's an artist
I'm not a good one, but I'll say I'm an artist. Uh, I would hate that
Uh, I'd rather you draw a shitty picture of me
Yourself, that's it. Um
Again, I can't
Really police that it's really just like a trust thing
Um
If you do it and I see it
I'm just probably not going to acknowledge it
Sorry
Yeah
I just busted a fat fucking note on the final image of your twitter game. What are you gonna do about it? Nothing
I don't care
Some of you have that you talk to me
Like you're trying to tease me. You're like, oh, what are you gonna do about it? No, I don't like brats
I'm not I don't like brats. Just behave be a good boy. Sit down bust them out and enjoy yourself. Jesus Christ
These white boys be tripping walk away
Is it considered criminal if it's taking three different art styles and blending them together to make a new style
Yeah, because it's still not original. That's not
It's not
that a whole I'm not gonna like go through a whole AI art debate
because
Like I just said like
I'm not a huge fan
in like when I first was um
My twitter using my twitter
I liked like a lot of AI art
Because I didn't know it was AI and then I go in and I'm like wow the person might have worked must have worked super fucking hard on this
Wow
And I looked in their point their fucking profile and they're like generated using blah blah blah and I'm like oh the fuck
And I went on an unlike shit and then my whole like I kept getting tricked
I still get tricked and I'm like dude. Just give me good artists
Just give me good artists and I'd like actual real artists, please
Oh, but I worked so hard already this prompt this prompt. That's how do you think about you?
I'm just burping while you're talking because I don't care. Um cool
Or whatever. I guess
Wow
gosh
Yeah, it's because a lot of the AI art has a distinctive style because there's like one person they mostly fed the algorithm on
um, I forget what the artist's name is I remember, um
Reading it the other day. He's like a famous comic artist
Remember an AI broke out ratioed by one piece to animator
I remember when like crony called out and a not even she didn't even call somebody out
She's just like, I don't like this. Can you put this someplace else and they're just like this is an AI and it's like freaked out
Um
They put why must you hurt me by shaving twice in one hour relax
Relax, I got it the first time you don't have to send it to me twice
Unless you think you made a mistake then I guess I can't really blame you for that
She just said you oh, yeah, that's what it was. Sorry. I don't really pay attention that much
Wait, you're half black. How can that dumpy not clap? Did your white half funnel it all to your chest?
What a travesty she we should have the back bedonk-a-donk that is her god's given right and then her back which suffer less too
That's not how it works. Also. She could have suffocated the entire harem under her bodacious cheeks such an injustice. Um
I still have a fat ass
Wait, I did I literally just tried to move my model as if I'm gonna turn around
But uh, you can just pretend by my hips
And how my thighs are
But yes, it's big. Oh by the way, um when I was messing around with trans making my stuff transparent
Uh
I got to see my butt fangs
I didn't know I had any
And I was like, oh
They were whoo
They were fangin
They were banging and fangin
Um, so yeah, you don't have to worry about that
My nose is itchy
um
It's funny because my dad's side all of big butts
And my mom has a big butt
But I just don't I guess
I've been told I have
A big butt, but I just don't believe people so I could be wrong, you know
I could be wrong
Because I just look at strawberries. I'm like, I don't have that
Me with my flat ass, yeah, but you're a man, so you're fine
Hello, madame
Would you be so kind as to bless us with your thigh peak once again?
I thought I had saved the day you blessed us, but apparently I'd not I checked your twitter
I'm not to rectify my grievous mistake, but sadly you had already deleted as much to my dismay
No, I'm not going to you can just wait for the thigh cam
I was tired of people being like damn you have the goosebumps and I'm like
Haven't shaved
I didn't shave my legs for like three days
Um, and by the way a lot of girls legs look like that even when they do shave
Uh, they just apply a lot of filters to their shit
I believe anything you see posted on the internet. Um
Anyways, you fast become my oshi. I love the energy you bring and I'm glad you let your true self try
True self shine through. I've been an enjoyer vtuber since COVID lockdown days. I never truly had an oshi
And I'm glad to call you my oshi. May you you and all the rest of you will be blessed with success and happiness
That was so nice
Wow, the fact that you think
I am your oshi and you haven't been able to find one and then you see me and I've only been here for like a week
And uh, that means a lot to me. You don't yeah that just
I just like it's hard for me to like
Like why the fuck maybe we like me like it's
That's just but that's that's everybody everybody has a little side of themselves are like, yeah, but why like how
Why could you like me like how could you because it's so hard
to like sometimes accept compliments and reflect on yourself and be like, oh, I do have good qualities and um
Like I definitely love myself
But I and like I practice self-love, but I just a lot of stuff. I feel like I don't deserve
Yes, imposter syndrome. Um, and that's what happens. Like I was very small when I was rena
Uh, I probably I at most had like a 50
Uh
ccb like current viewership
um
I only had like a couple regulars in my chat. I mostly had lurkers
So when I go from that to the sort of audience I have now
Lots of eyes on me lots of support lots of the it's just it's very overwhelming
That goes for all the girls. I know mercy is dealing with the same thing right now
It's like we all can't handle
being liked as much as we are because like
We expected so much more hate
We were fucking mentally prepared to get absolutely shit on by the community
But it didn't happen. We are okay. And that might be actually due to because we didn't get any sort of coverage from like the drama channels
um
because
like
like after we like I um
A lot of people admitted
That they're like, oh, I thought you were going to crash and burn
Or this was gonna happen or that was gonna happen
um, and then they watch us
And they're like I was actually wrong and I love you
And I'm like, please just like give people a chance. Yeah, you look at a small agency starting up
They can surprise you like you may plus surprise me. They have wonderful talented girls
Um when they first showed up, I remember I was gonna apply to them when they first
Opened auditions, but I it was too busy with my real job. So I didn't get around to it. Um
I could have ended up there, you know
It ended up in the other places I applied to
um
Just yeah, and that's okay. You can totally admit like I was one of those people. I was like a naysayer
because
You assume the it's not an unusual thing for people to assume the worst so they avoid being disappointed
But I'm happy
That we were able to surprise and delight everybody with how
Wonderful we all are
Collectively and we all have different niches and different styles and different
Ways about how we um go about things
Um
So, yeah
Thank god the worst case scenario didn't happen everybody's like, oh, I remember my favorite comment my favorite negative comment that I saw was
How long is it gonna take
For one of them for it to come out that one of them is a sexual predator and I'm like Jesus fucking christ
Are you serious?
There are so many loutubers in the vtuber community and you be you just assume
That we're gonna be sexual predator like what?
I was like that was just like out of malice or something like do you you just you don't want us to succeed and that's why you said that
like
That like blew me away generally and this is before I even gotten to be alert
like even just like being a normal viewer and being excited for the girls like I had like the
Auditions hadn't even opened yet type thing
They're like it's gonna be so funny when one of them gets out as a sexual predator or this i'm like
what the hell
There's so many different loutubers that are normal people like melody
Partic melody is a lovely person. She's so sweet her normal streams are adorable
And then you know you realize people just love to hate
What they don't know
We're on a stand yet because we are the first of our kind
being a lewd focused
YouTubeing agency
Normally that isn't the standard
So I can't blame some of you who are who are just like, uh, I don't really think this will work
um
But I will explain the people that are like they're probably horrible human beings like that was I just thought that was a totally
Terrible thing to say about people you didn't even know yet
And again, I wasn't even a talent yet. This was like way back when
dealer was announced
I was like damn I feel bad for those girls
When they get picked wow I'm here. Um, yeah reflects more on the speaker. I'm like, what are you saying? What have you done?
Hmm. Hmm
um
Melody collapse someday that'll be great. I hope so
I would love to learn from her
Um, I feel like she could teach us a lot
Her loves to hate and find any reason to do so. Have you seen any of the joked drama? I was like, I don't even know who that is
What's that? Who is that?
I think a lot of people just want to watch dramas again. That's true. People love drama
um
That sort of stuff pulls eyes gets views
um, I know that false only really covered us because there was a lot more vocal
angle to like
Actually, it was I feel like it was kind of even on both sides in terms of like
who was
Not for it and who was and even like, um kaiyo
And he's was more like a little bit unbiased when he covered the
um
The announcement of velour again. This was me
Observing this when I wasn't even a talent when they first announced auditions
Um, or not. They first announced the company
before they announced auditions, um
He was just like they both I noticed they both started off with the
A good amount of negative comments that were said about us and like responding to the tweet of them going
Going live
um, and then they followed up in the
There's their cover their cover story of like one or two or three nice things
And I was like
And then all the like the comments that were boosted were the more negative ones like yeah, I don't really see this working out
They're probably gonna burn out or they're probably not gonna want to do it
Or they're probably gonna do this and probably gonna do that
Or he just can wait and see what happens
Um, everyone's going through their own battle attack them now. They're fighting two battles. Boom. Yeah
Did you decide you I was the first person who applied?
Starny said I applied 20 minutes after stuff opened
Uh, I was the first person to apply
To be there
That is because I recorded my video three days in advance because I was so anxious. I'm getting it perfectly
I worked really hard on it
I
Yeah, that's the uh
I was ready. I wanted this for since
a certain rtx
strongy mentioned doing it again
Making her own company. I'm like, I'm in I want that. I didn't think I would get in
I was so ready to be disappointed. You have no idea
but
Yeah, I'm here
And I'm so happy I am
Happy I get to be with you guys
I will just say this melody right now is the godmother of lutubers and she we learn a lot. Yeah, like I'm always
Uh, like there's a lot of lutubers in the community. Um, that are of course way bigger than us. Um
People like to like crack jokes and be like, ah
Everybody's freaking out because like viewers the competition. We're not
We're not established. We're just starting out
Um, yes, we are have certain strategies to get support with like our patreon. We have like, you know cheaper options
um
well like
And I can speak for all the girls. We actively want to learn
from
the bigger vtubers in the community
because we
can learn a lot
like
We're just starting out
A bunch of us were very small before we were in a v in velar
And didn't even dream of being in a corpo
uh
I've only been a vtuber for six months like I've said
and
But mind you I've still worked very hard to be here. Don't get it twisted. Um
If I can grind it out for a very long time
I heard a velar when I first announced I forgot about it. I only remembered that they have to be a lot of people were like that
Was funny, uh
Lost face to grow. Yeah
Yeah, it's there are a lot of luteubers, but again, there's not a there's not
Corpo
luteubers, um, there are
I can't stop burping with the fuck
um
there are
girls in corpos that
really
Fucking dance that line
Of being completely on say so and doing crazier stuff than
Or stuff as much as us
And they just like but they like dress it up in a cute little bow and be like
I'm not doing anything bad. Um
There's those girls
We just say the we I always make the joke we just say the quiet part out loud
we're like
Because like a lot of a lot of fucking girls and agencies are like us. They just
They're just not allowed to do what we do
They would probably make the content if they um wanted to
Um, and if they were allowed to by their by their uh companies
Never heard of you learn till debut personally. Yeah, and that's fine. Like I'm it's glad you're here
Glad you're here. If you just just caught us on debut if you knew from the beginning
Um, if you followed strontae before she was strontae then
Yeah, just
You can't you were here for a reason
You're here for a reason
I almost said a reef link. You're here for a reason rafling. Um
But yeah
You can't say I've gone sph for mothers, but you'd be surprised
They're you'd be surprised because they again they dress it up as other things
They they tease you with uh, but they just use different words, but it's the intention
Is that
Um, but some people now you can just enjoy being you know, the bluntness of just being like, yeah
I want you to boop out of my beep and made it with a beep on boo with a boop like all that shit. Um
Yeah
I apologize for being too needy and chat madam
You scolding us and ording around honestly
Can't read that part. Uh, let me she be also you're not a whore you're a madam
That's funny. Um
These are just really so exciting at 10 times. Um, I don't really think you guys are needy
You want I think you got we like some of you complain a lot
But lately since I've like I said something the other day everybody's kind of shut up. I noticed
Which is finally nice
So I guess I will just be more
Straightforward because normally again, I'm a very nice person. I don't like being mean. Um
And so sometimes
I don't want people to think
That I like genuinely hate them
Because to be honest with you
I just don't have the energy to hate people on the internet that just say a mean thing about me
When I'm just being an anime girl. So like
Um, yeah
When I was
Also, you're not a whore you're a madam
Uh, while I was thinking of she be uh, your name warped in my thought to
Shibizi which is very rude. BZ is not a good word for women and I don't think we use BZ. What does that mean?
Should I not say that out loud?
Did I fucking just say something inappropriate?
It
Means bitch formally used for women
Oh, it means it's a slang term that means someone who is okay. It's like a bitch. Okay
Okay, cool
We're not getting cancelled. We're fine. It's just it was just used to be slang for like just essentially just like
A colloquial off word slang for a woman boomie. Hi, mr. Titties. Can you get your asshole out of my face?
You're gonna clean your ass boy. Oh, you are so heavy. Hello, handsome
What's up? You just want attention?
You just want attention?
Do you guys already all eat your all your food?
I need to refit refill your um feeders
You put you down. Oh my god. You're so heavy. I think he's like
15 pounds now. He's such a big cat
It's all fucking muscles
Like in my castle tree
What's this
Oh, what's this? You want chicken?
Oh, you want chicken?
Want chicken?
And you do the move
That's the fucking game wire
No
Are you guys, like it like a baby girl
Guys, I can't put it on your plate if your faces are in the film, I'm good.
Back up.
Here, relax, relax.
Come on.
Right now! Right now! Right now! Right now, where'd you go? Right now!
Oh, right there. Right, here you go, Mom. Shhh! I don't need to.
Here, come up. Do you know how to get down? You'll get confused.
Like, I jumped up here, but I don't know where to go.
Fuck...
Okay, give him some wet food as a little treat.
No, I know you guys can hear me. It's not like... I don't care if you can hear me.
My informant's fucking small. I only mute for pee.
I cover all intensely. Let's make sure I talk to our cats.
What am I reading?
Bad mute? I didn't mute.
Distant she be my blood. A flavor of wet food, I give him chicken.
Oh, is it like those small shorts about little Jimmy who moved bricks for a year and only got an apartment for two square? What?
I love the stuck in the closet in your house, roughly.
Mute for pee, bad mute. Oh, I see.
And once they dried cat food as a kid, that explains a lot.
It's not like... My house is like pretty normal size, to be honest.
Like, it's actually bigger than my childhood home, but my childhood home was really small.
I just have an open concept in my apartment, so that's why it's echoey when you can like...
Yeah, when I walk away, because they're like, ah!
Sorry, I don't mean to blow out your fucking eardrums.
So like, I have my living room area on one half of the room, then I have my kitchen area on one half of the room,
and then I have my bedroom, and then I have a bathroom, and then I have a giant walking closet,
because it honestly doubles as a bedroom if I want it.
Like, I literally probably put it at like a little like sleeping bag down.
Guys can sleep over, we can have a little sleep over.
We are in the walls.
It screws apart from on, where the cage goes.
Yeah, the cage is um... Actually, the cage is in the living room right next to the TV,
so you can have some sun, um, because like, I have a balcony as well.
I need to get furniture for my balcony.
I've lived here for almost like two years, and I still don't have fucking balcony furniture,
and like, I go outside and I just stand there awkwardly.
Oh, I got a fart.
Nice.
Um, hammock for the butt.
No, it's not big enough for that.
I'd probably get like one of those cute little like, suspended egg chair things,
or like something I could put my feet up on, just curl up with a book and a blankie.
I told you, you only get one tooth for free on stream.
Can you find it? I don't know if you can.
It's been there.
Happened in another stream, not this video.
Uh, anyways, um, the rest of this message makes absolutely no sense.
Actually, it makes sense, but like, this person was rambling and it's kind of funny.
They're just like talking about like, the entomology of the word, BZ,
and like, references and pop culture of the word.
That's kind of funny.
This is sorry at the end.
Probably baked.
Honestly, sounds like it.
Shibi, you know what would be really silly?
You should put Ona on throne and pretend to tie us and use it on us while degrading us for ASMR or a joy for Patreon.
Would that be silly and funny?
And ha ha.
Anyway, love you, you goofy bitch.
Enduring.
Um, I don't.
You want me to buy an Ona and use it on what?
One of my doze?
One of my doze of dild?
Like, I don't, I'd be like, oh, like, I'm gonna look so weird.
Oh, damn you.
Damn you.
Um, the maintenance man is gonna come in for me.
I ran into him again, by the way.
I ran into one of the guys, the one of the maintenance men that came in.
One of them fucking hates me.
The other one was nice.
And he held the door opened for me when I was bringing in a giant with a giant ass packages.
You guys got me from throne.
I'm like, I'm carrying all my horror merchandise.
What do you think you do again?
No, for those of you who don't know, my maintenance men came to change my air filter.
And oh, hi, Raina.
Did you enjoy your chicken?
She just like flopped into my arms.
How cute.
Oh, are you going in the bed?
Okay, there you go.
Um, they knocked on the door.
I had my headphones on.
I didn't hear them.
So I didn't answer.
They let themselves in thinking it wasn't home.
They realized I was there.
They're like, oh, hey, we're just here to show the filter.
And I'm like, okay, weird that they didn't like set a notice ahead saying that they're
going to do that sort of stuff.
I realized after they left, I had left toys everywhere in a door hanger thing that says
do not disturb, but masturbate.
And then one of them told on me for having cats.
They have an extra cat.
I have a bonus cat.
I think it was a dude that always looks at me to discuss when he sees me.
The other guy just like looks at me sheepishly like he doesn't know what to do with himself.
Um, they're new because like we, I, I'm like, they go through maintenance men so much because
there was another guy that came in like a month ago to fix my, because I have a trash.
What is it called?
Uh, trash disposal.
And it wasn't working because it wasn't like there was like some, apparently I thought
something came on screwed, but there was apparently just like something in there that got stuck.
Um, and it was like this totally different guy.
And then there's other guys.
Okay.
I'm like, I've never seen you before.
Who are you?
And that's why I was like, I initially freaked out cause I'm like, I've never, these, you
are not the normal maintenance man.
The fuck?
There was somebody before that and I haven't seen them.
I'm like, they're killing the maintenance men.
They're just like, you didn't do a good job.
Death.
They're just replacing them like, like, uh, cast members and they're hoping that you don't
even notice.
Um, but yeah, what?
I thought like half just growling, but something was just like, there's like, sometimes a,
my bathroom fan like vibrates a certain way and it's freaked me out.
Um, man, I hate when rental staff don't give the heads up.
Oh, at least an apartment that way.
Yeah.
That's why I'm like, I feel like legally and where I'm from, they're not allowed to do
that.
They have to give 24 hour notice.
So I was going to bring that up when I went to the landlord and I was like, Hey, you guys
technically came in when you weren't supposed to get a heads up.
I was from the spot.
That's why I said you could come in and it ended up being like, I, but I didn't even
have to use that because the lady was chill anyways.
It was just the other bitch property manager that was being annoying.
I was like, Oh, you're, you're fine.
You're a good tenant.
And I'm like, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
I got you for maintenance, man.
As a person who mainly came for the Fendham vibes, I was shocked that I got a female bro
along for the ride.
Oh, bro.
Looking forward to your future endeavors and hopefully you get more of those awesome
dubs of yours.
Yes, you are more dubs coming soon, coming right at you like right in your face, coming
in your face.
Don't you, don't you worry about it.
Um, yeah, you're my bros.
We're bros and sometimes make out.
Sometimes, you know, some of you, my boyfriend, girlfriend, if you're into that, you know,
boyfriend, girlfriend, Ryan Gosling voice, boyfriend, girlfriend.
Don't, you know, let me get to your head.
Okay.
Some of you are dogs and I'm your owner.
You can decide what you want us to be.
I will give you that one freedom.
Okay.
This got that GF bro.
Yeah, I can be your bro, Brogif, your bro GF Brogif, you know, but I'm glad that like
I, I'm happy that I pleasantly surprised people because people are like, oh, she's going to
be like this really reserved Dom and be like this and like that and just be like really
like, really like maybe like coup d'etre.
Um, I thought about being that and I'm like, you know, I'm going to be my authentic.
Nah, I'm going to do me.
Um, I want to be my authentic self.
I don't like lying and then it probably would fade away after a month or two anyways.
Authentic self, best self.
Yeah.
So even though the other girls struggle with that, be like, oh, should I act a certain
way?
And then in the end, like strong, he just really nailed.
She's like, I hired you for you.
I didn't hire you because like of this, this or that you could do this voice or do that
or do that.
Like I hired you for your personality and I was like, takes mom wipes away tears.
Um, you can be my ex.
I got everything in the divorce.
Sorry.
Shut it in a prenup.
Um, if you were to hypothetically allow us to send proof of us following instructions,
what would that be?
If the answer to above is I might be going too far.
Could we chat, get a bonk instead?
Uh, most of you have already done so.
So I'm like, I guess I'm fine with it.
I don't know.
Um, yeah, I don't.
I bonk chat anyways.
We're bonking right now.
Okay.
Sorry.
Let me refresh this.
Oh, now I have to go through and physically answer these.
Eventually, maybe I won't.
I might be a little bit too lazy for that.
Um, I need to scratch my booty.
My booty cheeky.
Um, outside of a stream chat and especially on other social media platforms, what would
you say their dues and don'ts when coming to talking comes to talking interacting with
you?
Uh, you guys have interacted me with me pretty normally.
I can't really think of anything that sticks out besides the people that have complained
about like the doming on like not being a dom enough.
But I've already addressed that, uh, going forward from the stream.
I'm not going to address it anymore.
You're just going to get blocked and ignored because, uh, madam shouldn't have to repeat
herself, especially to dumbasses who complain like that.
Um, into the other girls too, by the way, if you complain about them.
Oh, I see.
Isn't this enough?
Amy isn't this enough?
Mercy isn't this enough?
Azura isn't this enough?
Strawny isn't this enough?
I'm just literally going to ignore you.
Just like there's so many other girls, uh, in different agencies and Indies that will
probably be better up your alley then.
Um, I'm not a pushover.
I'm not going to bend to your will.
Uh, I am in control here.
Do not forget that.
Uh, I think I'm trying to think of, uh, probably maybe the people that like role play being
Dom with me, like that's kind of, it's not even like, oh, you're trying to like
Dom me because I'm a dom or like fighting for, you know, being the alpha or whatever
the fuck.
It just comes off so fucking cringy.
Like, like somebody sent me something like, oh, what if I were to come in and tie you
to the bed and use you the way that I want to, and then you don't have, you don't get
to say anything and I get to be used, use free use.
I'm like, I just didn't respond.
I just blocked him as the next person.
I'm like, I wouldn't do anything, uh, because that wouldn't happen.
I would call the police.
Uh, like, yeah, they're trying to find the switch button, but it's like, it's not, you're
not going to get that.
Like the, you're not like, I am a Dom first and foremost.
My audios might reflect differently because the scripts I have to fill on stream.
I'm your mother.
You do well to behave.
All right.
Uh, I'm your madam.
I'm your mother.
I'm your owner.
I wear the pants in the relationship.
You do not.
Uh, I might be sweet.
I might be nice to you because I'm a human being and Dom's aren't dicks all the time,
by the way.
I hope you knew that.
Uh, they're just not fucking beating the shit out of people 24 seven.
That's fucking stupid.
If you think that, um, I'm going to be nice to you when I want to be.
And I'm going to treat you terribly when I see there's an opportunity and you seem that
you want me to do that.
Um, could you be my father too?
Yeah.
I'm your daddy.
Call me daddy.
Call me daddy right now.
I'm waiting for it.
When did you call daddy and chat?
Perfect.
Oh, actually, I like being called daddy.
Hello.
It's kind of, it's kind of hot seeing like guys be like, yes, daddy.
It's kind of hot.
I don't know.
Did that just awaken something in me?
Damn.
Maybe it's like the corruption.
Um, noted.
Uh, I think that's definitely like a gender role thing, like reversal.
Like I am, I'm the man, this relationship or the woman.
Maybe that's, maybe that's it.
I don't know.
I have to dive into that.
She got unlocked again.
Dad, please put the belt down.
Not again.
Not the belt.
That shit hurts.
I've hit myself with a belt because my mom, my mom and my dad were like, oh, we were
going to use a belt.
You're lucky we don't use a belt on you.
And I'm like, yeah, this doesn't hurt.
And I was like, ah, on my arm.
Daddy, she be model one, like as in my dad, dad or like me as a dude, because I would
look, I would be the sexiest.
What is it?
Ikeman, Ikeman, Ikeman, Ikeman.
I was deaf spanked as a kid.
Okay.
I have to share that.
Oh, to be belted by daddy, she be.
That's me come to papa.
And you just like not on my leg or something because you're humping it or whatever.
Yeah, I think just people trying to be that because they're like, yeah, they're trying
to like, think I'll be submissive with them.
Um, no, no.
Even if you like, even if I was like, like if I was in like icy shoes and I was like
doing her character and her niche and she is like, definitely a switch because she's
like, you know, I keep, I keep smacking the mic with my hands because I throw them around.
Like she's a cute little girl.
You're her odyssin.
But then she's like a little feral polar bear.
Like, even if you talk to me like that when I was in like my cute space, um, I would literally
just like want to fucking punch you because that's cringy as fuck.
And that's not how you do that.
Like there is a right way to Dom and there's a right way to be a sub in the way that some
of you guys try to Dom is so fucking pathetic.
Father, may I have a piece?
Oh, come here.
It's funny.
One of my, um, emotes is me going up ease.
So you guys will be able to use that.
It just knows the rabbit mouth.
Yeah.
I like having this on.
I prefer it.
It prefer Dom and women.
Yeah.
I'm like, you have, I'm like, you definitely have never touched a woman before.
You won't.
It's like, this is like you talk like how you only watch porn, you know, it's no right
way to be Dom.
But looking at some of these messages, the chair is the wrong way.
Exactly.
Cause I have like, and it's funny because like I've seen like some of the stuff like you'll
send like Amy and I see or like kind of like the target demographic for being like, like
their subs.
Like, and nobody talks to them like that.
Like they, they, like they treat them with respect.
They're like, oh, I just want to take care of you, pan for you, do this, do that.
And then like sometimes they'll say something a little bit more charged, but it's never
like, I'm just going to like, what if I did this to you and did that?
Like, what are you going to do about it?
I'm like, nobody sends them that shit.
They send them normal shit.
I'm like, why are you sending me the shit?
I literally, I remember there's like one, somebody said something like that.
And I was like, I see, come get your OG son.
And she's like, I don't want him.
Yeah.
It's like people have this idea of like what it is to be this or that.
And it's, it's, and honestly, like porn has a, I keep smacking the microphone because
it's right near my hand.
It is because of porn perpetuates on like kind of like role stereotypes for things because
like you always see the fucking girl getting choked out, pounded.
Oh, yes, daddy.
Oh, yes, please.
Oh, yeah, you fucking shit.
Like, no, it's not real.
Their existence challenges their masculinity.
They don't know how to deal with that.
But like, but like, if I challenge your masculinity, you don't have to interact with me.
Like that's like you don't, like people feel like they have been like they need to like
they have to respond to something you don't have to.
Like if you don't like me, you don't have to watch me right now.
If I'm not your cup of tea, you can watch one of the other girls that you're totally fucking
entitled to that.
Like you don't have to try to prove yourself.
You're the alpha male.
Just be a regular dude.
Just be yourself.
Please.
Emotional damage.
It is real emotional damage.
Everybody's sending me really cheesy jokes now.
It's illegal to laugh out loud in Hawaii.
You have to keep it a low hot.
Fucking God.
I've heard that one before.
You guys fucking suck.
Oh, another one.
Why did Sherlock Holmes go to the Mexican restaurant?
He was looking for a good case of Dia.
Good case idea.
Good case of Dia.
Oh, you guys are so fucking funny.
Hi, CB.
I just want to say, congrats on your debut.
You've been working so hard and streaming daily more than once daily most days.
And I really appreciate your content.
Also enjoy how really you are with us, your chat and your crazy antics always make me smile.
Thanks very much for all your hard work.
You're truly another one of your followers.
Thank you so much.
I always thought it was a detriment to my content that I talk so much and that I overshared.
And then I realized people really appreciate that transparency.
And I'll be honest with you.
I'll watch other streamers and I don't think they talk as bluntly as I do.
I hear a weird noise.
Oh, it's boomie hysteric.
He's pushing a one of the cat bowls around full of the food because he's like pushing it as he's eating.
And I don't mean like I'm blunt in a negative way.
Sometimes it can be.
Sometimes I let myself kind of go too far and say things that I probably shouldn't.
But I feel like with most restrictions or like ideas of how someone should be in a community.
Like I really pride myself on these deep talks that we have.
I personally I don't get those a lot.
Especially like I can't really talk about like VTubing stuff with people except for you guys.
I don't have any people that like friends that watch VTubers.
So yeah, I love these talks.
Yeah, I'm a little crazy.
I'm a little cuckoo.
I'm a silly, silly Billy.
As for my streaming schedule, it's going to be a bummer because next week I'm not streaming as much.
I'm going to probably be streaming for the minimum two hours each time.
Just because I have to work.
I am actually working full shifts.
I don't start my part-time job for a couple of weeks, which fucking sucks.
I might...
I am debating on leaving my job completely and just kind of throwing it to the wind.
Yeah, I'm just debating to not even bother with a part-time job.
Just because it'll be...
I'll be honest with you.
I don't know if I'll have the same energy because if I'm working eight hour shifts interacting with people all day and talking all day,
I'm not going to want to talk as much.
But then I remember I did it back when I was an indie, so I'm like, I can do it again.
So I will try my best. Please be patient with me.
I have like a couple days off a week.
I will be taking more days off just so I can recharge because I've been streaming every day for multiple hours.
I've been pulling a strone.
And like this person said, I have been streaming twice a day like I'm doing today.
So I know you're probably used to my consistent time as well of being 4pm Eastern time.
That is probably going to change in the next few weeks.
But again, honest, if...
If I perform well enough and Patreon does well, everything does well,
again, I will probably fucking quit my job and just try to do this full time.
And maybe I'll do it anyways, even if I don't have the target amount that I want to make yet.
Oh, aren't you funny.
Dumbloser tipped $4.
Thanks Dumbloser.
Hello mom, I would like to beg for attention by donowing money to disrupt your stream with a funny joke.
Oh, lovely.
A woman walked into a bar. She said out.
That was so fucking stupid.
The name was pretty apt.
Name checks out.
Was it an owl?
She said a woman.
He said a woman walks into a bar.
She said out.
I've heard like the two men walking to the bar and they say out and honestly I find that funny.
Funny joke.
I didn't get the first part of the joke.
A woman?
Yeah, a bar, a metal bar.
Some people might have not gotten that if they maybe English is in their first language.
I prefer the pirate one.
A pirate walks into an hour.
How do you not get it?
Relax, don't be mean.
Some people don't get it. They're a little bit slower than others.
Leave the people who are ESL alone.
They're trying their best out here.
But yes.
Hi, Sheedy.
My name is Sheedy.
You watch gushing over magical girls.
If not, you should check it out.
Love you, you goofy bitch, endearing.
You goofy bitch.
I've never heard of gushing over magical girls.
Maybe I will check it out.
I'm Adam Sheeby.
Here's your joke for, wait a second.
One of you just exposed yourself.
Oh, interesting.
This is you, huh?
Okay.
Someone.
Oh, because I recognized a little fate.
Okay, interesting.
Because some of you guys write in a very unique style.
And I like to play a game if I can match the person messaging in my chat.
He's fucking exposed himself.
Hi, Madam Sheeby, here's a joke for you.
A pirate walks to a bar.
The bartender looks at him quizzically and asks,
Sir, are you aware that you have a steering wheel attached to your pants?
The pirate looks at him and responds,
Oh, and it'd be driving me nuts.
Everybody really likes that one.
I guess he nailed it.
Oh, yeah, you preferred it.
Sorry, bro.
Get exposed.
Madam, I'm thirsty.
I need fresh supplies to be made.
It needs to be direct from the source.
Will you allow me to hydrate myself?
Will my do my best at making you feel good as well?
Are you going to also get me a drink?
That'd be nice.
PS, I love you for being you.
You're my Kamiyoshi.
I'm your fucking co-
I'm your Kamiyoshi!
Stop.
Stop, I don't deserve that.
I don't even do anything.
Why do you fucking talk and do silly voices?
I'm not a singer.
I'm not doing crazy content.
I'm not this, I'm not that.
I don't know why.
Highlights and shambles now.
You'll be surprised at how far funny voices can take you.
Thank you for making every day bearable
from your tweets and streams alone.
Bless your heart.
Is it shiv over?
Probably we'll make some fresh Ibanez after this stream.
I'll try to make sure that
audio doesn't get corrupted when I do that.
When I sent the tip, I was messing with you.
I was an attempt to disrespect you and for that, I'm sorry.
No, this is an attempt to dodge the timeout.
I had that coming.
Ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, ah. You picked the wrong time to mess with me, boy.
You picked the wrong time to mess with me.
You think when I'm putting you in your place,
that's the opportunity
to tip and say,
no, I'm not gonna do it.
Remember, I don't, I don't like brats.
If you're a brat, you're gone.
I don't want anything to do with you.
But you apologized.
You guys are, again, we're getting to know each other.
You didn't know this about me.
You didn't know when I switched it on.
I don't like to be interrupted, although I said in my debut,
I don't like to be interrupted during playtime.
Um, you'll be forgiven.
You're gonna be, you're gonna stay in your timeout.
And I'm gonna both think about what you've done.
Okay?
If you're still lurking,
your apology is accepted.
Didn't she say that?
Anuma's tip, $2.
Anuma's?
Oh, great.
Uh, thank you for the $2.
Uh, moving on.
Hi, Madam Sheeby, do you ever wear glasses at all?
Uh, I'm wearing glasses right now.
Because I'm fucking blind.
Or do you find glasses attractive?
Do you find those people who find glasses, uh, quite attractive?
I assume because of how the frame and magnify the eyes,
which I find quite pretty.
Everybody was just like, eh.
Uh, no, yeah, I wear glasses.
Um, most of the time I wear contacts when I'm out and about,
but I wear them at home.
Because I just don't feel like sitting here with my eyes drying out.
And then most of the time I accidentally fall asleep wearing them.
But with my glasses, I, um, you know, obviously take them off my face.
It's funny.
Because I used to complain about not being able to see
even sitting in the front row at like school.
My mom like just like never believed me.
And then they finally took me to the eye doctor and they're like,
oh yeah, her vision, not good.
And it's like, I don't even, like my parents have like 20, 20 vision.
Not a lot of people wear glasses in my family.
They're getting older now, so they have to wear readers,
but like, I think like only like my uncle and my dad's side has to wear glasses.
And I'm like, what the hell?
Mom? Is there something you need to tell me? No, I'm kidding.
If you saw me and my dad, you'd be like, oh, that's copy paste.
Uh, she just has titties.
Um, and is a woman and I'm cute.
I don't look like a man, I promise.
Um, how much grade do you use?
It's not that bad.
I'm like, hold on, I have to remember.
Fuck, what is my prescription?
I'm like negative 0.25 in one eye and then 0.2 in the other or 0.3 in one eye
and 0.3, 0.5 in the other.
So like, I'm not going to lie to you.
I used to have a really, like when I was younger,
I was born with fucking googly eyes.
My dad used to call me like, call me fucking googly eyes, essentially,
because I had a really bad lazy eye and moved to the side.
I don't wear patches, kid.
So I was a pirate.
Um, it was corrected, but I can control it now.
So I can make my eye go like really, uh, really fucking like lazy.
And be like, hey, and then I always do that to people.
Like I would do that to my coworkers in the middle of talking to them
and they'd like freak out because my eye just like slowly drips away.
Um, but my mom, my mom's, my mom's just like, oh yeah,
you fucking hated the iPad, you would take it off and stick to the TV.
And then you just keep watching TV.
But then she's like, it didn't make sense because then you couldn't see past the sticker
and you would complain you couldn't see with it all.
Oh my God.
I don't have to tell you, mom.
Lazy Susan type beat.
Um, just sort of wore a second eye patch under the first one.
Um, yeah, that was like when I was like, like five or six or seven though,
I can't remember.
I don't, I like, I generally don't even remember wearing one.
It was only like, I only know that I had one from like pictures
of when I was super young.
I'm like, I don't even remember that.
Um, no, but it wasn't even, it wasn't an eye patch.
It was like a little sticker you literally go over your eye with.
Like it's like a little, like it's just a giant fucking sticker for your face.
And you just smack it on.
It's not like, so there could have been a second mercy.
Um, I actually did do that thing.
I would actually cover my eye a lot so I could see in the dark.
I would, uh, I would do that.
I would a hundred percent do that.
I was such a fucking shooting kid.
You have no fucking idea doing Naruto hand signs running around like,
like a fucking ninja.
I was so, I'm surprised.
My parents didn't get me locked up with how delusional I was.
She be demon.
I, yeah, it was my, that was my demon.
I'm my lazy.
I was my demon.
I, I can't even, I can't even remember which one is like, was my lazy.
I think it's the one that was, that has a higher, um, or technically a lower,
like prescription or whatever.
Our prescription.
Believe it.
Can we get some of the Chuni back now?
You got mercy for that.
She's a Chuni.
I'm no longer a Chuni.
I'm such a fucking normie now.
Like, uh, I used to be the hugest weeb in Korea boo.
Um, I was a weeaboo and a Korea boo in the worst way.
I was singing in Japanese.
I mean, my friend would talk to each other in Japanese.
I actually knew a lot of Japanese.
Uh, my Japanese name was like Mitsuko word of the fuck.
Um, we refer to that.
We would pass notes in Japanese.
Um, we would pretend we were, uh, anime characters all the time.
Uh, we talk in those stupid ass voices.
Like, oh my God.
So you discovered my secret power.
She has no idea what's going to hit her.
Ah.
Should be got a real job.
I know.
Yeah.
I really, I actually, like my job, like actually spoke Japanese pretty well.
And, um, I can actually, I'm very good at picking up on like accent and how to say something.
Um, I have a lot of, uh, Chinese customers and they would teach me Mandarin.
Some of them would teach me Cantonese and they would like say a word and I would just repeat it to them.
And they're like, Hey, that was actually pretty good.
I'm like, yay.
Oh, you need to be, um, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, she was great.
I missed her.
I haven't seen her in years.
Uh, I remember I tried reaching out to her, but it just like got no word back.
Like, you know, like people just go to college and they drift away.
Like that's, that's just kind of what happened.
Um, but I bet she's, I bet she's like prospering out there somewhere.
She was, she was a really talented artist.
I'll tell you that she was, she's probably like some fucking big animator right now.
I would not be surprised.
Um, super fucking talented.
Redacted.
If you're watching this, I miss you.
You know, you are.
Kiri and Muda forever.
She be Chunibom.
You know, there's me who goes through a friend every month for not really figuring out who
I vibe with.
Um, honestly, I would.
I imagine she's just, that'd be crazy.
Uh, no, they do not have the same art style because she has a very distinct art style.
Um, uh, that, I feel like that has to do more with you than it actually has to do with
the people that you're hanging out with.
Um, because you have to, you don't want to be friends with the saint.
Like, because my friends are totally different from me.
Totally different.
Um, hello.
Welcome back.
Um, she was a tough over.
Um, give people a chance.
Make sure you get to know them.
Uh, you don't make friendships in a month.
And sometimes you just have the personality traits of just like kind of just being an introvert
and that's okay.
You can have acquaintances.
You don't have to be friends with people, you know.
Yeah.
I could change your group.
No, thank you.
Um, different races, different backgrounds, different cultures, uh, different levels of
baseness.
You got me in the middle.
You got olive at the beginning and you got Salem way.
Fucking bass is fuck.
Um, and then like I have other friends who are like married.
I have friends who have like kids.
I have friends like, so it's like, it's so good to surround yourself with people that
are so much different from you because you will learn so much from them.
Yeah, you don't have to be like, I like, I would say olive and Salem, um, are my best
friends and I would die for them.
And then I have like friends from work where they're like, I'm not going to like go out
of my way to hang out with you.
I'm not going to like, if you can, if you have some fucking car trouble, come and pick you
up because that's like the good thing to do.
Um, but like, I don't really want to hear about how some dude broke up with you and you're
just like, because again, I'm so fucking nice and people just tell me their entire life
stories and I just have to like compartmentalize that and took it behind me and just be like,
yeah, okay.
And then I just moved on with my life.
It was a pony roll point.
What an RP group that lasted four years.
Hey, man, I was in a lot of RP groups.
I was in both RP groups.
So don't even get me started.
Oh, wiki foundry and wet paint forever.
Black bloods, black bloods.
Sorry.
Black bloods back.
That's back.
Um, Sasuke Itachi, itachi can't get heartbroken if you've never dated.
Oh, sweetheart.
I'll be honest with you.
Girls are very fucking brutal.
Uh, and then confidence is a thing like you have to, you know, work on your own like self-love
and all that stuff.
Because sometimes you feel like you're unlovable because you don't love yourself yet, you know.
Uh, and yeah, you can get heartbroken even if you never dated.
You're right.
I've gotten heartbroken after fucking anime characters.
I've gotten heartbroken over, you know, having a like a whiplash for a Vtuber.
I watched.
I totally get that.
I get it.
I've never been rejected.
Uh, I would go out of my way to get rejected.
I don't mean to like guys or whatever.
I mean, just like in general, like, hey, can I have this job?
Can I do this?
Because when you get rejected so often, you become used to it.
And, um, it doesn't scare you as much to me.
Like you realize you can survive after being rejected.
I also, again, I grew up a very religious conservative girl.
If I looked at a boy, I thought I was going to fucking go to hell.
I remember I got some heartbroken one time.
I was physically ill.
Oh, you sweet thing.
You're helping with confidence.
You know, she'd be, I'm glad.
I'm glad I can help you guys with confidence.
I like, again, I remember some of the messages you guys sent me.
You're like, oh, I really liked your aftercare and your ASMR role play.
It really actually, like I talk to myself and I say good things about myself in the mirror.
I'm trying to eat better and go to the gym.
Um, yeah, it all, first, um, it all starts with, uh, your mindset and, you know, kind
of learning with yourself.
So, okay, I'm going to be, I'm going to be really weird with you for a second.
You don't have to do this, by the way.
It's just like what I found was good for me in a good tool, uh, one therapy, but two.
Um, so there is something in like the witchy community and it's called, uh, your shadow
self.
And that's the self that you kind of push down and it's like, you know, hidden in the
shadows, so to speak.
And you don't really like to acknowledge it.
And how you do, like, you can look up like shadow journaling and it kind of gives you
a prompt where you have to kind of confront that shadowy aspect of yourself.
Um, because I remember I had like a really toxic friend and she was like a horrible
even being to me and I just did not have the power to tell her like I can't be friends
with you because I was such a pushover at the time.
So I sat down with myself and I'm like, what am I getting out of this relationship?
What am I, I'm not gaining anything from being friends with this person who just pushes me
around, uses me only for like when I have money and she wants me to buy or something.
Like what the.
And then just like blows me off for her other friends and then talk shit behind my back.
Like what are you going to know?
And then I was just, I came down to I'm like, I didn't like myself.
That's the shadow part was I didn't like who I was and I thought that I deserved that
sort of treatment, but you have to realize you don't.
Yeah, shadow work.
Yeah.
You guys know what shadow work?
Yeah, shadow.
I fought my demons.
I shadow box my demons.
I on it like and that's and you don't have to put it in that frame of like, oh, which
you should like honestly shadow work is very similar to like normal as someone who like
I actively go to therapy who just journaling in general, such a good outlet.
So I always say work on your mental and then find a hobby that is a good outlet for you.
That's going for the gym, go to the gym for me.
I was doing jiu-jitsu.
I'm currently not able to do that right now because of my injuries.
So it became video games for a little bit and then it became vTubing vTubing is such
a good outlet for me.
I can rage at video games.
I can talk to you guys.
I can do fun stuff on my own.
So it's it's good and I can make my friends.
It's a great outlet for me.
It's a great hobby.
Um, I also I'm currently working on trying to get a more active hobby now that it's nice
and sunny outside and all that shit.
So I'm going to try to go like hiking again and whatever, um, very Jungian concept.
Yeah.
That's kind of true actually.
Jordan Pierce in shorts.
Um, and yeah, it is cathartic.
It's literally like this is almost like therapy for me because like I talked to you guys how
I talk to my therapist sometimes just in the frame of like, Oh, this is how I'm feeling
this week.
Um, I've been stressed out.
Like I was telling my therapist, like all these eyes are on me.
I don't feel like I'm like we're currently we're working through my posture syndrome.
Um, but she's on a vacation for two weeks in Europe and I don't know what, but so you
guys are my therapist.
I'm sorry.
Sorry guys.
I'm going to cry to you instead.
Um, yeah, we can tell as I can't tell what the context of that was, um, don't take your
meds.
Dude, no, uh, if I didn't take my meds, I would never leave my house.
It's not fun being a gorophobic man.
It's really not.
I don't recommend it.
I only get bad advice.
Give us your tears.
Um, collective shoulders can hold a lot of tears teasing material for later.
She is a therapist and takes her meds like a good girl.
Um, no, it's cause I'm a fucking adult and I am not self-destructive.
That is teenager.
No, thank you.
Um, I'm a grown ass woman.
Uh, yeah, I have like, don't, don't get it twisted.
I have my Manhattan moments, um, but I almost do like act upon my more Manhattan moments
because I know I'm in a like safe space in the community where it's expected for that
to open up.
She's being a woman.
Uh, whatever.
But like, I haven't even really had that yet.
I'm like, because of, I've thought of like, I like had like a negative thought the other
day about streaming.
I don't even remember what it was, but I'm like, normally I would like vent about this
on my all.
And I'm like, I don't have to do that.
I don't have to do that.
Yes.
I have.
Okay.
What was my Manhattan moment?
Let me know.
I'll, I'll give you this one shot right here on my cheek.
I'm leaning in at me right here.
She's so female.
He's so foreign.
My marinara moments.
What is Manhattan?
Uh, Manhattan is a Japanese, uh, close deal term, uh, in the v-tubeing community for essentially
crazy person or someone who kind of like acts out a lot it doesn't have like any impulse control
kind of just like breaks down and kind of like loses it often like for example if i like imagine
if i instead of having like this productive talk with you i went on on my all and i cried
and i said everybody hates me i hate being a dumb um fuck all of you i'm never doing this again
i'm crying you guys suck i'm going to do this i'm going to that to myself because i hate you
and you guys make me feel terrible that's a manhara moment
acting challenge go
go
jebus manhara equals meltdown yeah essentially
we can't handle you at your worst you don't deserve you at your best shiboni moments
get it now thanks cool nice
shibi i hope this maro finds you well i wanted to thank you for the streams the tweets and the
patreon audios you bring unique vibes and and almost velvety experience i like that velvety
experience to your content love you and all of you learn i will keep cheering for you and supporting
you thank you thank you that is very sweet of you to say appreciate this comment very much um
i'm glad that you are enjoying my content i'm i get so happy when someone's like i really like
your tweets or i really like your streams or your audio was oh chef's kiss um i think yeah i
think my audio comes out tomorrow i don't know so i was going to record something in the interim
but i was too busy to do that it's still got to clean my house
what get shot by security um
like on what level do you think it's a good idea to see that out loud
hi rena she assaults on my desk sorry patreon audio wait my audio came out today
my audio came out today it's only five bucks
it just came out oh shit yeah cuz tronnie was just like it goes up friday my time in thursday
and thursday your time but i might have gotten them switched i might have thought she said friday
your time thursday my i don't fucking know i must i must have read her her message now um
i should yeah well anyways uh look down in the um box below my lovely description box you'll see
a link to my patreon and the audio is your boss catches you beep at work catches you beeping
at work so take that as you will please get a laugh that was the first audio
i uh i recorded that's the first first nsfw audio i ever recorded guys in my life
was that time so please let me know you can give me constructive feedback for that one again i've
learned a lot since then because that was back in um april so yeah but like i always like you guys
again constructive criticism please don't be like you could have done this better yeah but like why
or like how could i have like please like give me reasons give me reasons sweetheart does it use
he him pronouns um i don't know if it does i can't recall if it does
but morgan you know that i do have to address this because i know it's been coming up a lot um
um our company is female for male centered i don't know if like you'll have to send a mario
destrani i don't know if we'll be doing female for all audios or female for female audios because
we don't we don't like make custom audios or anything uh again we feel scripts that were given to us
my management uh to feel a little particular niches um but yeah i'm sorry if that disappoints you
or any other person who kind of was expecting that um that we kind of catered to different
identities but i don't know if we i don't think we are again because we're not
we don't have experience with that sort of content strani can't educate us on that content
if we don't know about it we don't want to offend anybody you know like it'll be cool once in a while
yeah i'm gonna be a safe for work audio on your channel yeah oh yeah no like um i i will obviously
like all my youtube stuff is gonna be safe for work hi you know why are you looking at me so cute
what the fuck is it looking up like mother pet me i am petting you um like all my asmr audios
are going to be safe for work uh low recorded ones sometimes when i do it live i can get carried
away because i get excited because i like bothering you guys and making y'all hot and bothered um
but yes i'm not i am a lewd audio va that's it i'm not a lewd streamer yes i'm wearing shabari
ropes in a ball gag don't don't don't let that uh don't let that bother you i'm i'm honestly pretty
normal on my uh streams i i i talk bluntly and i'm pretty forward and i can say inappropriate
things but i'm not gonna be like oh my god thank me really etc that's just bad patreon for that
we'll have fans leave eventually for that so i think yeah i get i think the families are gonna
be free because i'm just i'm probably just gonna be um maybe posting like yeah like doing
streams of h games on there they're just for show yeah i just forget forget it's there you're too
dorky it yeah it's funny i'll get like some arrows and somebody already sent one before
i feel a bit like i forgot that like you were supposed to be like this sex symbol because
you're kind of a dork and i'm like hey yeah you like it though right you're into that right
finger guns the bunny guard in front yeah well again that was kind of my that was that was part
of the bit though that was just the bit i'll eventually eventually i don't know guys i'm not
i'm not i'm not a staff member i don't know i interest the things i can give you i usually
update you guys when i get information um we want to all i know is that we want to establish
ourselves on one of the normal platforms first and then we will might branch out
she'd be such a bro you forgot till she gives you the whiplash yeah that should be like that
should be my thing like whiplash tm because like i'll just like switch it on and off and people are
like whoa oh my nose is itchy why is the tissue box all the way over there i'm gonna die rina why did
you do this to me is mercy streaming tonight did she say she was gonna stream later because i might
just read her go to bed can you whip in lashes he's a seedling oh god don't let strongly put her
in the jar the end of the line oh shit okay same your asmr had to be archived it was a ginseng
yeah i'll probably um post it somewhere eventually i don't fucking know um can you whip it and hit the
nene yeah duh i can always have to hit it but then hit the nene you think i'm cute you i'm so cute
too freaking type of character i am oh is there is still streaming okay that's cool nice girlfriend
begs you to let her hold it asmr strongy what the fuck is this what is that girlfriend begs you to
let her okay everybody i hope you probably already watched it but strongy released a asmr meme audio
10 hours ago that's fucking hilarious uh so check that out if you want to okay serenity is also streaming
who else is ringing
i can't fucking tell oh sweet oh i'm gonna raid mimosa later 100% um cool you guys better stick
around for mimosa let me see i'll see if any there's any more marrows and then i'll end it
okay
oh my gosh there's actually like a bunch that came through cool nice
thanks dumb loser tip eight dollars and forty cents hey oh you are hey so what do you know
are dot hey are a woman walking walked into a bar right ha and are she said our dot get it cos metal
you're a little bit late with that one bud but uh
well are you just thanks for the eight miss morrigan tipped one dollar i understand completely
about being more male oriented i'll just have to keep don't knowing asking to be called a good girl
and the like for all the two women in chat it was funny um thank you morrigan for the book um
i like looked at my analytics the other day you know how i told you guys i was like 99% men
and then 1% women i like looked at my um analytics again and it was like three percent women my mom
says i have to apologize for the bad joke i made before or she will put my ps5 in the freezer a
freezer okay uh thank you for your apology tell your mom that i accepted thank you for the tip
on numus um but yeah i got two i got more girls like shout out to the girls in chat um and it's
funny because girl women can a lot of women watch vtubers usually it's male vtubers yes but like
i feel like there should be like a like i want to be a girl's girl too like i want to be able to
be like a girl's bro you know like i want a girl to be able to watch me be like oh my god she's
funny as fuck like i told be friends with her i would like to appeal to all genders in a safer
work fashion female watchers who want to talk shit into gossip exactly you know and then maybe
one of you guys uh you know we'll find a girlfriend or something maybe you'll find love in one of my
streams what if i set you up with someone what if i'm a matchmaker and you fall in love with sticky
girl right there or i thought your name was maya but it's my name owns so i'm gonna call you maya
maybe fall in maya right there you don't know all the girlies all the girlies where your hand
raise your hands up right now girlies in the chat
are two girls maybe because of the lens are that too you know
that's cheating on sheebie though well but that's like they're not a streamer if i if i can manage
to get you like an irl girlfriend i would honestly feel like i wouldn't even be mad about that
i don't think like i'm possessive of you with other like streamers but like
it'd be kind of nice if like because i've heard that before like someone's like i found my wife
watching your streams and then you guys can get laid and like you know you can do btsm
shit on each other and then you can like send me videos
because i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking
anyways
oh my back
hello is she dead
yeah i want you to lose your peak card to another hair remember
lose it even if you're a dude and you're dude you're losing it to each other
the five kids they can raise them on my streams exactly the safer work ones of course
oh my god we're gonna be a cute little amish family guys i'm making a commune in a cult
we're gonna be the second jones town i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
um i still have to really pee i haven't peed in like several hours wow
i am quite the endurance streamer aren't i um
i've never watched vtubers before but i clicked on one of your streams out of curiosity
and now i'm lurking in all your streams i'm quite shy so i don't chat much during live streams
but i wanted to say i really enjoy your content um i'll pause there there's a lot more thank you
if you lurk thank you you don't have to talk in my streams if you don't feel comfortable
i appreciate uh that you just like want to hang out watch me listen to me maybe have me in the
background i love my lurkers lurkers are amazing um it's also hectic if like a hundred people talking
chat but yeah uh but welcome welcome to vtubers uh it's quite a wild ride but it's really cool
and fun you'll soon discover uh i like how blunt and honest you are it makes you feel like more
of a person than most of the other vtubers i've heard of i've been going through a rough patch
lately and your streams have been helping i'm afraid i'm becoming parasocial oh i don't know
if this is a bad thing or not all i know is that's generally not advice do you have any advice how to
prevent this if not then that's fine thanks for being chill the chillimeters app off the charts um
i can't really stop you for being parasocial um
um
you have to understand
that i'm trying to say this nicely it's gonna i think most people are pretty understanding
that like i'm probably i'm never gonna meet you in person um we're never gonna hang out together
um and i'm sorry that's not a possibility but it's for everybody's safety um and mental
well-being so nobody gets hurt uh i totally understand i've also been parasocial with
streamers before flesh tubers and vtubers alike uh i used to have dreams that pewdiepie
actually knew me and gave me a shout out on his main channel and i'll have continuances of dreams
where i run into him again um and in my dream i'm just like he's like and i'm like an old friend of
his i've never fucking met the dude i've never talked to him i don't even know i had those dreams
i haven't watched pewdiepie in years but like sometimes one of those will just pop up and i'm
just like what the fuck because i really liked him as a creator i would watch him when i came home
from school at the time so i get it uh pewds got me through a lot of shit in markiplier,
jacksepticeye and like game grumps and fucking van os's crew and all that shit i watched a lot
of youtube growing up because i didn't have any fucking friends so i get it it's hard not to develop
friendship feelings or otherwise what the people you watch especially if you really enjoy their
personality um i always said my goal was to be a content creator that you felt like you could come
home to and sit down and watch and like just kind of unwind after a long day and like you're hanging
out with an old friend playing video games and chatting with them that was kind of my goal um
but like i know that's probably really a little bit problematic now given like
vtubers are kind of again a little bit more parasocial because you can't see me it's hard to
remember them a human being sometimes and you know i can't really blame you for that uh
at all actually like i totally get it like i sometimes will watch a streamer and i'm like
yes they are this type of cat girl yes totally like you get caught up on it i can't blame you
can you be parasocial with your cats that's fine
bro if i were able to sample any of richie b s*** for my rap music that'd be phenomenal
this talking spectacularly because how much it relates to that very similarity for other streamers
yeah honestly i give you permission for that um i has cupcake yeah ld shadow lady oh my god yeah
100% like i watched markiplier um the most right and actually no game grumps i watched the most
and i literally if i'm i'll have him in the background and i feel like i have like two of
my older brothers hanging out with me uh playing f***ing resident evil giggling over lady dibertresque
and i'm just giggling while i'm cleaning my room cleaning the house doing this putting on my makeup
and it's like i get it i totally get it um but then you at the end of the day you have to remember
watch real what's not but i feel like a lot of my viewers are pretty
uh like they kind of are self-aware and they're like oh my god i'm falling in love with her
that's fine well like i don't want to hurt you i'll hurt you physically like
you know like i don't want to oh my god i'm literally tearing up because like i don't want to
break anybody's heart i don't want to break anybody's f***ing heart man
because it sucks having your heart broken because you can't be with someone so i f***ing get it
like i'm not gonna discourage it but
i don't really yeah i don't know what else to say like i can't stop you i can't
yeah it's an inevitable if i discourage or not
but i almost don't want to like i can't i don't really discourage it because like
there is
i i kind of think that like being parasocial is a spectrum
you have people in one end that are like this is a cool streamer i watch and then you have other
people get it and they're like i am actually married to them um and i just want to be in the
middle where you're i'm a streamer you watch you like and you can enjoy me but you just understand
you know
like you just be realistic and it sucks because like i'm a major f***ing people pleaser
and i want to make you all happy i don't want to break people's heart
um but i can't tell you not to love me i can't tell you not to like want to be my friend because
i understand it i watch so many female vtubers and i'm like oh my god i wish i could be their friend
it sucks because i know when i'll ever be even being a streamer now like i'm like i'll never be
their friend you know even it sucks i love you too much for the middle
i'm not even in this for the hornet i just want to watch someone who isn't restricting what they
say or do that's fine too um
yeah that's me though i know like emi and isi are f***ing hella parasocial with you guys
oh my god they f***ing love you guys you'd have no idea and mercy too oh my god
is there a little bit she's like a little bit laid back about it though um isi's in love with
y'all if you're gonna f***ing hunt you down parasocial responsibility kids yeah exactly
i just don't want anybody to get like hurt over me you know
and i think that's kind of also what it's like being a dom because when you're a dominatrix
and you have clients and they come in and they ask for they have certain requests
and you fulfill those requests at the end of the day
it's a different type of relationship and that's the relationship i want to have with you i want
you to feel safe with me i want you to feel you know protected with me i want you to feel like
you can go fulfill fantasies with me and if some of those fantasies have to do with be with you loving
me that's like that's okay i don't mind being loved i don't mind being loved at all
it's called codependence yeah codependence
oh should i nuke this vod i'm getting too f***ing emotional right now
i'm so lonely he cries profusely um i'm also saying this for myself
because i don't want to get too caught up i'm a very um
um
what i love i love very deeply so i also don't want to get my heart broken
ah f*** emotions uh
i still have to really pee i know i just like i i get so shy sometimes and i'm like i have to
destroy every vod inside i need to start over i mean because i have this like i want people to
have this image of me but i'm like no like let me just show them my real self i'm working on it
sorry for destroying vod you're good where we're going we don't need vods you just have it in your head
but thank you thank you for your honesty um anonymous
hey sheepy i originally came to be a lair because of strawnee but you've quickly
risen to be one of my favorites you're insanely sailing good at setting your own boundaries and
being so real when it comes to saying what's on your mind and your zatzidans along all of this
along with the fact your funny as hell makes you watching watching you a great such a great
experience and i hope you can keep doing this for a long time all this dumb stuff is just a
hidden plus i never knew i could experience so thanks for that to you i guess you're welcome i
think it's funny because a lot of people will come into stream and be like wow this is great this
is a great stream and then i'll say something like and check out my patreon for this content
they're like wait there's that what they like f***ing fly over there
yeah the honest i'm just myself and the loot audios are a bonus because i like voice acting
and that's fun it's actually really fun doing that sort of voice acting i like i like really
getting into it you know like really getting into it when i record wink wink um anyways
you're an inspiration alley doubt it i no no no no no i mean hey good advertising
convince me to pay that five dollars um you get me moaning in your ear four times a week for five
dollars how awesome is that
i'm sold
i won't lie to you i listened to one of my own audios and i kind of like kind of like
diddly dj myself because i was like hey oh this is pretty fly oh i'm getting my
turn on hey y'all um
i feel really comfortable as community so she be and i'll be alert thank you oh i'm so glad
i feel like even like a short it's just a short amount of f***ing time we've cultivated
such a community like i've seen people's reaction like i haven't felt this way about a
company before all the girls are lovely blah and i'm just like yes that's what we wanted
you get totally just like you just get us you get really cool girls that don't have to
be restricted and what they f***ing do and say and they can just be real
we're also f***ing nerds like anime and we're horn dogs
small but strong we're growing every day i don't think we're small i don't think we're small one bit
it we only just start give us a couple months holy f*** oh my god i guys i expected to have like
20 of you watching me like i expected like 500 people are debut
you blew all of our predictions out of the water like we didn't think we were gonna get that much
attention at all strontium is just like oh you know probably get like one no what is she i don't
even remember what she said the other girls were like i'm guessing like 500 i'm guessing like this
me i was like we're getting 5k we're getting 10k i was so f***ing optimistic and then when they said
that it kind of hit me like a brick like oh sh** maybe they're right like we're probably not
gonna get that many people and i was like eh whatever um and i care that much i'm not doing it
for the f***ing views i'm doing it because i like to yap i yap to f***ing nobody i'll yap to nobody
again people either yarn for the lude tubers she really remembers when you get famous after your
30 000 viewers i never forget f***ing anybody i remember my fans from when i was a f***ing flash
viewer i remember where i i won't forget where i came from either people you know where who who i
where i was from when i was rena uh i don't f***ing forget those people um i appreciate the support
across all of my many lives i have to heart type sh** that's what that's how i keep it real dude
got any day ones in the chat i highly doubt it a lot of people couldn't find me i usually i kept it
i kept it quiet i didn't oh baby a triple thank you god she be is the best tip three dollars and
thirty three cents be allure forever leave her she be thank you thank you god she be is the best
um oh that's who you are i mean what um i missed every two of you not gonna lie you're fine you're
fine leave her she be leave her she be um yeah i'm i'm always thankful like i always make sure
that i spread the love around like that's why some people are confused or like why are these
like what they consider complete nobody's because they don't they're not like in a
corpora or something because they're small indies but like those are my friends um i'm not gonna
blow them off just because i joined an agency and i'm a little bigger i'm never i would never f***
can do that s*** if you like me you'll f***ing love them i can't wait to do my stream with
tola tomorrow or not tomorrow next week i don't know where i am this pokemon smash your past is
gonna be so hilarious probably gonna drink it's gonna be a great f***ing time everyone start
everyone start somewhere that's why like i'm thankful for the people who did the watch along
that gave us a chance um it's nice
just curl a collab tomorrow
that was uh well it's almost 11 okay
hey sheepster i've got a hobby of a handmade 3d pen draw tool was curious if you had an idea or
little model you'd like me to try to make i made one for mercy and she thought it was kind of cool
i figured i poked the glass to see if you oh i saw that i actually i saw that i thought it was
really cool were you the one who made it with the white um the white uh like filament on
white paper and you were like freaking out because you realized they couldn't show up well
i thought that was so funny and cute um that is it was really cool if you're the same person it
was cool figured i poked the glass to see if you had an idea if not i probably just do your emblem
keep up the good work remember to take care of your throat for those fun voices yeah i know i need to
i try not to talk at all actually before like anytime before a stream unless i have to i don't
really like have to go and do stuff a lot um so that's fine but like i i can tell my voice is getting
a little bit dry from the use but i know i but i know when i'm losing it um but i know i'm not at
that point uh you can hear i'm a little bit uh gravelly right now because i've been talking all
day even though i've been drinking water actually a lot of water ah i'm also a little bit gravelly
because i was crying uh when she be cries it's so hot um 3d print throne collar oh that's pretty
funny uh that's really cool though actually um yeah honestly you can go with what you want uh i don't
really can you make my boobs can you make like you know like how my like almost my body is cut out
by the shape of my shirt can you just like make like a lower part of my neck and then my boobs it
looks like a little heart no don't do that um you can i don't know you can like draw my little you
can draw the harem like the harlot character i did the gravelly he has my morning voice oh i just
sound like a zero for a second what the fuck this is my morning voice hello hello bleeding hearts
pie is here it was really i was really close she is like she almost has she's very slow when she
speaks you know people said how zero has a lisp i never noticed that and then she said she had a
list i'm like yo a lisp i never heard it i didn't really fucking get it i just heard her voice and
i was like i'm gonna come that's all i thought about every time she spoke we had our first meeting i
was like hello i never fucking noticed it my mom pointed out to me because i was showing her as
her stuff she's like oh she has a really cute lisp i'm like what um but yeah do whatever you like
gushing over magical girls anime about magical girl fanatic
hiragi utena becoming a magical girl on the side of villains oh and coming to learn the
realizing she likes magical girls is to see them struggle and get humiliated
oh i'm so watching this that sounds right up my alley holy shit
after oh i need to plug in my headphones they're dying after what happened to the other guy in chat
i'm now definitely afraid of somehow being found out what kind of sinful marrows i said about wanting
to be your bitch what if i just said your what if i just said your name right now what if i was
just like oh no problem redacted would i just send your name would you cry probably thanks
for the marrow guy appreciate it oh don't worry kid oh god kiffed was it you kiffed kiffed
nope wasn't me i'm gonna start just reading marvin paul
obionics saver morgan dr p starbucks daddy corn avenge aphibian
wren's the clips calibrate 50 nadalia
nah i know who who yeah chainsaw lizard kamikaze zombie eight will crown nugget i
l siren i siren marvin flapjack doc you guys are the weird whoa how do you come with these
fucking names hypen android exobock blood you guys are going too fast i can't read your names
blank ali misaka best pun enjoyer mystic tonio too lover effendom fiendish boy
gabba bond coro we are so back is your name just slend
pun blake king mufasa rock star x2 doki i'm hoping i didn't miss anybody diddy
because i will literally cry if i miss somebody
no stop well i can just scroll and it stops moving
you don't name shampy i'm gonna name shame all you uh sticky girl
steve what um dark shaman shaman shaman vincen the kind necroman
bro what the fuck is your name what is your name too
murph duck i like how everybody's suddenly talking because they want me to say their name
unseen ask kurrick ask turricks you know you spelled that wrong right
andrade nine nine oh two nine
charles loss sabastian ramires fiora rastero cowboy ranch man
hakuna sama room desolation pochita osami
shock train nebula bio-weapon axe my body is ready
sultan serks is the s zero inserts revolving rooster notice me pretty rabbit miss morgan
i already said did you ever say your name um nugget
is that everybody two moons hi two moons you want me to say your name hi going back to lurking
oh osmani not osami i can't fucking read abcrum
hmm the secret to engagement
hahaha
daddy corn torah jam ghostia ranatics forever what the fuck is your name
well at least one of us sent a marrow barbecue two three one
i see you barbecue q q two one where the hell you
are
oh jeez sorry rudeness it was rudeness hundred percent
i didn't mean to burp
dragon andante fionnore rastero
that are you saying your names okay some of you are getting bonus names rends the clips
you clip in rends the clips delusion green enigma
dragon he's nuts across your face come come he's up you know it'd be a funny like stream idea is like
try to keep up with chat and read everything they say
read every sentence and you can't skip but you have to read it as fast as chat is moving
big fan of delusion
fast firing engagement i'd be modig and schlicken
if you blow up to like 1k viewers it would be so it would be impossible
yeah it's actually sometimes it's hard to follow chat i kind of like i prefer having a small
ccv because i can keep up with chat when we first like had our second like the 2.0 stream
and we did have around like 900 people uh consecutively watching us and trying to keep up with
chat was a nightmare i was like actually like between that and then heading 17k on my twitter
i was kind of heartbroken because it was really hard to interact with you guys like because i
couldn't i liked liking a lot of your tweets to show you that i like liked it and you know read
them and stuff and now it's almost impossible for me to do that on twitter because i just get so
many fucking notifications from people liking all the porn that i retweet
mentioned the hauling girls yeah that's why i'm like i don't think it could be
one because of how i am uh in haul live just because like
i don't like the fact that some people because they're so large start to see their audience
as a number rather than individuals and i never want to feel that and i felt it when i hit 17k
on my haul and it sucked because i'm like i'm just looking at a number and i liked it when it was
way smaller because it's weird and i know it's mostly bots thank god like i think actually
knowing that it's mostly bots kind of make me felt better because i'm like okay there's still a
couple like humans i can interact with they're still individuals they're still like it's because
of me overwhelming yeah it's a lot of bots i wish i could purge them i really wish i could purge them
but i don't want to accidentally purge like people who are normal
uh oh i'm getting eepy i need to wash my face and i put on makeup today gross
i'm trying i went to a dermatologist because i just like have been breaking out really fucking
bad and even before like streaming and stuff um because it's not like stress related um and
they're just like oh you you have like a hormone imbalance and i'm like what the fuck
because like um so like i have a lot of like issues um so i have to be on birth control
um and birth control can fuck with your hormones and that's another reason like that's why i sometimes
have to take like mental uh medication and other medication but like it also regulates other parts
that would get fucked up otherwise if i didn't take it and so it's like the lesser of two evils
is that i get fucking acne or i go i go batshit crazy so i'd rather just get acne
oh just breed me instead that's pretty common yeah like a lot of and like because i get
really like tmi if you don't like to hear about like blood or periods please click off um i used
to get really horrible painful like feeling i'm stabbed in the fucking uterus um cramps i had
to go to urgent care before uh the way i was describing it my mom felt like i had like some
sort what is it called like we have it it's not like a cis like a non nodule there's like a
like one of like an over exploded or whatever the fuck but it was really it was just pain
it was just pain i've grown up a woman this is a Tuesday for me uh no i but i don't have endo
like i don't have endo um they do they do think i have polycystic ovary syndrome um
but they're still trying to figure it out that's why i've been going to the doctor's appointments
um i hate being a fucking woman uh there's so much fucking shit um
because like they didn't ultrasound on me and they didn't see anything physical but then my endocrinologist
was telling me that like it can like you can still have it and not have actual assists which i didn't
know that um but yeah it was like i would have like really fucking heavy periods just bleed
through super pads like i'm if you're a guy you probably don't know or maybe you have a sister
maybe you do know or a girlfriend or whatever um but like a super pad is like a different thickness
it's because like uh it's not it's not i'm going to the i'm going to the pharmacy uh you need tampons
but your pussy size no it's like it's not like large and like super isn't like a super huge pussy
it's it's like the flow and what it can hold um so when you have a really heavy flow usually you
have to get like supers um so i would do that and i would bleed through them real fast i'm so sorry
if this grosses you out i'm so sorry i'm so so so sorry um but uh yeah it just like really fucking
sucks um and then my yeah i'm like i was gonna describe some more symptoms i'm like never mind
but um supersize me um i remember like my mom uh telling my dad to go get tampons for the both
of us and my dad was like uh he's like you're my wife it's fine but like this is weird he's like
why can't we just have sons and i'm like hey i'm like hi my girl it's because like it's so
because it's like your kid is growing up you know he was just like i don't know it's i don't
know how to deal with this but like my dad has a younger sister too like i haven't on but like
they are so far apart in age that my dad's is like what i remember like really conservators
religious households so like sex education is not a huge thing but like i think i think my mom
educated my dad pretty well i'm gonna get a hormonal cycle so simple yeah i hate like
going through like pms like just like being upset maybe that maybe i'm pmsing although like
what you're really knowing about being on birth control is that i'm irregular so i don't really
like i don't know what the fuck i'm gonna get it just happens
um yeah men have a hormonal cycle i think it like takes place through a day but for women
it's it's a we have a month long hormonal cycle
yeah yeah men's is daily um and then for yeah for women it's like we have like
you know before we get it we have like ovulation
right before we get it period then like the time after that and then like maybe like a
fucking day or two of rest and then it's like ovulation and then
yeah it usually happens when you sleep that's why you wake up fucking shooting everywhere okay
why why are all the men surprised that they have a hormonal cycle
guys look you got yeah you guys have a hormonal cycle
how do you think your body regulates the t an estrogen in your body
you guys never knew that men have a horn that's wow
yeah you guys yeah you're just just a lot shorter but that's like yeah there's that's a sometimes um
that's why men can kind of freak out when their t levels are low or it's like there's a there's a
or you actually don't have enough estrogen in your body because remember men and women both make
estrogen um just yeah because then we just both have different levels of it so you have two less
you're like more likely to have certain behaviors vice versa and stuff it's just part of the fucking
it out process doesn't really change for us yeah it's like it's not drastic for you guys like it is
for women so then again we don't bleed from our privates each month yeah i feel like i've always
said and like all the girls joke about this like um if men had the same sort of hormonal cycles
as women did there would be like so much difference in like how those are treated because like if you
imagine you were like kicked in the nuts for like
at least like at maximum eight days like wouldn't you want a day off
but like you don't get a day off for that you don't get a day off for having like the first
day of your period is the fucking worst
well like one get well not not like in a good way like if it like surprises you not like when
you're expecting it in like a horny way can't go to work my peepee hurt that's true
i'm thinking like one no continuous kicks wait has any of you had like a kidney stone
have any like had a kidney stone or like a really like really bad constipation
i'm like trying to find an equivalent for you to understand no drink water the pain of a period it
is not like this is like women have like women have a higher pain tolerance than men
and you guys should totally testicular torsion um
like i know there is like those like simulators you can do where you can put them on on a guy
and it will like stimulate either like childbirth or a cramp i love watching those videos i remember
they did it for like i think it's i want to take talk of like a cop did it and they turned
it up to a 10 and he was like on the ground the cop and then they they put it on a woman and she
was just like oh yeah that's really fucking hurts but she was like just like standing and looking
around she was like fine how would a guy want that because it's just you don't have to want that
but it's like it's i think it would make men a lot more empathetic would you guys would you
take care of me if i was on my period and i wasn't feeling good pissing a stone was the most painful
thing i've experienced yeah my my dad my dad's diabetic so he's more apt to get to these stones
um and my dad's like is this what giving birth is like to my mom and mom's like no it's worse
imagine if you were torn from asshole to vagina you drink the blood you're gonna earn your red wings
now i don't want to be the simulator's i'm good i stick with empathy no sympathy needed
i'm into the store for your ultra pads but um no i don't like i might thankfully because like
again so this was before i was on birth control now that i'm on birth control i barely have a
period i live in life except now i fucking zits and like normally when you're my age you don't
have acne anymore so i usually maintain it with skincare um and i didn't because i'm stupid i
like finally went to the dermatologist because my doctor was just like whoa like you like what's
happened and like i don't have like bad acne um it's more like again i've said because i'm melanated
my skin will scar if i'm wearing makeup you can't even fucking tell but like if you were looking at
me with that makeup i have like a lot of like um like dark spots on my face like they almost look
like freckles and um but like or like the beauty marks on my face um and my doctor's like yeah no
that shouldn't be doing that and so i went to the dermatologist they're like oh yeah your hormones
are like really thrown off by your um your birth control so like we're gonna like put you on this
and it actually helps like regulate it i'm like this entire fucking time i've been on this for a
year and i could have why didn't you guys tell me this sooner they're like well you shouldn't have a
side effects i'm like fuck you do pimple patches help yes they do a lot actually yeah hyperpigmentation
i get hyperpigmentation and because i have dermatillomania it's fucking annoying or excorciation
disorder whatever it's called it's like it's almost like a form of ocd where you have like
i can't really explain it you can just google it um you think emi likes picket scabs you haven't
met me yet um i fuck gore to he moment doctor moment okay richie guy i can just get a grow
beer to hide him yeah like i always say beer just like the makeup for men but like again i look
um i just look like i have a lot of fucking freckles on my face um and usually they get
mistaken because i'll like i'll go out with no makeup i don't give a shit um and people just
like think i just have a lot of freckles or beauty marks um and then if i really want to
i'll just put like foundation on and it's gone i hate having to shave every other day
yeah i can't relate besides like i'll get like a couple of peach fuzzies actually like the other
day i got like one like chin hair and i was like oh my fucking god what the fuck is this
what's going on in my face my mom's like oh yeah they have to be around your age i'm like what am i
am i mutating but i just plucked it and i'm fine and i haven't seen it since
before without a beard before i lost weight it looked like a thumb oh like a thumb from like
spy kids or if i try to grow beard looks like pubes and i don't know those words oh i know like i
a lot of my co-workers who are younger than me um some of them are guys and they can't grow
beards and like again like men and women have like different like gripes with things like guys
worry about their fucking dick size or whatever and then growing beards and then women worry about
like literally every aspect of their fucking body yeah and so um uh like so i really
i try to empathize with men because i'm like oh i'm gonna have it easy but i'm like no you know
no they kind of don't because like i'm not a boy so i don't know kind of like i i recently figured
out how rudely men treat each other based on appearance or like how they carry themselves
and i thought it was a joke but i was like listening to um what was it no this wasn't
recently it was actually like months ago what the fuck i'm talking about before leave um one of my
co-workers because i i'm uh you know i'm a nosy bitch don't forget gemini moon um
and i was overhearing my uh male co-workers talk about a group chat and like they were
like roasting this kid in it and i was like holy fucking shit jesus fucking christ why do you have
him in there if you're just gonna shit on him um so like and they were like yeah they're making fun
of his appearance or that he spoke this and that and i'm like wow they're just as bad as girls
so like i i definitely uh it kind of like threw some sympathy at me there so like when i went
guys complain like oh i can't really grow a beard that well or i'm this or that i'm like you know
i get it we just have females have a different equivalent of that you know
no that's pretty random behavior with the g's yeah or just like um men having a sort of like
kind of like what is the word i want to use
it's like dick measuring contest like you have to like prove yourself
i don't know i've just observed that i feel like you guys are like kind of passive aggressive
sometimes in friend groups early yeah like men friendships are very interesting because i'm
like do you guys actually like each other because you're like making fun of each other you're calling
each other you're doing this you're doing that hegemonic masculinity but then i see the but then
like you're all like gay as fuck i'm like are you guys gonna make out or like are you touching
him on the ass like that and i'm like looking at my co-workers i'm like is he gay i'm like oh no he's
not gay he's just hanging out with his friends i guess i don't it's called the bromance oh that's
true bromance i love you in the most heterosexual way from like ryan hega
guys are very interesting like how they like i'm i'm sorry but i've been like studying you
like i'm a fucking weirdo i'm just like what the fuck like why are they like like it's so weird
so weird like before i went on my medical leave um because again i'm a i'm a mentor to a lot of
the people in my store um and it is a male dominated field so a lot of uh gentlemen are
not like i'm in their superior and so they'll come to me and talk to about stuff and be like oh
this girl or this guy and our friends and then this happened and then this happened and i'm like
why the why don't you guys just talk about your feelings and then just like oh we don't do that
we're guys and i'm like oh that's a good point you guys never really talk about your real feelings
it's kind of like it's kind of like superficial and i don't know why like i don't excuse me you should
excuse me um have feel like you can have a safe space to talk to your bros about how you feel
like i'm like i'm sitting and listening to this kid tell me about his parents divorce
and i'm like i don't know you that well one two you have like your boys are in the corner over
there you could go talk to them about it not that i like i'm not gonna like not listen to you but
i'm like why are you but then i realize that maybe it maybe it is a cultural thing maybe it is like
a make american cultural thing like you have to be tough and you have to have this air that like
you don't have feelings and stuff and it makes me really sad like i want you to be able to talk
about your feelings men should be able to talk about their fucking feelings especially your feelings
for me you can't see but i like did the cute like tuck my hair behind the ear
fending happens in brazil too yeah i feel like it's a cultural thing but you're not weak
feelings are a fucking normal thing honestly for me when a guy shows his feelings
it shows me a sense of maturity because you're in touch with yourself you touch yourself to me
um uh you're kind of
i don't know i feel like it makes you more open-minded um secret secret for you if you have a girlfriend
or if you want one talk about your feelings but don't be weird about it
being able to talk about your feelings and be vulnerable is a sign of strength in my opinion
exactly i got that cry and riz um yeah not from the get-go don't just like you know chill
like everybody else and then when you get closer and you're like wow i really like this person then
you can be like hey i wasn't feeling so good today because you said this to me and it kind of hurt
my feelings and if the girl immediately starts bitching at you that like oh i wouldn't ever
tell her to shut the fuck up and leave her
sorry i like playing therapist and being a big sis slash mom sometimes
i don't know i just i just like helping people out gotta wait till a few drinks get into no
no you don't fucking get drunk and share your feelings because then it just sounds like word
vomit and creepy took that advice to heart to almost be her girlfriend i think at the ick they're
not the right person precisely is it a therapist or she'd be spitting facts
we have to ask more details to start taking potshots of who i was subconsciously inspired by
yeah it's hard because i know for guys because women can be really bitchy like they can be catty
um not all women but women sometimes they will be passive aggressive and they will use things
you've said to them against you and if that happens leave because they do not care about
your feelings if they're taking really low blows and shots women know how to hit you or it hurts
sometimes and some men too some men i was watching this like tiktok of these women who it was like
pop a balloon if you want to if you don't want to date this guy and it was this like really uh arrogant
like dentist doctor and so they go to interview the first woman and they're like hey so
like why did you pop your balloon like why don't you want to date him and she's like you know he
came across this really arrogant i don't really think that's appropriate i feel like this this and
this and the first thing he said to her was just like who did your teeth because they don't look good
and like that's how he responded he didn't be like oh i'm sorry you feel that way but i'm going to
rebuttal with a valid point insert point here like he just responded the most dickish way and it's like
for every woman that popped their balloon and like let me tell you like they nicely explained
why they weren't attracted to him like one woman said um i feel like your arrogance because you
come up this is like there's a difference between confidence and arrogance and i feel like your
arrogance against would get in the way of you loving me she's like i would be able to love you
but i don't think you'd have enough room to love me and then and she and then she like made some sort
of um i think like illusion i can't remember the english term like she made like a like an
illustration of um not like a physical illustration but like you know what i'm trying to say um
turn to an a yeah like a metaphor of like giving pieces of like her love in a box and him not
being able to like have it and then he illusion was right okay and then he was immediately set
like essentially just started calling her crazy and gaslighting her it was just like um well
he said like i really hear and understand you know get where you're coming from but the way
you said that did not make any sense this and this and this and he was like trying to pick
apart argument instead of just being like no i think i would actually you know have be confident
and then be able to have love for somebody and i was like this dude fucking sucks uh my headphones
died so i can't hear 33 cents feeling better thank you mr tony is as based as ever either
head off for class it's been interesting good have a good time at class pay attention do good in
school get those grades up kiddo but yeah there are guys like oh like if i find the clip i will
show it to you guys like i'll retweet it on my all and be like i hope you're not like this
because i was like wow and mind you these are like gorgeous women and he and he was a nice looking
guy but then like you realize like as he's talking like oh he's an ugly man on the inside though
but so like it's true like men can also be really passive aggressive and kind of pull out stuff
that you wouldn't expect those both sides human beings just suck that's why i have three cats
lonely i'm so lonely didn't you try to mainsplain yeah self-walk yes yes that's exactly what i'm
talking about um it's like these these black women these black this black dude
is this a local no people just mean regardless of gender yeah surrender for yourself a good
friends and chat yeah a hundred hundred percent everybody yeah then nobody nobody escapes that
guys do i have to like respond to every marrow because i do not feel like it i might just like
heart all of them and then call it a day for these marrows i don't think i want to type everything
out i'll leave the vault up go pee oh peace i'll pee in a second go piss girl but like i'm
happy i hope we had like a productive chat i'm sorry if like me being super honest with you and
stuff puts you off i understand i know some people don't like me cries um because i tend to
overshare and yeah and i was like uh he's talking about a period with the fuck girl gross
i know i know you have you guys enjoy the yapping but i mean like sometimes the
the subject matter in which i talk about it people don't like
what i like about you chibi you just did a full workshop fat did i really
holy fuck dude
what the fuck is wrong with me sometime
gets you thinking i like people to be introspective i don't you know i like philosophy a lot
just kind of like think about human nature and all that shit
casual seven-hour yapathon i mean if it's controversial something like that
a tit trigger warning or content warning wouldn't hurt
but like i don't i think we're all adults here and if you hear something you don't
like you just leave i shouldn't have to be like trigger warning i'm talking about blood
i don't i'm sorry i'm not gonna
we're adults i'm not gonna hold your hand for that stuff
and then like oh if it's like really bad like when we were doing like the class of
09 stuff i knew was gonna be edgy so i'm like disclaimer there's gonna be edgy stuff
this probably isn't the stream for you but that's like immediately when i started stream but like
and i did say like guys tmi i'm about to talk about like periods and stuff so like
i didn't preface it and i do usually preface just like kind of subconsciously
say it out loud to you guys like oh i might talk about something you not like might not like in the next
five seconds
she be made for the sake of the future we should have a rule stating we're 18 plus stream
i think that's a given
why should i make why should i have a rule saying i'm an 18 plus stream when it's obvious i'm an
18 plus streamer
you know
like i mean
all right you know not to youtube jannies it isn't they probably yank it if i said that
you should be have you ever considered playing elden ring might be fun i'm not sure if you're
interested in soul series yeah my cat's not named via or anything yeah i fucking love elden ring dude
i'm probably not gonna play it though on stream uh i know strani's playing it soon
18 plus i thought that you were 17.9 jesus
it's already known because can you people get me if it happens it happens if i need to
then i will i'm not gonna do that though that's just silly
like
i think it's obvious from my content when you look at my description uh in the
you know description box below and on my twitter and especially on my alt
that i'm 18 plus look at my fucking outfit dude
look at my outfit do you think i'm user friendly
do you think this is the reason why i haven't been monetized yet
you need to finish up elden ring for the dlc right
youtube hates her look very innocent i'm so innocent i'm so innocent you like
you like my innocence
what's my alt nobody tell him
i thought you were chill bro get the fuck out of here
great to finally meet shibi i love your model and the club you're hella stunning oh thank you
me too i just i want you guys to have your emotes and like i just want to do membership streams
man i want to do the you know the monetization celebration stream that's all i want
well she just had a brainer account content is educational and health and medicine
paces she's good that's true i can literally just switch the thing on this and be like it is
educational because it is we're not talking like i'm literally actually being very educational right
now am i not give us that emotes youtube i'm like sticking
oh right oh right oh she's stepping on my bladder there's no alton bossing say
you don't want the money you just want the celebration stream yeah
pretty much like the money's like i'm not good i'm not gonna lie to you money's nice again i said
if i ever i would not be able to go full time as a streamer unless i relied on you know you for
donations and support and watching me like i'm not gonna fucking pretend like i don't care about
money whatsoever i need to feed my kitties but i am always super fucking thankful anytime someone
does i got a toot i'm afraid if i toot i'll pee because i peed a little when i tooted already
i don't want to toot again
always my favorite boss in eldering
hmm
does it have to be like one of the main bosses or does it have to kind of be like one of the
mini bosses because then i was gonna say the uh what's that fucking thing that jumps around
fucking piss me the fuck off i was so happy when i killed it it's like the night star
fallen thing and you break everything as like a scorpion tail
no it wasn't astell was it the whiteboard no it wasn't astell it was like it was almost like
a horse that would jump around yeah the meteor beast actually really like the design of that
the fallen star beast was actually really beautiful
no i wasn't thinking the falling star beast i'm thinking i was thinking of the one that looks
like a deer for a second um but the falling star beast yes was my favorite um and then the
deer one was also really gorgeous is what i meant to say the ancestor spirit in terms of looks
hell yeah um astell yeah i was fine um
elton dragon monster the ender dragon was pretty cool as well
radigan damn fucking radigan i'm in love with radigan
radigan america who is pretty i just long-haired gingers
and also when they're falling apart and like leaking gold and shit it's pretty sick general adon
it took me forever to beat radon because i was so one it was like this is that was
elton ring was like the second from soft game i played um and so i didn't know how to approach
anything and then i can't like i didn't know any strats like to defeat radon
and i couldn't even like then i looked up like walkthroughs but like how to
fight him then i found like oh you can like cheese like boss i was like what the fuck is
teasing and i just figured out what it was um and then i couldn't even cheese radon properly i was
so fucking shit but then literally after i beat him i like honestly everything changed when i got
the black knife i can't lie i fucking abused the use of the black knife i'm not good at games
i just i don't play games skillfully i am just smart
figured you can use some of the weapons as terrain to eat oh yeah no yeah i knew that
wonk play style what build did you use an elton ring uh i used a
again i haven't played elton ring like a year so i can't remember a lot
but i didn't mean to do that um what is it called it was blood build
i actually i was like a blood and faith build
and i used a lot of arcane too i didn't use rivers of blood
i actually used the um the halo scythe a lot i used halo scythe the black knife
i started off as a confessor because i literally just picked one i didn't know what the fuck to
scale with i didn't know how things scaled i literally elton ring is the first game
i like actively did so much fucking research on all the fucking lore i watched about it all
about like the how the weapons scaled jesus christ i'm like i'm doing math
what am i doing oh yeah use the dragon incantations yeah
oh what the fuck did i just step on oh boomie what the hell what are you doing down there
oh we're just hanging out
yeah so it was like a faith blood build oh my god i got two please don't pee
i did not pee we're good
and he cools breath for the scarlet raw it was clutched so often yeah i did use that
drank this faith yeah fancy flame should be base clutching button
yeah uh i would probably i don't want to embarrass myself by playing other ring online
i mean like on stream i mean after strani does because strani is like such a fucking
good gamer she like hundred percent shit and i'm like looking at her watching her streams i'm like
jesus fuck why am i so shit at games and like i've played so many games for a while and i'll
actively try to be better at them but i just fucking suck man like
like like i played hundreds of hours of valorant in csgo and i still was a fucking silver okay
but then like again i but then i was like nasty a destiny in cod so i don't understand
i think valorant that's the issue listen i needed a fix i needed something else that wasn't csgo
and i liked the concept of heroes with like abilities on top of the csgo mechanics or just
counter strike mechanics in general um i probably won't i was not a valet girl um i probably won't
play fps is on stream because everybody fucking loses their marbles when streamers do i keep just
smack the mic again i'm sorry um like how you guys bullied azura into not boy tips three dollars and
thirty three cents she be i saw you play another craps treasure and decided i was gonna try it
i just finished the game while watching your stream and i hope you finish it because there's
plenty of fun dialogue to dub might be difficult though sorry you beat it in six hours are you
fucking shitting me thank you i just want kms even more
i don't know if i'm gonna finish another craps treasure on stream because the
fucking input lag on my controller is so shit and i hate it and i'm not playing with keyboard
i wish i could speedrun games that'd be fun
the leafy videos i would suck at surf i would try to do surf i don't like gary's mod
oh yeah it gives me like a second behind
oh baby a triple miss morrigan tip three dollars and thirty three cents trying to feed the three
percent of us in chat could you please tell me i've been a very well behaved girl for you today
morrigan you've been such a well behaved little sweet girl today shout out to the three percent
he such a good girl prop hunt ttt ttt hands down bitch i played so much
trouble and terror is down ttt was my fucking jam and then prop hunt and then murder after that
that's how the order goes i watched a lot of um vanos gmod uh and like the c nanners crew gmod
should we play some gmod i would so play gmod i would i'm trying i i'm so tempted to buy the
girls all gmod so we can play ttt or um prop hunt prop hunt must be so fucking funny
c nanners is a deep cut
prop hunt was hysterical it's so weird like adapted it for cod i'm like that's not the same
gmod yeah gmod's only like 10 bucks honestly i wish the price would drop it should be like five now
two and gmod doesn't give you guys any tech issues i feel like gmod would work so well
well tell the other girls to buy gmod because i'm not gonna i don't want to bully them into getting it
chibi go to bed all right i should it's almost midnight what's tomorrow
friday
i have asmr stream i still hear right the any right bullet points from my asmr stream
i need to do like a i haven't i've been putting it off i need to do some sort of um
kind of like kind of direction and what i wanted to go in like i have the idea and i got all the
stuff and like i can just like add a little bit but i kind of just want a focused stream
because i feel like that would be beneficial um like a focused asmr stream that isn't let's
so i don't go off on tangents for like five hours and it's like a five hour asmr stream
the majority of it is me just whispering really stupidly
this
summer sales like a week away okay you're fucking right i'm buying it all for them
proper gmod murder that'd be murder we'd be so funny
murder murder murder was like the og among us you know
well here's to my new fav dom bun bun gives head who said you could touch my head
who the fuck gave you permission to touch me get your filthy paws away from my hair
you know how hard it is to curl my hair every day
it's naturally this curly but still to get it in these nice ringlets
hide and seek yeah
none of my mods are awake right now so i have to i can't i'm too and i'm too lazy to control you
and tell you guys to fuck off
yeah you're the ones who give me head all right don't forget it how big of a curling iron do you
have uh it's as huge big as uh one of you
cost my curl yeah my hair is prehensile don't forget that that's how i can dance with fit
or curling iron this is two of the harem exactly
why we can do whatever we want then
don't don't no don't let me get to your head stop it stop it get some help
can i get a hoy um
oh
i'll never sleep if she be streaming
yeah uh pookie is uh she's not a like a mod mod she's just one of my friends
but you should be scared of her she's a cute little emo goat so be fucking afraid
me
all right what the fuck am i doing
i'm gonna check my email real quick to see if i got accepted
no i don't need to do an email go away oh hi boomi don't stick your ass in my face dude
you
you too please oh my sensory toys came in
i am excited
time to be a little autistic girl on the internet
boomi can you please my cats are getting a little finicky because i'm not giving them
attention big boy big boy what's the matter use my mommy's attention and give you kisses
oh my big boy you're so handsome you're a handsome man you're so handsome
thank you for my kisses and i depend oh if you jump in for a boy
i love you even if your your pouch looks like a pair of titties even if you have a cup of titties
boomi looks like he has titties his little primordial pouch is so fucking thick and he's not
even like a fat cat he's very active but i'm like why is your pouch like you can see his little
nippies i love him so much he's been getting a lot more snuggly lately normally he's like
kind of a more chill cat like he'll like he'll like hang out with you but he doesn't like
snuggle with you and perv like hysterically like fia um rena do put you on the ground because
you're getting a little bit walking around should be me not down
wait does somebody say something inappropriate do i have a ball toggle no
bro stop mentioning other shimmers i'm prompted who
i feel like there aren't many people who can be with you either well it's not like
don't get it twisted it's not a competition to us we're just hanging out and having fun sweetheart
like we don't we're not in the scene because we're like we're about to take
everybody's fucking they're gonna be all our we're gonna be all their oh shes and
everybody's gonna love us more than everybody else no
like we're not doing it
competitively we're doing it because we like streaming we like spending time with you
i see loves are odysons amy loves her bros i love my harem zura loves her bleeding hearts
i wish you would change the name it's just too fucking long to say strontia loves her reeflings
mercy loves her snippets
we're not like trying to collect you all like your fucking toys i'm starting to sound like
i'm drunk because i'm tired and i'm like my eyes are like heavy and that's why i'm like
my eyes closed sometimes not enough
no i don't love you don't stop stop it i can't get hurt again
pression though i'm telling i will do a 24 hour stream i want to do it for the donathan
guys give me ideas of what to do for donathan in terms of like although mine's not till like
september but um but like in terms of like rewards or like activities to do like i'm
obviously gonna do handcams probably like a thigh cam towards like the end of the donathan um
probably sleep on stream a little sleep moment you guys can just like i'll have like i'll be like
snuggling with the three dio you guys can like hear my heartbeat and like hear me snore
i snore when the air is really fucking dry maybe it will be september so maybe i won't snore as much
every hundred dollars my cat gets a treat yep they love their greenies finish my immortal well
i was gonna finish my immortal anyways but yeah like you know throw throw some of your ideas at me
bath stream that would be fun actually i don't know how i do that though i probably have to like try
like because like the only laptop i have is a macbook and i don't is there like vtube studio for
macbook and then i have to use like maybe i need like a little travel microphone and then
yeah i don't know
grant the outline for your ASMR and stream yeah it'll be fun
it's really like how you talk to us when you walk away from your pc but in the bath
guys hold you want to see this is my bathroom's over here i can really stand up for shit
bathroom i'm all the way over here
did you even hear me
you can almost hear me yeah go pee go piss girl play armor core six oh yeah
you can hear me was i like a little why would i be so
your bunny girlfriend takes a bath except she's across the house yelling at you
i'm like a cruelty squad
yeah we couldn't hear you do you can do your bit
are you trying to trick me you're trying to trick me you can trick me i can't be tricked
bitch i like how i'm looking over here i should probably flip my model
because i'm like not looking at the chat i'm like looking at my monitor on this side
it's a very human video game oh i remember that reference this is a very human machine
it's a very human design
babe i forgot my towel get it you know i literally forgot my towel
this morning when i went to shower because i had taken my old towel off and i'm like
okay i need to do a load of towels and then i forgot to put a fresh towel back on
and so i had to walk out on nakey i like kind of like shake myself off like a dog
squeeze out my hair throw it up in a little my little uh little dry hair turban that you do
you know i have like a little satin um in microfiber towel tie up in my little little head wrap um
um and then i had a waddle my little cold wet ass to the my closet to grab a towel and fia and
boomie are in between my legs and i'm like i'm gonna die i'm wet i'm cold i'm afraid i'm gonna
trip over a child and i was able to tell myself uh this is how my dog feels after a bad session
i remember i had to like bathe fia in the sink she's really tiny so i can just put her in the
sink boomie you'd have to put in the tub um but we put her in the sink and i always recommend if
you're gonna bathe a cat or even a dog make sure um you put like a towel actually under them and then
when you fill it up with water because they can't they freak out when they don't have grip because
when they have grip they'll actually just kind of stand there uh so if you lay something down
they'll feel a lot better um so i put uh the towel in the sink filled up with you know lukewarm water
and she just looked like such a little wet rat i wonder if i can find a i can't did i take a
picture of her i don't think i was able to because i was just in my hands are full and then um i have
a towel warmer that um i got for christmas and and it's like i was i threw a towel in it and
i took her out she was all bundled up in a little perrito and a towel and she was just like screaming
and stuff but it was cute and i dried her off um this is when she um her legs didn't work so i had
to bathe her because she couldn't like move maneuver her body to bathe herself and sometimes
she would have to go accidents but i'm a good mama i clean up after her
can we get a wet cat pick next time excuse me
perrito are you next to what
i don't know that view
yeah it's actually good advice yeah cats actually they start when they start to scrabble everywhere
and they can't get a full hole they freak out and then dogs do that too
some angry video games review bro i'm too tired to understand what you're saying
play et for the Atari i'm gonna go into the desert and dig one of them up
i can't
do you ever get like a tickle
on your butt cheek my butt cheek is tickling am i okay am i losing it
oh it's just a tag from my underwear i'm like what's tickling me
he
fuck the mimosa get offline fuck i have to fart again
god damn it why do i have to stream for so long fia can you stop scratching my chair
you can literally jump she just wants me to pick her up you fucking nugget she's like a ferret by
the way fia is like she moves like a ferret she looks like a ferret she's a fucking cute though
oh you just pop you just pop and purr you remind me of ferret girl
oh fia why are you so cute fia's the cutest cat oh my god i love you so much are you so fucking
oh i love you oh i love you so much i'm so happy you can walk again
you rumblin yeah come on hang out with me you haven't hung out with me all day actually it's
only been boomi and reina that have hung out with me i got a fia in my lap and i'm feeling good
okay
all right i'm gonna raid you sure she ain't a ferret she's part ferret it's funny because she
like stretches out she's a very long cat but she's very tiny she's like she's kind of has like
was had stunted growth because of her um a weird random disease she had for a bit so she's very
small but i love it she's like a kitten um fia oh my god she also smiles when you pet her she's so
cute oh you're so cute oh my fia line they're so cute um ferrets are just cat snakes um but she likes
to like stretch out and have her belly rubbed and she'll just lay on her back and to stretch out
her legs really far and we do this thing now um i'll take her because i had to move her body around
because i didn't want her muscles to atrophy so much so i would have to like work her muscles
when she couldn't walk and move and her legs didn't work so i'd take her little arms i'd put like
right under her armpits and i would like push her arms up and she would stretch out her little
paws and like reach for the sky and we go big stretch and then she loves it and she still
does it now like she's so fucking cute we'll go big stretch and she'll get already she'll get
already i'll have to take a picture of it are you are you rumbling are you making air biscuits
she's like the most snuggly cat i've ever met i remember the rescue where it was like almost
didn't want to let her go because um she was and this is a rescuer that's like rescued so many
cats in her lifetime and she was currently looking after like 50 cats and a lot of dogs as well um
she's just like i didn't even want to give her up because she's like the most loving cat i've
ever met and fia is seriously like the loviest cat oh she's so good she's truly the deathbed
companion
she also likes to lick you she's like a little puppy dog she wait when i wake up she runs over to me
she runs over all excited and starts purring up a storm and then starts licking my face
she licks my nose and i'm like thank you for the nose licks your breath really stinks
and then i'll give you a little smooch and a boob on the snout
i love animals of all sorts yeah i love my cats they're so good you're so good
you're so good usually they're all around me right now so i can tell they're telling me to go to bed
so i will go to bed oh no my snoot uh fia and boomi actually don't mind like they're
they don't care if their noses are touched they don't care if their paws are touched
they're very um fia just reached up at me with both her little hands what are you doing i'm petting
you you don't have to reach for me oh do you want a big stretch oh big stretch you good girl
oh my god i'm gonna fucking cry you're so fucking cute why are you grabbing my titty
she's like
guys i can't wait to have the cat cam back so you guys can see what the fuck is going on
she's really just like on her side on my lap her she has one paw on the top of my boob and one
paw on the bottom of my boob and she's just like holding on for dear life for some reason
why are you so cute why are you so cute you're so cute i want to fucking die
i'm gonna get diabetes from this thing
i'm playing audio over your cat i'm like oh my god oh my god you're so cute you're so
so cute oh my god and rena just comes over and she looks at me like i'm fucking cheating on her
she literally looks at me like uh she caught me in bed with another moment
reluctantly saying tipped 13 dollars and 37 cents thank you reluctantly hey shebe i fell asleep after
the collab but thank you for such a hilarious stream oh i'm glad you enjoyed it no not those
cheeks oh i wasn't gonna say those cheeks but yeah no my cheeks are hurting too that's for sure
you need to be snuggled like a cat oh if he has like a cute pink nose and she has like
cute little pink beans oh my god she's she's just a little girl and she likes to move her
little hands around you want to do another big stretch oh my god oh my god you're gonna say hi
the terrific she's really just flopping right now like a fucking ferret
okay she be time to end the stream um who to rate oh is there still on oh is there still on
look at us the endurance corp oh
okay that's uh no one that oh cool cool and it's not a lot of people like up at this time
there'll be more streamers i'm calling a lot of people so i can just like redirect
okay please don't tell me that like azure is ending soon too i can't remember if we're in the same
time zone or not i think no azure usually stays up to like 2 a.m eastern time sometimes i've
accidentally like woken up and i like look at the discord she's like fucking talking and i'm like
girl are you awake yeah there is a est she always like sometimes i'll be awake and i'll be talking
to her and she's like why are you still awake i'm like why the fuck are you still awake she's
like well i'm my night owl and i'm like oh yeah you're right
can i see me thank you for the stream
there's too much i just like really weird deja vu for a second all right i'll be seeing you
i'm gonna go pee and um more like me out here thinking that she be on the east coast because
i am on the fucking east coast i am on the east coast you guys haven't even been able to tell where
i'm from yet
sorry i'm putting my cat okay bye i need to sneeze
oh
no i want to wait
okay later
so
even feel the interesting
you
You